Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Wir sind's, die Freakshow, der Podcast,
wo es kein eingefahrenes Konzept gibt, wie die Sendung begonnen wird und die
Leute begrüßt werden oder ob man erst die Leute vorstellt oder die Hörer begrüßt
oder die Sonne grüßt oder sonst irgendwas macht. Es ist alles totales Chaos.
Und somit kommen wir auch schon zum Ende.
So viel zum Feedback. Ja, hallo, wir sind's, Freakshow Nummer 283.
Wir haben den 5. September 2024.
Es ist immer noch Sommer, zumindest in Berlin. Es ist heiß.
Wetteranzeige sagt 26,9 Grad, ist aber draußen. Und hier drin ist, weiß ich nicht.
Steigt sowohl die Stimmung als auch die Temperatur.
Das stimmt. Oh, ich habe mir noch gar kein Getränk geholt.
Was für eine Unterlassung. Naja, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall,
ihr habt es schon gehört, Ralf ist am Start. Hallo Ralf.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Ja, die Konstante, also nach mir, ja auch eine Konstante, würde ich sagen.
Und dann haben wir noch eine Variable.
Roddy ist nämlich gerade im Urlaub und ich glaube wir können auch sagen wo,
nämlich der ist dann auch mal in die Ukraine abgedüst.
Das ist einfach ein sehr populäres Reiseziel mittlerweile, da wollen ganz viele
hin, vor allem aus dem Osten leider.
Aber wir haben würdigen Ersatz gefunden und begrüßen Malik in unserer Runde.
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen bei der Friedschau.
Hallo. Ich muss hier mal die Technik ausprobieren. Hallo zusammen.
Es gibt geile Mute-Tasten. Ich bin ganz begeistert. Schön hier zu sein.
Das ist schon nett, ne?
Ja, das ist perfekt.
Ich kannte ja deinen Vornamen schon, bevor ich dich kannte.
Also nicht, dass ich wusste, dass das deiner ist. Aber der Name Malik ist ja
in der Literatur verbreitet, also zumindest in einem besonderen Buch,
das weißt du sicherlich.
Das weiß ich, das ist, finde ich, auch die einzig sinnvolle Referenz.
Malik ist ja der Chef von den Sebani und die Sebani sind im Koran die Höllenwärter
und als alter Metal-Typ, der ich ja bin, als ich das gelesen habe,
dachte ich, alles klar, ich stehe ja so da, kommt Mohammed und ich so,
du kommst hier nicht vorbei.
Genau so ist das. Und seitdem wird das natürlich dauernd zitiert.
Aber habe ich auch erst mit Ü40 gelernt. Danke Wikipedia.
Okay, aber du weißt auch, auf welches Buch ich mich beziehe.
Ne, gibt es noch eins.
Wie noch eins?
Außer den Koran.
Ja.
Ja, ja, okay, ich rede vom Koran.
Achso, darüber hatte ich keine Kenntnis, das habe ich nicht gelesen.
Nein, im Illuminatus von Robert Anton Wilson spielt Matt Malick eine Rolle. Rolle, doch.
Wie schön.
Für dich für sicherlich einen Grund, mal dieses Buch einzudocken.
Ich hab's ja tatsächlich mal gelesen. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das geschafft
hab. Ich bin sehr schlecht im Buchlesen, generell, grundsätzlich.
Und auch immer schlechter geworden. Aber ich hab tatsächlich mal Illuminatus
gelesen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das etwas ist, was man Leuten empfehlen kann.
Aber Leute tun das. Ist nicht bei allen gut ausgegangen, wie wir wissen.
Wer überhaupt nicht weiß, wovon wir reden, also Illuminatus ist ja so ein bisschen
so, hat den Ruf, so das Verschwörungsbuch zu sein.
Aber nicht im Sinne von ernst gemeinte, richtige Verschwörung,
sondern er spielt ja quasi mit dieser Idee der Verschwörung.
Und entwirft also ein Universum unserer Welt, was einfach nur noch irre ist.
Und ich glaube, das Buch führt, ich kann es nicht wirklich quantifizieren,
aber ich weiß, ich war überrollt.
Man hat die ersten 100 Seiten gelesen und fragt sich die ganze Zeit,
was sind die wichtigen Personen?
Was ist der eigentliche Strang? Wann kehrt irgendwann ein Element wieder?
Was gehört hier zusammen? Ich werde wahnsinnig. Und das ist irgendwie glaube
ich auch so, dass das Prinzip dieses Buches, ich kann dir zum Beispiel auch
überhaupt nicht mehr sagen, was Matt Malick eigentlich für eine Rolle spielt,
weil das einfach das Buch, das irgendwann,
wenn du dann so bei den Nazi-Horden am Boden eines Sees in der Nähe von Nürnberg
angekommen bist, da sprengt sich sowieso alles ab.
Welche Memes, die man so kennt, kommen denn daher?
Also ist irgendwie die 23 ursprünglich, weil die 42 ist der Anhalter und so?
Also sagen wir mal so, Illuminatus ist eine Pop-Melange aus so einer Zeit,
in der dieses ganze Verschwörungsding eigentlich erst so richtig losging und
sich ein bisschen gegenseitig befruchtet hat.
Und mir ist selbst gerade erst vor ein paar Wochen nochmal was gewahr geworden,
als ich begonnen habe, ich habe es leider noch nicht abgeschlossen,
aber es ist relativ umfangreich, als ich begonnen habe eine Dokumentation nachzuschauen
und jetzt rede ich langsam,
weil mir natürlich wieder ums Verrecken alle Namen nicht einfallen.
Lustigerweise heißt die Dokumentation Can't Get You Out of My Head,
also wie dieses Lied von Kylie, Blinkenleids Kylie, genau.
Und was hat sie geleistet, um Blinkenleids Kylie sein zu dürfen?
Naja, das Lied Can't get you out of my head, das Video dazu,
tanzt sie vor blinkenden Gebäuden und wann kam dieses Video raus?
Zeitgleich mit Blinkenlights Also im Herbst 2001,
haben wir irgendwie Blinkenlights eingeschaltet und dann kam Kylie und hat gesagt,
Blinkenlights ist gut, hier, ich mach mal ein Welthit und tanze also nicht vor
unseren Fenstern, aber Aber halt...
Ich ahne eine Verschwörung.
Ja, eine. Jetzt kommen wir langsam zu dem Punkt. So, und jetzt gibt es eine...
Dokumentation, die heißt Can't Get You Out of My Head und diese Dokumentation,
ist von na Gott, was ist das denn jetzt?
Ich werde verrückt.
Ralf, du bist doch hier der Beauftragte für jegliche Dinge, die Menschen jemals
kreativ erschaffen haben.
Adam Curtis.
Ah. Ja?
Adam Curtis. Sagt euch das was?
Der Name sagt mir was.
Okay, also das sollte euch etwas sagen. Adam Curtis halte ich für eine der wichtigeren
Personen der journalistischen Zeitgeschichte.
Den sollte man sich auf jeden Fall mal genauer anschauen. Das habe ich auch
schon getan. Also Adam Curtis ist BBC war das.
Oder?
Ja, genau. Also Adam Curtis ist auch für seine Stimme und seine Moderation sehr
bekannt. Das ist ja immer sehr verbreitet so etwas.
Und hat ein paar weltbewegende wegende Dokumentationen schon gemacht.
Also unter anderem hat er das ganze Aufkommen des islamischen Fundamentalismus
aus Ägypten und so weiter in den 70er Jahren.
Da gibt es irgendwie eine Dokumentationsserie und das ist irgendwie eine seiner,
bekanntesten überhaupt.
Ich kann auch noch mal kurz schauen, wie die hieß.
Die hatte auch immer ganz tolle Namen dafür. Ich erinnere sie nur gerade nicht,
aber ich schaue mal kurz nach.
Kurze Frage zu den Shownotes. Werfen wir die einfach in den Hauptkanal?
Ja, wir haben keinen separaten Kanal dafür. Das ist etwas, wo wir vielleicht
von euch nochmal was lernen können.
Also wir werfen die in den Hauptkanal?
In den Hauptkanal und ich suche danach das raus, was irgendwie nur,
was da nicht reingehört.
Wie heißt denn das nochmal? Das war nicht Hyper-Normalization sondern das war
noch ein älteres Ding Gott,
The Power of Nightmares von 2004, also das ist sozusagen sehr interessant,
also wer sich schon immer mal über dieses Aufkommen des Islamismus in der arabischen
Welt und des Neokonservativismus in den USA,
weil es hängt auch immer alles zusammen.
Und das glaube ich seine bisher, nee stimmt gar nicht, stopp,
das war seine zweitberühmteste Sache davor, 2002, The Century of the Self,
damit ging es eigentlich los.
Also er hat auch vorher schon ein paar Sachen gemacht, aber das sind,
sagen wir mal so, die, die man gesehen haben muss.
The Century of the Self 2002, The Power of Nightmares.
Da lernt man einfach schnell sehr viel Weltgeschichte.
Also das ist einfach der Shortcut zu World Geopolitics und wenn man sich das
anschaut, dann ist man auch gleich so,
oh ah okay, alles klar, ich verstehe die Tagesschau auf einmal besser.
Weißt du?
Weil du auf einmal diesen Kontext kriegst für, warum hauen die sich da in Israel
die ganze Zeit auf die Koppel?
Was ist da mit Ägypten am Start und was?
Wieso werden die sich da nicht einig? Und da ist sehr viel davon drin.
So und jetzt zurück zu der anderen Geschichte Can't Get You Out of My Head,
das ist halt eine neue Sache und hier greift er tatsächlich diese Geschichte
der Verschwörungserzählung auf und zu meiner persönlichen Überraschung fängt
er schon in der ersten Folge mit dem Diskordianismus an.
Und erzählt tatsächlich die Story von diesen beiden Vögeln, die diesen Diskurrianismus
sich haben einfallen lassen.
Was ja eher so eine humoristische, so ein Pan auf Religion und Gesellschaft ist.
Wir machen jetzt hier mal unsere eigene Religion und Ere ist die Göttin des Chaos.
So die ist jetzt hier, ne, eine Frau ist jetzt mal unsere höchste Göttin und
ihr zu Ehren essen wir irgendwie freitags keine Hotdogs und so weiter.
Also es ist alles ja so ein bisschen albern gehalten, spielt aber eben auch
schon viel mit diesem ganzen klassischen Verschwörungsdinger mit 2,
3, 2 plus 3 gleich 5, Pentagon und irgendwelchen Machtwesen im See.
Und es geht dann halt auch wiederum in der Referenz zu hier so zu Tulu und ähnlichen.
Verschwörungsgeschichten von wie heißt er nochmal gleich hier?
Lovecraft also mysteriöse Welterzählungen so was passiert wirklich die großen Alten und das hat halt,
das wurde halt alles im Illuminatus zusammengerührt.
Und jetzt kommt also Adam Curtis und legt die Geschichte aus und ich war sehr
überrascht, weil klar, Diskordialismus spielt mit Verschwörungstheorien und
ich weiß auch, dass es in Illuminatus eingeflossen ist,
aber er beginnt dort seine Story mehr oder weniger.
Und die erste wirkliche politische Verschwörungsgeschichte ist dann quasi die
Erzählung von so einem rechtskonservativen Heini in den USA in Bezug auf den Kennedy-Mord.
Und da nimmt das sozusagen seinen Lauf.
Und dann stellst du fest, und das erzählt er in dieser Dokumentation,
dass der Typ, der die Principia Discordia gemacht hat, der Cary Thornley,
war bekannt und wollte einen Film machen über Lee Harvey Oswald,
der Kennedy ermordet hat.
Alles kommt zusammen.
Aber das ist halt wohl recherchiert und wirklich interessant und ich bin leider
noch nicht durch mit der Doku, weil das ist sowieso ein Neunteiler und jeder
ist eine Stunde und so weiter,
aber du kannst einfach dir mal so Weltstory erzählen lassen von Adam Curtis.
So, das war jetzt ein sehr großer Spannungsbogen, aber da ist eine Menge zu
holen und das ist echt jetzt schon mal meine Empfehlung an alle,
schaut euch bitte die Dokumentation von Adam Curtis Hört es an,
ihr werdet es nicht bereuen.
Das ist nicht irgendwas, sondern das sind vielleicht mit die wichtigsten Dokumentationen,
die überhaupt jemals gemacht wurden über so Geopolitik.
Um jetzt die Klammer zu Malik wieder zuzulösen.
Matt Malik.
Genau, zu Matt Malik. Genau, da habe ich nämlich jetzt mal gerade nachgeforscht.
Eine der faszinierenden Figuren in der Elaminatus-Trilogie.
Diese Figur ist eine moderne Version von Hassan Isaba, dem historischen Begründer der Assassinen-Sekte.
Richtig, genau.
In der Trilogie ist er der Anführer einer fiktiven Gruppe von Anarchisten und
Revolutionären, bekannt als die Justified Ancients of Moomoo.
Jetzt weiß ich endlich, wovon KLF eigentlich kommt.
Gesungen haben, da kommt alles zusammen. Das sind ja auch überzeugte Discordia,
KLF, die Copyright Liberation Front mit K wiederum, das K aus Kallistie,
aus der Prinzipia Discordia,
was ja griechisch für die allerschönste ist, was die Aufschrift war auf dem goldenen Apfel,
den die Göttin Eris der Hochzeitsgesellschaft beim Zeus geschickt hat,
als verräterisches Geschenk, Weil das Chaos nicht auf die Party eingeladen wurde.
Und dann fingen sie an, sich alle um diesen goldenen Apfel zu zanken. Der Zank-Apfel.
Und darauf steht K-Listie. Deswegen ist das K eben auch so das Symbol für das Non, für das Copy Left.
Also für das Non-Copyright. So All Rights Reversed.
Und das, verstehst du? Das ist eine ganz große Sache.
Aber Tim, erklär mir doch mal eins. In dem ganzen Konstrukt fehlt ja noch ein kleines Element.
Wenn ich auf der Autobahn unterwegs bin, da in Nordrhein-Westfalen,
dann sehe ich immer wieder diese LKWs, auf denen steht riesengroß Discordia.
Und immer muss ich dann an dich denken.
Und ich halte auch das für ein Konstrukt, das irgendwo absichtlich erschaffen wurde.
Die Meta-Ebene hat überall ihre Finger drin.
Siehste? Ich wusste es. Also auch Logistikunternehmen.
Also KLF, das war echt meine Jugend. Das war so meine Abi-Zeit rum.
Und man wird jetzt ja wirklich alt und hört nur noch die Musik,
die man auch irgendwie als Jugendlicher schon gehört hat, wir kommen ja vielleicht
hinterher noch dazu, aber KLF, das war wirklich geiler Scheiß,
als das damals rauskam, das war auf so vielen Ebenen fantastisch.
Also du kennst das doch als Musiker, ist ja doch KLF als Projekt auch bekannt.
Oder? Ja, es gibt auch dieses kleine Buch, ist das das, was du hier gerade,
nee, How to make a number one?
Genau, How to make a number one Hit irgendwie.
Das hab ich mal gelesen.
Genau.
Auch super gut übrigens.
Genau, dieser Drummond und der andere Typ, das sind ja so zwei verrückte Vögel,
halt auch überzeugte Discordier,
die halt, die hassen die Musikindustrie und sie haben dann dieses Buch geschrieben
und dann haben sie nach diesem Buch ihr Projekt sozusagen auch durchgezogen
und hatten ja ihre Number One Hits und zwar mehrere, ne?
Last Train to Transcentral und all diese ganzen Sachen und episch und wenn du dann halt…
die Musik hörst und dann kommt das nämlich, we're justified and we're ancient.
Und dann im Hintergrund der Chor.
Also diese ganze koreanische Verschwörungsmythos mit irgendwie Illuminators
und Lovecraft und das volle Programm.
Alles zusammengerührt in einer ganzen großen Pop-Scheiße, mit der sie die Musikindustrie ficken.
Und KLF steht halt für Copyright Liberation Front.
Und das ist einfach, Ich staune auch manchmal, was das alles ausgelöst hat.
Nur weil die beiden Typen da irgendwann mal auf der Bowlingbahn standen und
dachten, lass mal eine Religion gründen.
Nice.
Aber am Ende sind wir vielleicht auch schuld an dem ganzen Kram.
Weil irgendwie die Welt will Scheiße glauben.
Haben wir jetzt gerade auch in Thüringen und in Sachsen gesehen, dieses Wochenende.
Wahlen, müssen wir uns nicht groß drüber unterhalten, ist natürlich alles ganz
furchtbar, aber war auch absehbar, hat das auch glaube ich keinen wirklich überrascht,
also wenn man da jetzt sagt so, oh, das kommt aber jetzt überraschend,
so, wie hieß der Stein nochmal?
Wo deine Amazon Postanschrift ist. Also,
Dieses, die Welt ist gerade in so einem Wahn und ich weiß nicht,
ob dieser Wahn sich beliebig steigert oder ob das nur so eine Phase ist.
Ich glaube ja generell an Phasen.
Ich glaube in dem Fall auch an eine Phase und das ist ja kein Zufall,
dass in Zeiten großer Wandlungen,
sag ich mal sowas wie Klimaerwärmung und Finanzkrisen und Corona und sowas,
die Unsicherheit um sich greift und Leute sich dann an Strohhalme klammern und
irgendwie ist mein Gefühl,
das ist der Ausdruck von alle klammern sich an Strohhalme.
Also als psychologisches Phänomen einer unsicheren Zeit, dann sich zu retten
auf, egal ob es logisch oder unlogisch ist, auf irgendetwas, was Sicherheit gibt.
Und ich glaube dieses, ja früher war doch alles besser, ist ja etwas,
was Sicherheit gibt. Auch wenn dieses früher nie wieder herzustellen ist.
Und auch nie besser war.
Und auch wahrscheinlich nie besser war. Also ich meine, das Nazi früher sowieso
nicht, aber vielleicht das Kindheitsnostalgie früher.
Ja, ja, klar.
Genau, also sowas gibt es ja auch. Aber es ist auch eine Art von Realitätsflucht.
Nur die eine ist halt menschenfeindlich und die andere nicht.
Also ich vermute so etwas, denn so habe ich mir das zusammen konstruiert als Matt Malick.
Matt Malick, der Vorsitzende der Assassinen hier.
Ja, es ist irgendwie, also es ist lustig, dass überall, wo der Name auftaucht,
ist auf jeden Fall Blut und Gewalt. Ich begrüße das sehr.
Man muss das alles im Metal-Kontext sehen. Dann macht das komplett Sinn.
Wahrscheinlich, ich bin ja einfach nur Version 3 und wurde dann logischerweise
in der Metal-Szene abgeladen. Wir kommen da noch zu.
Wir kommen da noch zu. So, es ist jetzt, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
dein zweiter Auftritt hier in der Freakshow.
Ja.
Du warst ja schon mal in der ersten Qualifikationsrunde. Am 2. November 2017.
Damals mit Huckel und Roddy und Clemens und meiner Wenigkeit.
Da haben wir uns über die Subscribe unterhalten übrigens. Das können wir heute auch nochmal machen.
Berliner Leistungswasser hieß die Sendung. Und da hast du bestimmt auch schon
ein bisschen was über dich erzählt.
Bestimmt.
Aber das ist ja ein bisschen her. Sieben Jahre, um genau zu sein.
Wahnsinn.
Lief wohl nicht so gut.
Ich schiebe es auf die Entfernung von Aachen nach Berlin. A bis B ist manchmal 600, 700 Kilometer.
Ja, nee, ich meine aber, fragt mich, ich komme.
Genau, aber du bist ja, vielleicht erzählen wir doch aber trotzdem nochmal ein
bisschen was über dich, weil wir ja auch neue Hörer haben, die vor sieben Jahren
noch nicht alles auswendig gelernt haben.
Das soll es geben, Malik, deswegen musst du schon nochmal ein bisschen erzählen.
Also du bist ja in der Gestaltung und in der Musik unterwegs,
da gibt es ja einiges zu berichten.
Das hast du sehr schön subsummiert, aber es ist ein bisschen komplizierter als
das. Deswegen habe ich dann auch mal eine Homepage gemacht.
Malik-aziz.de sind Show Notes. Ihr seht da so eine Seite voller Kacheln.
Jede dieser Kacheln ist ein Projekt, irgendwas, was ich mache.
Und ich habe das gemacht, um auf Partys dieser Frage zu entgehen.
Ja, was machst du denn so eigentlich? Und früher wäre die Antwort gewesen,
ja ich bin Designer von Beruf, ich habe Design studiert mal in jungen Jahren,
bin jetzt auch schon 50 und danach ist es aber irgendwo hinmeandert und zwar
überall hin so ein bisschen, was mit Medien könnte man sagen und wenn man mal
auf die Homepage klickt, dann sieht man,
damit ich auch nicht vergesse, kann ich mal durchgehen, also man sieht da so
schlicht und ergreifend, das ist so der Design Business, Corporate Design, Grafik Design.
Du hast Ultraschall falsch geschrieben.
Ja, jeder kann was.
Das wird nicht mit großem Binnen-S geschrieben.
Das ist, die einen sagen so, die anderen sagen so.
Der Kampf ist noch ongoing.
Lass mich dann mal die UI weitermachen. Okay, dann fangen wir mal oben an.
Dann habe ich noch mit Apps was zu tun.
Auch darüber wird noch zu sprechen sein, nämlich den Ladefuchs und den Parkfuchs.
Ich habe den Parkfuchs hier gar nicht drin. Könnte man nicht auch noch mal reinmachen?
So, und dann habe ich noch, ich mache noch so Musik mit so einer Band.
Damals war es eine andere. Jetzt heißt sie Dark mit 2K.
Dark.Band. Direkt mal hier Instagram und so, ihr könnt Sachen anklicken.
So ganz klassisch mit Rockerlady und...
Genau, in dem Fall Kim mit Sängerin und die anderen drei sind von meiner alten
Band Start a Revolution mit rübergewandert.
Corona hat die alte Band so ein bisschen zerfickt und unser Sänger ist ja der Bierkapitän jetzt.
Also Start a Revolution hieß die alte Band. Der Sänger und Bandgründer Patrick
hat irgendwann in Corona entschieden, dass man auf Malle mit,
Biersongs ja sehr viel Geld machen kann. Das ist das, was jeder sagt.
Ja, das ist ja so simpel, das kann ich auch.
Und er hat es halt gemacht. Und hat dann den Der Bierkapitän. Könnt ihr mal gucken.
Bierkapitän.
Das ist auch der Malle-Sommerhit 2022. Was?
22? Nee, vorher. Genau. Und dann hat das ganze Ding, er hat das halt durchgezogen
und macht jetzt halt nichts anderes mehr als der Bierkapitän sein.
Da gibt es übrigens auch, ihr wisst von nichts.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. In den Videos könnt ihr mich auch rumtanzen sehen.
Ich supporte meine Freundin natürlich, wo ich kann.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, ernsthaft. Es funktioniert halt. Muss man mögen, sag ich mal,
aber Patrick, bester Mann.
Genau. Und das heißt, dann war das mit Star The Revolution so ein bisschen schwierig
mit dem Songwriter, Bandgründer und der Stimme, wenn die dann nicht da ist.
Dann kam Corona und dann war irgendwie klar, okay, die anderen haben gesagt,
ey, wir machen so gerne zusammen Musik, aber wir können das so nicht weitermachen.
Gerade weil Patrick eigentlich 90 Prozent der Musik geschrieben hat.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, dann machen wir neu.
Und Kim hatten wir schon vorher mal angefragt als Ersatz für Patrick.
Und dann kam aber Corona und es kam nie dazu. Und dann haben wir gesagt,
willst du mit uns direkt eine neue Band machen? Sagte Kim, ja klar.
Und dann waren wir eine Band. Und jetzt sind wir eine Band.
Und das erste Single kommt auch irgendwann jetzt die Tage. Und wir spielen aber schon Live-Shows.
Nächste ist in Bochum auf dem Two-Rock-Fest.
Hast du jetzt deine Abstimmung da gewonnen online?
Ja, erster Platz.
Ernsthaft?
Hast du mitgekriegt? Ja, ich habe auch mit gestimmt. Echt? Ja, klar.
Siehst du denn?
Doch, doch.
Ich habe heute auch meine Freunde.
Ja, guck mal an. Ich dachte, du liest immer nur heimlich mit.
Es gab ein Online-Voting, weil wir gerne auf diesem Festival spielen wollten.
Und dann haben wir gebettelt und gefläht und waren lustig und haben getan, was wir konnten.
Und Leute haben offensichtlich, das sah man nicht während des Votens,
du wusstest nicht, klickt da überhaupt jemand oder nur meine Mama und ich.
Und tatsächlich, ich glaube, wir haben 160 Stimmen vorsprungen oder so.
Also das heißt, wir waren deutlich vorne auf Platz 1 und dann kriegt man einen
schönen Slot und jetzt spielen wir da wahrscheinlich am 25. Oktober.
Wo genau?
Das ist in Bochum in irgendeinem großen Dings-Zentrum, ich muss das rausnehmen,
Two Rock Fest 24, guck mal nach.
Two Rock, so zwei Rock?
Nee, T-U-R-O-C-K, das ist ein sehr bekannter Rockladen in Essen.
Aber die Show ist nicht in dem Laden. Die ist auf irgendeiner größeren Bühne.
Okay, du musst ja den passenden Ding...
Ich mach da, ich mach Turok.
Okay, also Musik.
Genau, wir schweifen ab. Ich mache hier...
Wir sind immer noch bei dir.
Genau.
Was du alles so Tolles machst.
Ich bin hier in meiner...
Wir geben ja auch ein bisschen an mit dir als Gast. Was wir so für interessante Leute haben.
Das ist lustig, wie ich einfach letzte Woche mit dir angegeben habe.
Als Gast, als du bei Audiodump mit dabei warst.
Genau, das ist eine schöne Überleitung. Ich mache einen Podcast,
der einfach ein Fan-Klon von der Freakshow ist. Der heißt Audiodump.
Fan-Klon?
Sind wir mal ehrlich.
Da lacht der. Hat die ganze Podcast-Szene hier begründet und wundert sich,
wenn Leute Podcast machen.
Nee, darüber wundere ich mich jetzt nicht. Ich wollte den Begriff jetzt ein bisschen überraschen.
Also die beiden Pappnasen, die überhaupt Schuld an allem sind,
sitzen ja hier mit mir im Raum. Also Ralf kriegt gleich auch noch sein Fett an. Also auf jeden Fall.
Ich fahre immer noch durch Bochum. Ich komme da ja her. Ich gucke gerade,
wo das ist. Stadionring ist das. Ganz feine Ecke.
Wie heißt der Laden noch?
Hier, Ruhrkongress.
Ah, Ruhrkongress. Ich war noch nie da.
Ist so eine mittelschäbische, neumoderne, Stahl-Glas-Geschichte.
Schäbisch oder Schwäbisch?
Nee, Schäbisch.
Solange die Leute Unterhöschen auf die Bühne werfen, ist es fein. Okay. Okay, okay.
Gehen wir jetzt alle deine Icons hier durch?
Nee, nee, nicht alle. Manche lassen sich einfach subsumieren.
Also ich mache auch diese Podcasts und genau, da könnt ihr auf der Seite selber nachgucken.
Jetzt gibt es auch den ersten, den ich nur produziere, ohne Host zu sein.
Das ist Herzensschwester. Da wird über Gefühle gesprochen von Christine und Annika.
Kann ich auch mal den geneigten HörerInnen hier mal ans Herz legen,
wenn ihr mal was anders hören wollt als über das neue iPhone.
Als ob wir hier nur über iPhone reden.
Achso, ja, ich höre da nie so richtig zu, Tim können. Genau,
und was auch vielleicht interessant ist für die einen oder den anderen hier
ist malik.fm, da habe ich zum Beispiel zwei lange,
das sind so Einzelinterviews, sowas wie, ich sag mal UKW, aber andere Themen,
also alles, was nicht in die anderen Podcasts passt,
da habe ich zum Beispiel mit Linus ein langes, cooles Gespräch geführt,
und da habe ich ihn endlich mal all das gefragt, was ihn sonst irgendwie nie
einer gefragt hat, weil der nie in anderen Sachen sitzt, als Logbuch,
Netzpolitik oder Tagesschau und dann denke ich immer so, ja,
aber warum redet nie einer?
Mit dem Mann und dann bin ich hingefahren und hab mal mit ihm geredet.
Das kenne ich auch, das Gefühl.
Genau, siehste. Genau und ja, dann gab es noch, viele werden es kennen,
Clean Electric, so ein E-Mobility-Podcast, war ich lange Mitglied.
Und genau, die anderen Sachen guckt ihr euch einfach mal an.
Hat das einen Grund, dass du diese Sendung, die du hier veröffentlicht,
ohne Datum veröffentlicht?
Welche Sendung?
Na, auf Malik.fm.
Da sollte eins hoffentlich stehen.
Ja, also wenn du das hoffst, dann müsste ich deine Hoffnung leider enttäuschen.
Manchmal ist so in der Mobilansicht sieht man dann irgendwas nicht,
weil ich zu faul bin, das Template sinnvoll zu backen.
Ich habe hier auf dem Desktop keine Anhaltspunkte, ob das jetzt letzte Woche
war und du täglich produzierst oder ob das alles schon seit fünf Jahren rumliegt.
Absolut täglich. Spendet einfach fleißig. Da kommt jeden Tag eine Sendung.
Bist du hier nur zum Geld verdienen oder was?
Also die einen sagen so, die anderen sagen so. Grüße gehen raus an Jonny.
Tatsächlich ist es wahrscheinlich einfach Unfähigkeit. Wenn da nichts steht,
dann ist es Unfähigkeit. Guckt in euren Podcasts.
Wie echte Menschen.
Okay, und dann bla bla bla, noch Teenager Sex Beichte und andere Podcasts. Gibt es den noch?
Die einen sagen so, die anderen… Ach komm jetzt. Ja, ich würde sagen,
er ist nie beendet worden. Wir veröffentlichen regelmäßig wöchentlich.
Ach so, wie Not Safe for Work.
So, genau. Jetzt gucke ich mal, dann könnt ihr noch so Projekte,
die will ich alle gar nicht erklären.
Dann sind wir mit einem Elektroflugzeug von der Schweiz nach Norderney geflogen,
irgendwelche Weltrekorde gemacht und dann gibt es noch Gastauftritte.
Jetzt das wichtigste Projekt von allen, Ultraschall.
Nur richtig geschrieben mit einem großen Binnenest.
Nee, das geht gar nicht.
Das ist wirklich, das musst du ändern.
Genau, ich bin reingezerrt worden in das ganze Ding.
Ich glaube, weil wenn du in der Nerdwelt Designer bist, dann hast du sehr schnell
sehr viele neue Freunde.
Einer davon war Ralf Stockmann. Warst du auf einem Kongress oder wo?
Oder habe ich dich ange...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir eigentlich übereinander gefahren sind.
Ah, ich glaube, ich weiß. Ich ahne es. Es war immer das Gleiche.
Es fehlte mir irgendein Feature und ich habe den Typ angeschrieben,
der das Feature einbauen kann.
Und dann, genau, so wird es gewesen sein. Und dann kommt Tim von der Seite und
sagt, ja, nicht beschweren, machen.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ach, man kann auch selber da irgendwie.
Und dann hat Ralf mir Affinity Designer beigebracht, das ich vorher noch nie
angefasst hatte und jetzt benutze ausschließlich.
Tatsächlich? Ausschließlich? Ja, für solche Sachen.
Also InDesign, für die Layout-Sachen, aber für alles, was so Vektor-Gefummel
ist, nehme ich Designer.
Und habe auch meinen Schmerz damit, aber es ist alles besser als Illustrator für mein Leben.
Und dann haben wir uns ja irgendwie drüber gebeugt und dann kriegte das Ding
mal so ein bisschen so eine Form und das soll ja jetzt bald weitergehen, wie ich hörte.
Ich hörte so etwas in eurem Podcast.
Ach, da, oh, der Druck steigt.
Wie war die Formulierung? Ich glaube nicht, dass Ralf sich die Blöße geben wird,
über die Subscribe zu laufen und im 5-Minuten-Takt nach der Release gefragt zu werden.
Ja, ja, sie wird kommen.
Punkt.
So, jetzt ist es raus.
Ja, ich glaube, da habe ich es jetzt so kurz gemacht, wie es irgendwie sinnvoll möglich ist Okay.
Auf jeden Fall hast du auch so eine Plethora an Podcast-Projekten den du irgendwo
deine Finger drin hast, produzieren, teilnehmend oder?
Genau, ich habe noch was vergessen, das wo das Geld herkommt Das sind noch so diese zwei grün und,
orangefarbenen S-Logos, die man hier sieht Das ist eines Shapes.Film Das ist
eine Filmproduktions-Company, die ich mit mit meinem Kumpel Tom,
vielen auch bekannt aus Audiodump und Malik FM und allem, zusammen mache.
Also wir sind einfach nur wir zwei und wir machen halt von Musikvideos bis Industriefilm.
Wenn ihr einen Film haben wollt, klickt da mal auf shapes.film und schreibt uns mal.
Und dann gibt es noch Shapes Music und das ist was ganz anderes,
das ist so Ad-Music, wie man sagen würde.
Also wenn Nivea kommt oder die Meta-Ebene und sagt, wir brauchen eine neue Musik,
dann setzt sich Tom hin und macht auf Weltniveau, würde ich sagen, supergeile Mucke.
Das ist das, was demnächst von KI übernommen wird.
Naja, schauen wir mal. Vielleicht machen wir es auch mit KI und verkaufen es
euch teuer. Also ich bin auf jeden Fall der, der dann die Rechnung schreibt.
Aber Tom ist da. Wir haben zum
Beispiel gerade für WDR 2 die komplette Sender-Audiodesign neu gemacht.
Ernsthaft?
Das war so ein anderthalb Jahresprojekt.
Okay, Respekt. Also ich habe es nicht gehört und kann jetzt quasi nicht so sagen,
aber in dem Bereich reinzukommen und sich den Auftrag zu erwischen.
Ja, das fand ich auch und wusste gar nicht, wie groß der Auftrag war.
Das habe ich dann erst erfahren, als ich dann durch die drei Schleusen im WDR
erstmal da war und in diesem Zimmer saß und die uns die Excel-Tabelle gezeigt
haben, wie viel von diesen Jingles es so gibt.
Ich dachte, du machst da 15 Motive und fertig. Naja, es ist mehr so 300.
Also viele davon leiten sie selber ab, aber es ist wirklich,
und ich wusste auch nicht, dass ich glaube, es ist der größte deutsche Sender
oder irgendwie einer der.
Ja, das ist der Punkt. Ich mag ja immer so diesen Begriff Selbstwirksamkeit so im Leben.
Man will ja doch irgendwie so das eine oder andere tun, was irgendwie so einen
gewissen Footprint hinterlässt.
Und jetzt kannst du sagen, du hast Dinge gebastelt, die die Millionen von Menschen
tagtäglich im Rohr haben und die sie hoffentlich eher erfreuen als nerven.
Cool. Also ich selber bin kein Autor, das heißt auch da, ich schreibe halt irgendeine
Rechnung, aber Tom und Kollege Thomas haben da die Art Direction gehabt oder
Creative Direction, dementsprechend, da bin ich dann eher,
wie hat Tom gesagt, er wollte mich in der Firma dabei haben,
weil wir sind persönlich, wie man merkt, seit Jahren befreundet und ich habe
gesagt, ja gut, ich mache zwar lange Musik und so weiter, aber ich habe keine
Ahnung von diesem speziellen Business,
also ich habe in Werbeagenturen gearbeitet, aber das ist noch was anderes als
Ad-Music machen und er sagte, ja, aber ich brauche jemanden zum Türen eintreten.
Er meinte damit, ich könne gut mit Menschen reden und dafür bin ich sozusagen abgestellt.
Ob das so gut klappt, werden die Annalen irgendwann verkünden,
aber so, jetzt habe ich es glaube ich.
Aber ich sage, es ist viel, deswegen musste ich diese Homepage machen,
es ist viel einfacher, wenn man sagen kann, hey, ich bin bei der Stabi Chef.
Dieses Framework hätte ich gerne. Obwohl, nee, das war von eurer Band, sehe ich hier gerade.
Da nutzt ihr Linkstack.
Ach so, genau.
Warum ist das nicht in Cloudron drin, frage ich mich gerade.
Ich frage mich, was ist Cloudron?
Ja, das wollte ich irgendwann auch nochmal breiter hier vorstellen.
Das ist dieses Klick mich Bunti.
Ich habe keine Lust, irgendwie eigene Server mehr zu betreiben,
sondern shoppe mir einen einzigen Server.
Und dann in der Virtualisierung kannst du dann so alles an relevanten Open-Source-Tools
da drin deployen mit zwei,
drei Klicks und hast dann ein WordPress und hast ein Discourse und was weiß
der Geier was halt und da fehlt mir das nämlich seit zwei oder drei Jahren schon drin und...
Vielleicht soll ich mal kurz sagen, worüber wir sprechen.
Ja.
Linkstack ist quasi ein Linktree Open-Source-Klon.
Genau, jetzt musst du noch erklären, was Linktree ist.
Linktree ist, ihr kennt das oft, bei Bandseiten ist es häufig oder Influencers
oder so, die haben dann eine Domain, aber wenn du da drauf gehst,
ist da halt kein vollständiges WordPress oder so, sondern du siehst quasi nur
eine Liste von 5, 6, 7 Links,
die direkt dann zu den Social-Kanälen oder zu YouTube oder so führen.
Und das haben, glaube ich, Linktree mal erfunden oder so, oder zumindest populär gemacht.
Das heißt, es ist eine Micro-Site, oder wie würde man das sagen?
Also super simpel, da sind nur Links übereinander, man muss selber auch nichts
programmieren und man wirft da einfach seine Links drauf und dann wird für einen
so eine winzige Seite generiert, wo nur die wichtigsten Dinger drauf sind.
Und dann gibt's halt die Jungs und Mädel, glaube ich, von Linkstack.
Das ist quasi die Variante, wenn du nicht Linktree dafür bezahlen möchtest,
dass du, keine Ahnung, acht statt sieben Links drauf machen darfst oder sowas,
dann nimmt man halt das Ding, kann man sich selber mit drei Klicks irgendwo,
kopieren oder, ja, ich glaube, man muss das irgendwo rüberkopieren auf den FTP
und dann lief es auch schon oder so. Also es war sehr simpel.
Jemand von Mastodon hat mich da netterweise an die Hand genommen,
dann habe sogar ich das hinbekommen und genau, das ist, wenn man auf dark.band,
also mit dark mit 2K, dark.band geht, dann,
Dann sieht man, wenn man runter scrollt, Powered by Link Stack und dann könnt
ihr draufklicken und dann habt ihr das auch.
Genau, und das ist mir völlig unerklärlich, warum dieses kleine, nützliche,
eigentlich sehr simpel zu betreibende Tool, warum das nicht Teil vom Cloud Run-Stack
ist und in dem Support-Forum da fordern wir das seit Jahren,
also nicht nur ich, sondern irgendwie zig andere Leute und da verstehe ich die wirklich nicht.
Die sitzen ja auch hier in Berlin, vielleicht muss man da nochmal anklopfen.
Sealight war es übrigens, der mir übergeholfen hat. Schreibt er mir gerade.
Jemand von. Sorry, Sealight.
Jemand von Mastodon, genau.
Ja, ich bin sehr vergesslich. Das ist ein Skill, den ich übrigens auch oben
auf die Homepage drauf schreiben könnte. Also gerade mit Namen und so. Furchtbar.
Matt Malik merke ich mir aber jetzt.
Alright.
Dann können wir ja mal langsam hier mit dem Inhalt anfangen.
Das war doch noch nie so. Wir sitzen doch in der ersten Stunde.
Wir sollten mal ein bisschen Feedback leisten und dann könnt ihr euch jetzt,
Wir reden gleich nochmal über Design. Du hast jetzt so viel geredet.
Dann mache ich mal hier einen ganz kurzen Nachtrag.
Und zwar haben wir uns ja über Reinigungsmethoden unterhalten.
Und ich habe heute tatsächlich wieder gereinigt.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt so einen Fimmel hätte oder so.
Das muss ich doch mal zu mir einladen.
Ich muss vor allem erstmal Mal, naja, also ich finde, so Reinigung hat was Reinigendes.
Meine Mutter findet das auch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum, aber egal, lassen wir das offen.
Manchmal muss es ja sauber werden und ich hatte ja die Geschichte erzählt von
dem Schimmel im Auto und dann habe ich irgendwie diesen Ozongenerator reingeladen.
Da habe ich aber noch Unsinn erzählt in einer Hinsicht, das wollte ich jetzt
noch mal gleich klarstellen und zwar in Bezug auf diese diese Wirkung vom Ozon.
Also man stellt ja diesen Ozongenerator in einen Raum oder in ein Auto eben, in eine Enclosure.
Und natürlich sollte man sich dann da nicht drin aufhalten. Ah,
aber da kam ja noch die Frage, wie ist das so mit Lebensmitteln und so weiter.
Da meinte ich ja, alles ganz gefährlich, weil der Sauerstoff,
der da freigesetzt wird, der zerstört alles.
Dem ist natürlich nicht so. Sondern das Ozon, also O3, zerfällt ja dann schnell
in normalen Sauerstoff, also den O2-Sauerstoff, den wir alle kennen und atmen.
Und dann bleibt ja noch ein O
übrig und dieses O, das ist halt dieses kontaktfreudige oxidierende Wesen.
Und das oxidiert ja dann im Schimmel und in Sporen und alles,
was halt so rumliegt und so latent biologisch ist und Ärger macht.
Also alles, was so bacillös da auf einen einwirken möchte.
Und genau dafür ist es halt gut. Und das vernichtet halt dieses Gewusel und
Gerüche und all das so. Aber es wirkt halt, wenn er jetzt so eine Tomate ist, nur auf der Oberfläche.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das tief eindringt und jetzt jegliche Materie auflöst
oder so, sondern da war es dann halt auch.
Und wurde auch darauf hingewiesen, es wird halt auch zum selben Zweck,
wird es zum Beispiel in der Lebensmittelindustrie für die Desinfektion jetzt
in Produktionsstraßen, wenn das Gemüse irgendwie durchmarschiert,
wahrscheinlich durch ihre Apparate,
dann gibt es halt auch nochmal ein bisschen Ozon obendrauf, weil dann wird halt
was auch immer da vielleicht an Schimmel oder sonstigen Substanzen sich da auf
der Haut befindet, auch nochmal weggekickt.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht so viel drüber, aber so ist es wohl.
Ich habe zwei Fragen. Irgendwie habe ich so einen Chlorgeruch-Gedanken,
während du das so erzählst, du hast es auch in der Sendung erzählt, wie riecht das denn?
Riecht das so wie Chlorreiniger? Wahrscheinlich nein, aber hat das so einen
spezifischen Geruch oder riecht man da gar nichts von?
Ja, es riecht nach Ozon. Wie riecht Ozon? Naja, es hat auch so ein bisschen,
also nicht wie Chlor, aber...
Ähnlich. Ich kann den kurz mal anmachen, dann riechst du es.
Oh, warum nicht? Ich bin dabei. Also wenn ihr von uns jetzt nichts mehr hört.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt den Hörern viel bringt, aber ich kann es ja mal
kurz machen. Kannst du das dann beschreiben?
Uns beim Sterben zuhören.
Was kann nicht?
Ja.
Riecht nach Laserdrucker, sagt Sebastian. Ah, ja, den Geruch würde ich kennen.
Ah ja. Hier wird sehr viel Laser Laserdrucker, das finde ich super.
Gerade noch die Sendung gehört, schon das Gerät vor der Nase. Es ist blau.
Riecht nach Laserdrucker ist, glaube ich, eine gute Beschreibung.
Es riecht schon, obwohl es noch gar nicht an ist.
Es riecht schon, obwohl es nicht an ist? Warte mal.
Aber das kann jetzt auch einfach die Klotür gewesen sein.
Dann ist es wohl wieder gereinigt, da kam der her.
Mysteriöse Gerüche.
Achso, meine zweite Frage, während du das Ding aufbaust. Und hätte es auch geholfen,
als damals in meinem alten Golf hatte ich Einkäufe hinten drin.
Auch eine Milch habe dann Leute mitgenommen von der Disco nachts.
Das Auto war dunkel und irgendjemand hat wahrscheinlich, ohne es zu merken,
diese Milch mit seinem Springerstiefel zertreten und ich hatte einen Liter Milch
in meinem Unterboden. Dieses Auto hatte einen Totalschaden.
Ist das, wäre das wäre noch gegangen, sagst du?
Genau dafür ist es gut.
Wow. Okay, ich will das Auto, schickt mir bitte das Auto. Es ist nur 15 Jahre her.
So, jetzt mache ich mal hier den Ozongenerator doch kurz an.
Geil, wir werden so sauber, war ich lange nicht. Ich bin hier immer bei 33 Grad
durch Berlin getigert, tagelang.
Warum duschen, wenn man auch in der Meta-Ebene kurz mal einen Ozonstrahl Jetzt geht's los.
Laserdrucker.
Ja.
Okay. Ich mach mal wieder aus.
Laserdrucker, genau. Also man kann wahrscheinlich auch einen Laserdrucker einfach
ins Auto stellen und 3000 Seiten drucken.
Immer so Milchtüten als Mahnmal. Ich darf keine Milchtüten zertreten.
Okay, du hast gereinigt.
Ja, heute habe ich gereinigt, weil ich hatte jetzt noch diesen,
dieser Ozongeruch, also obwohl jetzt dieses Ozon ja eigentlich schnell verschwinden
soll, hat man den dann irgendwie trotzdem noch in den Polstern und ich empfand
den so als, also er ist nicht irgendwie,
wird einem nicht übel oder irgendwas, aber er ist da so und ich dachte mir so,
jetzt machst du dein Auto mal richtig sauber und jetzt nimmst du auch noch so den Rest mal raus.
Und da ich aber jetzt nicht gleich zum Detailer laufen wollte,
der mir dann sozusagen da Full-Service macht, wollte ich einfach nochmal was
ausprobieren. Und dann habe ich wieder einen tollen Tipp bekommen.
Und zwar kann man offenbar bei allen Drogeriemärkten, sowas wie DM oder Rossmann
und vielleicht gibt es auch noch weitere, das weiß ich nicht ganz genau,
kann man relativ unkompliziert sich Nasssauger leihen.
Du musst nur das Reinigungsmittel dort kaufen.
Das ist so quasi die Miete.
Ich definiere einen Nasssauger.
Ein Nasssauger ist wie ein Staubsauger, der aber auch in der Lage ist,
Flüssigkeiten aufzusaugen und entsprechend dann auch abzuführen.
Oder auch selber einen Tank hat mit Reinigungsflüssigkeit.
Genau.
Habe ich zu Hause. Willst du kaufen?
Du hast einen Nasssauger.
Ich habe ihn von hier auch teuer und gut und nie genutzt, weil dann mit Wischroboter besser.
Hier die, die die teuren Ventilatoren auch machen. Dyson? Dyson, ja.
Ah, ein Nasssauger von Dyson.
Oder ist es von, da muss man eben gucken. Also auf jeden Fall marken Dings so
halbwegs rechts unten, war das?
Ja, in meinem Fall, ich weiß gar nicht, von welcher Marke jetzt dieser Sauger
war, weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Es kann sein, dass es vom selben Brand, dass es genauso gebrandet war wie jetzt
dieses Reinigungsmittel.
Also das war Sapur hieß das. Und naja, also ich habe online,
also in dem Fall war es ein DM-Markt und du kannst halt bei DM da auf einer
Webseite, sagst du hier Postleitzahl, sagt er hier sind drei,
vier, fünf Filialen und wenn die halt einen Verleih-Service haben,
dann siehst du auch sofort die Termine, kannst du da klicken und zack, so.
Und dann bin ich da heute hingefahren, hat auch alles wunderbar funktioniert,
gibst 200 Euro Kaution ab und
dann bin ich da mit diesem Nasssauger losmarschiert und hab halt Polster,
also ich hab nicht nur im Auto noch einen Wohnwagen,
aber ich hab sozusagen mal so alles, was über längere Zeit ohnehin viel Staub
und Dreck und Sitzerei ausgesetzt war.
Und natürlich auch dann dieses Fahrzeug, insbesondere hinten dieser Teppich,
der dann so im Boden liegt.
Und habe das mal alles ordentlich durchgesaugt.
Aber das ist mit so einer Tonne hinten wahrscheinlich. Nicht einer,
der so als ein langer Stab fungiert.
Weil das sind so zwei verschiedene Gerätetypen, die es da gibt.
Also hast du so eine Tonne hinter dir hergezogen oder war das so ein einziges Gerät?
Also guck mal hier. Also es gibt die hier so. Also ich zeige es Ihnen jetzt
gerade mal hier. Google-Bildersuche, so das ist das Tonnenmodell und das hier
ist das, es ist alles in einem einzigen sehr fetter Staubsauger-Modell.
Es war im Wesentlichen einfach ein,
rechteckiges, wie sagt man, rechteckig im Volumen, wie heißt das? Quader?
Auf jeden Fall, das Ding hatte eine Öffnung für das Frischwasser,
da machst du Frischwasser rein,
da passt so So 8-9 Liter rein und auf der anderen Seite hast du halt einen rausnehmbaren Eimer,
wo dann eben das durchgespülte Endprodukt drin landet und dann machst du halt
das Reinigungszeug ins Frischwasser rein und hast dann zwei Tasten, einen für den...
Für die Pumpe, die sozusagen dieses Reinigungswasser rauspumpt und eine Taste für den Sauger.
Und du kannst dann beides anmachen, also du kannst nur die Pumpe anmachen für
diese Reinigungsflüssigkeit und dann drückst du da drauf und dann spritzt der
halt einfach nur die Reinigungsflüssigkeit.
Das heißt, ich habe erstmal alles ein wenig vorbehandelt und getränkt,
dass das so einen Moment hat, da die Tenside sich auch mal reinzugraben und
sich mal kurz mit dem Schmutz so unterhalten.
Scheunt das? Aber das scheint dann so. wie bei so Autowäschen?
Es hat bei mir nicht geschäumt, aber es hätte wohl geschäumt,
wenn ich gecheckt hätte, wie ich diese Düse richtig einstelle.
Die war nämlich etwas locker, die fiel mir am Schluss dann ab und dann wusste
ich, warum da nur so ein Strahl rauskam.
Also eigentlich ist das mehr so zum Einschäumen wahrscheinlich gedacht gewesen.
Und das ist halt ganz gut zum Vorbehandeln und wie sehr das schäumt,
weiß ich nicht. Es hängt davon ab, wie viel von diesem Reinigungszeug da reinmachst.
Hab jetzt keine lange Erfahrung damit gemacht, ich hab's halt nur angewendet
und jetzt riecht der Wagen auch wieder ordentlich.
So und wenn du halt Staubsauger anmachst und diese Pumpe, dann kannst du quasi,
Flüssigkeit rein und gleich wieder raussaugen. Also es wird sozusagen reingesprüht.
So, du ziehst das Ding zu dir und es wird halt zwei, drei Zentimeter vorher,
ins Polster reingesprüht und dahinter saugst du es glaube ich gleich wieder raus.
Und wie feucht ist es dann noch? Also beschlägt das Auto dann drei Tage lang?
Achso, nö, das war, also ich kann es jetzt ein Prozent nicht ausdrücken,
aber du kannst das richtig schön matschig nass machen und danach ist es so feucht.
Okay. Man will sich nicht sofort draufsetzen. Doch, ich hab mich da auch sogar draufgesetzt.
Also nicht in der nächsten Sekunde, aber als ich fertig war.
Das war überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Also, falls du das häufiger hast, ich hab mal geguckt, ich hab den Vileda Jet
Clean 3 in 1 Saugwischer. ich mache dir einen sehr, sehr guten Preis.
Für die Gerichte oder für den Verkauf?
Gerne Verkauf und weg aus meiner Wohnung.
Achso, aber das ist jetzt so ein Bodenstaubsauger.
Der ist hauptsächlich für Boden und Teppiche und sowas.
Ja, das hilft mir natürlich wenig, wenn ich so enge Polster abschleife.
Du willst ja was in der Hand haben.
Du willst ja so einen Schlauch in der Hand haben, wo vorne so eine,
wo das sozusagen auch mit so einem durchsichtigen Plastik abgedeckt ist,
dass du auch siehst, wie viel Flüssigkeit da rauskommt.
Ja, das siehst du bei dem auch. auch, also dieses durchsichtige vorn hat er
auch, aber der ist halt nicht jetzt um die Ecke und schnell mal irgendwo im Auto.
Teppich habe ich ja keinen, also damit kann ich jetzt nichts anfangen.
Der Nasssauger, den ich hatte, der hat eine andere, wie sagt man, eine andere...
Bauform.
Darum eine Frage. Ja, das ist eine berechtigte Frage. Dann hattest du nämlich einen mit einer Tonne.
Nee, ich hatte auch keine Tonne. Es war, wie gesagt, es war ein Quader.
Aber ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, welches Modell das war.
Ich habe Teppich zu Hause und der lässt sich auch mit Staubsaugen,
weil der ist schon echt alt, nicht mehr so richtig reinigen.
Ist das der Moment, wo man zu einem Baumarkt fährt und sich so ein Ding leiht?
Ah, ich habe jetzt einen gefunden, Kunden, der der Bauform entspricht,
den kann ich mal kurz hier in den Dings reinhauen und das mache ich deshalb, weil der so geil heißt.
Der ist nämlich von Kärcher, Arschteuer, und der heißt passenderweise Kärcher Putzi.
P-U-Z-Z-I, Putzi.
Der Putzi.
Aber der hat sagen wir mal jetzt genau diese Bauform. Also du hast sozusagen da in so einem Ja.
Es ist eine Tonne, die halt einfach nur liegt, statt steht.
Mit zwei Rädern. Ja, Wien-Staubsauger, so ein alter, klassischer.
Aber ist das jetzt sowas, was man sich durch die Wohnung geht?
Genau, das da unten, genau, Abdelkader hat mal wieder den Volltreffer gelandet,
dieses Sapur-Teil, das ist der, den ich hatte.
Also der blaue da unten, also einer, der,
ja, von der Firma gebrandet ist, ich bezweifle, dass sie den herstellen,
wahrscheinlich ist es auch nur ein Kärcher, bloß ein Beleger, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Anyway, auf jeden Fall sowas funktioniert, kann ich empfehlen,
soweit und der Wagen roch danach angenehm.
Also mir ist offensichtlich gelungen, dieses Restozon dann aus den Polstern
raus zu saugen und jetzt ist wieder alles supi.
Und nebenbei habe ich auch noch die Sitzmöbel, die sich da noch angeboten haben,
auch gleich noch mit gemacht und es ist schon erstaunlich, was da für ein Schlag rauskommt.
Also wenn man das dann ausschüttet am Schluss, die Menge an Sand und die Menge
an Dreck, die war schon beeindruckend.
So viel dazu. Reinigen ist das halbe Leben, wenn man es richtig macht.
Gut, so viel dazu, es ist eine interessante Welt.
Respekt. Ja, wenn jemand in Aachen und Umgebung so einen Reiniger hat,
also die Alternative dazu ist, ich überlege schon lange umzuziehen und gucke
mir demnächst nochmal Wohnungen an.
Vielleicht ist das, in dem Fall gibt man einfach auf und zieht um.
Mal gucken. Aber ansonsten, falls in Aachen jemand so ein Gerät hat und unbedingt
will, dass ich das mal teste, damit ich in unserem Abklatsch-Klon-Podcast auch
darüber sprechen kann, dann... Holler mir ab.
Anderer Nachtrag zur letzten Sendung. Thema Kontakte, Todesdatum und sowas.
Da gab es nämlich etliches an Rückmeldungen bei uns im Blog als Kommentaren
und ich habe da in der Tat auch selber noch länger drüber nachgedacht nach der
Sendung und hatte so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass wir da so ein ganz klein
wenig das Thema verfehlt hatten, so soll vorkommen.
Weil wir uns irgendwie so irre lange aufgehalten haben, so warum steht da jetzt
irgendwie Geschlecht und Gender nicht und stattdessen irgendwie jetzt Anrede und so weiter.
Und den eigentlichen Skandalfaktor der ganzen Geschichte haben wir irgendwie,
finde ich, nicht klar genug rausgearbeitet.
Nämlich egal, was da jetzt drin steht, ich will danach filtern können.
Und egal, was ich für eigene Felder anlege, ich will danach filtern können, danach suchen können.
Und nichts davon bietet mir diese App. Und ich frage mich halt,
was genau hält Apple aber davon ab?
Das heißt, ich habe ja eine Datenbank, ich befülle eine klassische Datenbank
mit klassischen Datenbankfeldern und ich habe eine klassische Trefferliste,
ich habe eine klassische Suche und nichts davon ist irgendwie vernünftig durchintegriert.
Und die einzige Arbeitsthese, zu der ich überhaupt irgendwie gekommen bin, ist, naja,
vermutlich haben sie den Architekturansatz, dass sie das einzig und allein über
Spotlight abwickeln wollen und sie haben halt keinen Bock in Spotlight jetzt
irgendwelche zusätzlichen, schon gar nicht generischen Felder noch irgendwie hinzuzubauen,
weil Aufwand und teuer und kein Team dafür da.
Aber, dass man im Jahr 2024 irgendwie auf einem Desktop-PC mit sonst was für
einer Rechenleistung eine olle Winz-Datenbank,
das sind ja ein paar hundert oder ein paar tausend Eintragungen,
die ich vernünftig durchsuchen kann, das ist schon ein mittlerer Skandal und
das ist uns da, finde ich, doch ein bisschen durch die Lappen gegangen bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Ja, also dazu noch ein paar Hintergrundinformationen.
Also was mir etwas entfallen war in der ganzen Diskussion in dem Zusammenhang
mit der Contacts-App ist,
dass ja Apple vor einiger Zeit schon, wie es auch mit vielen anderen Systemprogrammen passiert ist.
Die Kontakte-App ist ja nicht nur eine App, die ihre eigene Datenbank hat,
sondern genauso wie die Kalender können ja auch andere Programme darauf zugreifen.
Also es handelt sich dabei schon um eine System-Datenbank.
Und es gibt Party-Apps, die das machen. Genannt wurde CardHop,
das ist von diesen Flexibits-Leuten, was aus irgendwelchen Gründen einen Online-Account
bei ihnen braucht. Das habe ich dann erst gar nicht ausprobiert.
Und was ich wo ich selber hätte drauf kommen können, war Busy Contacts.
Busy Contacts und Busy Cal sind auch schon sehr lange Mac-Programme von Busy Mac.
Das ist so eine Macintosh-Utility-Bude, die schon ganz lange dabei sind und
manche kennen die und manche nicht.
Und BusyCal ist so Power-User-Kalender, also das ist halt wie iCal,
aber kann halt noch tausend andere Sachen zusätzlich.
Letztlich, ich persönlich bin immer wieder in den normalen Kalender gerutscht,
weil es mir dann ein bisschen zu viel von allem war,
aber eine Zeit lang war es irgendwie das Einzige, was zum Beispiel Kalenderwochen
anzeigen konnte und sowas.
Also so Details, wenn es um sowas geht, da sind die dann besonders gut.
Wollen wir über Kalender reden? Naja.
Nein, wir reden eigentlich über Adressbücher.
Genau, und es gibt halt Busy Contacts und das macht es halt auch.
Aber auch hier, du musst halt nicht jetzt alle deine Adressen importieren,
sondern benutzt einfach dieselbe Systemdatenbank.
Und siehe da, dann habe ich das mal ausprobiert und stelle fest,
es gibt ein Todes-, ein Sterbedatum wohl als valides Datenbank-Element.
Es wird bloß von der Contacts-App nicht exposed, wie man so schön sagt.
Und mit anderen Worten, zumindest dieses eine Datum wäre tatsächlich verwaltbar
mit Busy-Context und ist sozusagen da.
Ich habe das jetzt nicht weiter...
Ausprobiert, nicht viel Zeit drauf gegossen, weil ich hatte auch noch gerade ein anderes Event,
was wichtiger war, aber will nur sagen,
es macht den Eindruck, dass zumindest bestimmte Dinge theoretisch in der Datenbank
schon vorgesehen sind, sie werden bloß von dieser Kontakte-App aus irgendwelchen
Gründen noch nicht mal optional angeboten und teilweise tut es dann halt Third-Party-Programme.
Das erinnert jetzt immer noch nichts an der ursprünglichen Fragestellung,
die sich ja eigentlich, unabhängig jetzt von solchen technischen Details,
generell so diese Fragestellung mit, wie hilft dir dein Computer dabei,
mit deinem Freundeskreis zu arbeiten.
Und da ist halt sowas wie, jemand ist tot, ist schon so eine Information,
wo ich sagen würde, die ist nicht so ganz unwichtig.
Gerade wenn du E-Mails rausschickst. Es gibt ja auch nichts beklemmenderes,
als wenn du das dann doch gemacht hast, so an alle und dann kriegst du dieses,
ja, dieser E-Mail-Account existiert nicht mehr, von dem du jetzt genau weißt,
welche Person dahinter steht und so. Das will man halt auch nicht haben.
Jetzt, wo du gerade den Namen Cardhop erwähnt hast, erinnere ich mich,
dass ich das besitze, aber nicht benutze und habe es gerade noch mal aus dem
App Store runtergeladen.
Ich glaube, ich habe es deswegen nicht benutzt, weil Apple ja nach wie vor,
mal sehen, wie lange noch, diese Krankheit hat, dass das nicht deine Standard-App
sein kann und dementsprechend sprang ich sehr oft in die Contacts-App,
wenn ich eigentlich Cardhops Vorteile,
schnellere Suche und so, vielleicht hätte nutzen können.
So, deswegen habe ich es dann irgendwann gelöscht, weil ich es einfach nie benutzt habe.
Jetzt habe ich nochmal runtergeladen und gucke nach und ich kann dort ein Sterbedatum festlegen.
Also auch in Cardhop-Contacts.
Wie es jetzt heißt. Weil das offensichtlich in der Contacts-Datenbank an sich schon definiert ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da auch die Möglichkeit gibt, hier quasi App-Dependent,
Oder App-Specific-Felder anzulegen und denen vielleicht auch einen Typ zu geben.
Also die Frage ist ja, kann ich überhaupt Felder anlegen?
Und zweitens kann ich sagen, was der Typ dieser Felder ist? Würde ich mal vermuten,
wenn das mit den Feldern geht, dann kann man wahrscheinlich auch einen Typ machen.
Dann kann man wahrscheinlich auch einen Datumstyp machen.
Aber damit wissen ja alle anderen Programme immer noch nicht,
was die Bedeutung dieses Datums ist. Sondern es ist halt nur a date.
Und solange das eben nicht klar ist, hilft einem das ja dann auch nur so begrenzt
weiter. Weil man will das ja nicht aus der Perspektive eines einzigen Programms machen.
Und ich gehe halt noch weiter und sage, das System muss sowas wissen.
Also dieses ganze, eine Person ist nur ein Eintrag in der Datenbank,
das ist mir zu wenig. Ja, also es hat man ja auch schon erwähnt,
es fehlen diese ganzen Links.
Was sind die Social Media Accounts? Man kann das alles nicht hinzufügen,
es ist nicht flexibel, es ist nicht erweiterbar.
Es gibt da keine Rückführung, es gibt überhaupt keine Funktion mit.
Ich hatte Kommunikation mit Ralf.
Welcher der 30.000 Optionen, die mir heutzutage zur Verfügung stehen,
wurde jetzt gewählt? Wie komme ich da ran?
Und das ist absurd, weil über sowas wurde bei Apple schon mal sehr früh nachgedacht.
Ich erinnere mich, System 7.51.
Lass mich überlegen. Ne, ich glaube 7.0. Wenn es nicht 7.0 war,
dann war es 7.5, aber auf jeden Fall eins von den beiden. Also macOS.
Das ist sehr lang.
Prä-X.
Genau, also wir reden jetzt von 93, so 94 die Zeit rum, da muss das gewesen
sein, da kam das irgendwie raus.
Und das war sogar noch dieses, warte mal, da ist Apple mal auf diese bekloppte Idee gekommen.
Genau, da gab es nämlich System 7 und es gab System 7 Pro.
Es gab tatsächlich eine Zusatzkaufvariante deines Betriebssystems.
Eine verdammt schlechte Idee.
Die lief wahrscheinlich nicht auf meinem Klon, die hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Ne, die lief auf jedem Macintosh, nur das Pro war sozusagen zusätzlich und da
waren dann so Sachen drin wie äh,
Powertalk und worauf will ich hinaus also System 7 oder 7.5 ich weiß nicht mehr
ganz genau, hatte die Idee einer Universal Inbox.
Also da sozusagen, dass du wirklich aus mehreren Quellen über eine Inbox alles
bekommen kannst, also egal was es ist. Und damals gab es ja noch gar nicht so viel.
Das fand ich eigentlich sehr weitsichtig.
Nur, dass halt damals macOS einfach andere Probleme hatte,
die ja dann später auch zu richtigen Problemen führten, dass wir so 93 ist so
kurz vor dem Fast-Kollaps von Apple gewesen,
ja, also 95 lagen sie ja dann schon da nieder und werden fast komplett gestorben,
wenn dieser bekloppte Gil Amelio nicht zumindest eine einzige gute Idee in seinem
Leben gehabt hatte, als er Apple-Chef war, nämlich Next zu kaufen und sich damit
Steve Jobs wieder in die Bude zu holen. Naja, will sagen...
Ich finde, ein Betriebssystem sollte solche Dinge, solche Real-Life-Dinge modellieren
und allen Programmen dabei helfen, diese Modellierung zu unterstützen.
Also Personen, Menschen, mit denen ich rede, Organisationen,
also Gruppen von Personen, das sind so Dinge, die sollten irgendwie als abstrakte
Objekte modelliert werden können.
Und ich sollte die befüttern können mit verschiedenen Programmen und befragen
können und es sollte universell skriptbar sein,
was ich mit denen tue oder was ich von denen erhalte und kann mir ein Skript
machen, was halt all diese Quellen herausfinden kann, was Kanäle checken kann,
was schauen kann, sind da neue Nachrichten, wann sind die gekommen,
von wem wurden die geschickt und halt alles auseinanderhalten,
was man heutzutage noch auseinanderhalten muss.
Ich weiß, das ist im Zweifelsfall dann auch viel und man könnte argumentieren,
für ein Betriebssystem ist es dann auch zu viel, aber ich finde derzeit machen
sie einfach viel zu wenig.
Also es ist ein Fernziel und nie wird irgendwas perfekt sein,
aber dass du da, ich hatte das ja vorgelesen, wenn du da jetzt Social Media
einträgst, irgendwelche chinesischen Buden und nichts was heute aktuell ist
und alles heißt noch Twitter und also es ist absurd, was sie da zusammenbauen.
Ich erinnere vage, dass es so zu Web2 Hochzeiten gab es auch so ein paar Regierungsansätze.
Einer war glaube ich Friend Feed, das war so, wir bringen irgendwie Twitter
und Facebook alles in so eine Universal Timeline rein und für Chat und Nachrichten
war das glaube ich Pidgin, kann das sein, dass das so hieß?
Erinnert sich da jemand dran? Oder Trillion war glaube ich auch sowas.
Eine Trillion war ein Meta-Client.
Genau, wo du also all deine Chatprogramme irgendwie eintragen konntest und hattest
dann quasi eine einzige Chat-Oberfläche, mit der du die alle bespielen konntest.
Aber die haben dir glaube ich nicht eine Timeline gebaut, sondern sie haben
dir eine umschaltbare, also so wie Tabs, meine ich, so war das, meine ich.
Oh, das ist schon lange her. Aber ja, ich begrüße das sehr.
Also ich wäre auch dafür, dass da mal was passiert, dieses ganze Zerschossene
wieder zusammengeführt wird.
Kleines Follow-up. Abdelkader ist ja bekanntlich der Patron des Vollwissens
in diesem Podcast-Internet und er sagt, die machen das in Cardhop auch über
ein Custom-Date-Field.
Also es wird auch in anderen Apps, zum Beispiel der Contacts-App,
exponiert, aber man kann eben nicht automatisiert damit arbeiten.
Also sprich, das Programm weiß dann immer noch nicht, dass es ein Sterbedatum ist.
Ja. Ach ja, dann.
Lösche ich das mal wieder. Wieder. Ich wollte gerade bei Ralf ein schönes Sterbedatum eintragen.
Ja, Matt Malik, ihr habt das eben alles eingetütet.
So.
Ja, mich hast du aber schon in der letzten Sendung überzeugt.
Ich habe auch gedacht, stimmt, wieso geht das eigentlich nicht? Und wieso ist das?
Okay, pass auf, kleiner Rant. Warum ist das Betriebssystem eigentlich nicht
viel schlauer, wenn es doch schon weiß, wer die Person ist, wo der Ort ist und
so weiter? Und angeblich ist Siri ja so super klug und führt das alles zusammen.
Mir ist jetzt zweimal folgendes passiert. Also ich wohne in Aachen,
meine Freundin wohnt in Köln.
Das sind 90 Kilometer, ich bin da schon tausendmal hingefahren.
Mein Handy lernt ja angeblich mit, was man alles so tut. Gut,
was ich mache, ich mache Carplay ans Auto und sage dann, navigiere mich zu Freundin Arbeit.
Ich sage etwas anderes, ich nenne sie nicht Freundin, aber jetzt mal so.
Und dann macht er sofort, sucht halt raus aus der Kontaktkarte,
wo diese Arbeitsstelle ist, wo ich sie abholen soll.
Da ist eine Straße, eine Hausnummer, eine Postleitzahl und Köln.
Das ist absolut eindeutig. Auf dieser Welt findet jeder und sein Onkel diese
Adresse. Gut, und das funktioniert auch.
98% der Fälle. Und in diesen 2% sage ich exakt den gleichen Triggersatz,
sitze im gleichen Auto, fahre an der gleichen Stelle los und möchte zur gleichen
Stelle wie tausendmal vorher,
fahre los, der Weg sieht gut aus, jetzt wird es richtig perfide,
der Weg sieht gut aus, ich fahre Richtung Köln, eine Stunde über diese Autobahn
und plötzlich, kurz bevor ich weiß, wo ich eigentlich abfahren muss,
will er, dass ich woanders abfahre.
Und ich denk so, ach das ist vielleicht Stau, Umgehung, bin fast geneigt das
Lenkrad rumzureißen, noch den LKW auszubremsen und so und denke dann grad so,
ne warte mal, der fährt ja in den Norden, ich muss aber irgendwie in den Süden, WTF, gucke nach,
steht original die richtige Straßenadresse, Hausnummer, aber wieso zeigt der
auf der Karte das im Norden Kölns an?
Immer blöd auf der Autobahn solche Probleme zu fixen. Faktionen zu lösen, ja.
Gut, was ist es? Köln hat halt von dieser kompliziert klingenden Straße zwei.
In Berlin gibt es ja sicher auch fünfmal die Schulstraße oder so. Ja, ja.
Genau, aber das ist jetzt eine komplexere Straße. Davon haben sie zwei.
Aber wenn man die Postleitzahl im Adressbuch dabei hat, ist es eindeutig,
ist absolut eindeutig. Aber ab und zu guckt Siri einfach nicht nach der Postleitzahl
und führt mich natürlich auch zu dem anderen Ding.
Obwohl sie es die Woche davor und die Woche davor und die Woche davor immer
richtig gemacht hat. Auch sich darin orientiert.
Also wenn wir noch diese Probleme haben, willkommen Apple Intelligence, sag ich mal.
Es kommt alles in Ordnung mit dem Angreifen von Apple Intelligence.
Neunter, neunter.
Ich musste eben so kichern, als du Friend Feed gesagt hast.
Wieso?
Irgendwie das Organisierte. Kennst du noch Friend Face?
Nee. Also glaube ich zumindest nicht. Nee, Friendface?
Link or it didn't happen.
Link or it didn't happen. What is Friendface? Friendface is a great new site for meeting.
Does it work? Friendface works along the same principle as a cold or a terrible plague.
But it's not disgusting germs that Friendface spreads, it's friendship.
Each Friendface page is like a Petri dish filled with friendship germs.
When you stick your face into the dish, you may come away with millions of other
people attached to your face. Das ist richtig.
Now it's just love and companionship and everything's fine. We own everything
you put on Friendface. It says so in the terms of agreement.
But don't worry about that. We won't use it to do anything bad. We promise.
Just think about love and companionship and everything's fine.
Friendface. Friendface. Friendface.
Der Font ist korrekt.
Schön. Du weißt, woher das ist?
Ja, ja, es ist The AT Crowd. Ich habe es gerade gesehen. Hätte ich jetzt aber nicht parat gehabt.
Ja.
Aber natürlich auch totale Anschauerempfehlung, also wenn man immer den Eindruck
hatte, dass irgendwie hier Big Bang Theory alles schon so weich gespült und
so ist. The IT Crowd so die erste Season.
Gibt alle Antworten zum Nerd-Dasein, die man wissen muss.
In Teilen auch noch die zweite. Das ist schon eine sehr, sehr epische Serie.
Das kann man sehr gut machen. Meine Lieblingsfolge ist ja, ich glaube,
das ist die letzte in der ersten Season so, wo sie das Internet zerstören.
This is the Internet. Das ist schon alles auch härter an der Realität, als man es gerne hätte.
Ja, IT-Crout ist super und hat auch wirklich so Folgen, die so ein bisschen beyond sind.
Also nicht nur an sich lustig, es ist auch darüber hinaus noch auf der Meta-Ebene
lustig. Also großartig.
So, das dazu, wie Computer darüber nachdenken.
Womit wollen wir weitermachen?
Ich würde sagen, jetzt kann doch mal Malik mit seinem großen,
langen Thema kommen, oder?
Wollen wir nicht erst über Events reden? Wir haben so viele Events.
Oder hol ich mir noch schnell ein Bierchen und dann, oder du führst schon mal ein.
Ich führ schon mal ein ins Event-Wesen. Ja, also es gibt einige Events in der nächsten Zeit.
Eins davon ist Podstock, das hatten wir hier schon mal erwähnt.
Das ist so ein kleines Community-Draußentreffen, was der Sebastian organisiert.
Das ist ganz nett. Ich werde da sein.
Ich weiß nicht, Ralf, warst du schon mal auf dem Potsdark? Nein.
Nein? Du auch nicht, Malik, oder? Nee, okay, gut.
Ist gemütlich und so weiter. Ein paar Vorträge wird viel so live gepodcastet
und so weiter und rumgefummelt. und ich werde halt da sein und habe einen Workshop
angemeldet und zwar Ultraschall-Editing-Techniques.
Hört nicht auf Tim.
Er schneidet alles in kleine Schnipsel.
Naja, es sind meine Editing-Techniques, die haben schon was für sich, denke ich mal.
Also ich habe keinen großen Plan, ich werde einfach mir irgendeinen Rohdiamanten
aus meinem Recording-Archiv nehmen und dann einfach live zeigen,
wie ich damit umgehe und wie ich da schneide und damit vorgehe.
Einfach so aus so einem praktischen Ding heraus.
Weil darum geht es ja bei solchen Veranstaltungen. Also das wollte ich euch
nur mal erzählen, wo ihr ja alle so ultraschallig seid, aber ihr seid ja der
Meinung, ich benutze das Programm falsch.
Aber es ist ungewöhnlich, wie du es nutzt, sagen wir mal so.
Aber ich meine, wir geben dir
ja die Möglichkeit ist, auch genau so zu nutzen. Von daher, alles fein.
Ungewöhnlich, findest du das?
Naja, schon. Also, vielleicht für diejenigen, die das jetzt nicht so richtig vor dem Kopf haben.
Also normalerweise, wenn man so ein Audio aufnimmt, egal ob jetzt ein oder mehrere
Spulen, hat man ja so einen großen, langen Audioschlauch und dann hat man da
halt die, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ist es die Wellenform oder die Hüllkurve?
Ne, es ist die Wellenform.
Hüllkurve ist mit Attack, Release und so weiter.
Also mit der Wellenform und was Tim jetzt halt macht, ist, dass er das halt
zerhackt in In fast Sätze oder sowas könnte man sagen.
Und dafür nutzt er halt eine Funktion, die Reaper, was ja die Basis unten drunter
ist unter Ultraschall, einfach schon immer bereitgestellt hat.
Und wir haben ein bisschen an den Parametern geschraubt.
Dass bei einer normal ausgesteuerten Aufnahme er das halt entlang von Pausen zerschneidet.
Das heißt also, wenn jetzt jemand längere Zeit nichts sagt, wird dann ein Cut
gemacht und die Pause quasi schon automatisch weggelöscht.
Und es bleiben dann also nur noch die informationstragenden Elemente übrig.
Im Idealfall, ja.
Genau. Und die nutzen halt Tim dafür, um beispielsweise mal so etwas längere,
peinliche Pausen irgendwie einfach dann schnell zusammenzuschieben.
Weil wir haben ja auch diesen Edit-Modus, dass man einfach ein Element greift
und mit einem zusätzlichen Shortcut, wenn man dann dieses Element verschiebt,
verschieben sich auch sämtliche Elemente dahinter auf allen anderen Spuren gleich mit,
sodass man also trotzdem immer ein konstantes Audio über mehrere Spuren hat, alles sowas.
So, und das sieht aber halt erstmal ein bisschen wild aus, weil in wie viele
Items hast du das mal gezählt?
So eine 4-Stunden-Freakshow, du zerschneidest, dürften etliche hundert sein, oder?
Wenn dir das so rumkommt. Ja, locker. Und es wirkt erstmal so,
als könnte da eine ganze Menge schief gehen, weil was man halt nie haben will,
ist, dass sich halt Spuren zueinander halt verschieben und dann plötzlich Leute,
alle übereinander quasseln und so.
Ab und zu hört man solche Schnittfehler da draußen ja auch mal in the wild.
Ja, aber das wird jetzt dadurch nicht schwerer. Also ich meine,
du musst halt trotzdem alles richtig machen.
Das ist gar nicht so das Problem dabei. Also es hat verschiedene Gründe, warum ich das mache.
Erstmal hast du dadurch natürlich schon mal eine bessere Kanaltrennung.
Also ich identifiziere halt viele Störgeräusche.
Also was ich machst dir keine Vorstellung, wie viel Schnalzer ich von dir rausnehme in jeder Sendung.
So, so.
Also du bist so ein Mensch.
Trink mehr.
Genau. Und die kann ich damit sehr gut isolieren, weil die sind dann immer am Anfang davon.
Die sehe ich schon. Also überhaupt dadurch, dass ich auch hier diese spektrale
Einfärbung nutze, kann ich halt auch bestimmte, ich sehe schon vorher, was es ist.
Vielleicht auch das kurz beschrieben, weil man das auch selten sieht.
Reaper hat einen Modus, wo man nicht nur eine einfarbige Wellenform sieht,
sondern die jeweils dominante Frequenz dieses kleinen Soundabschnitts durch
eine Farbeinfärbung sichtbar gemacht wird.
Das heißt, es ist also sehr tief, wenn ich so mache oder irgendwie so ein hoher S lautet.
Ja, oder es ist Atmen oder Seufzen.
Das sieht man dann entlang der Wellenform schon.
Genau, also da schaue ich drauf wie so eine AI quasi.
Und das hilft mir auch beim Schneiden, das hilft mir zum Beispiel auch,
um Repetitionen zu finden.
Also wenn jemand wirklich einen Satz dreimal anfängt, dann funktioniert das.
Muss ich da gar nicht groß hören. Ich sehe das. Und das Geilste ist,
dadurch, dass ich ein Häppchen habe, kann ich halt schön mit Altcursor von Satzanfang
zu Satzanfang springen.
Und so höre ich die Sendung im Turbomodus durch.
Ich höre eine Freakshow durch, aber nicht alles, sondern ich gehe die Anfänge durch.
Ich muss aber auch nicht viel hören. Ich sehe ja schon, ob es passt.
Ich sehe Ich sehe einfach meine Pappenheimer schon von vornherein.
Ich sehe den Schnalzer, ich sehe das Stöhnen, ich sehe das Mikrofonrapseln.
Wenn du das jetzt rausnimmst, dann...
Naja, ich weiß, aber da werde ich ja drauf achten, weil I know.
An der Stelle würde ich jetzt nämlich zum Beispiel einen Marker setzen.
Du willst ja während der Sendung keine Marker setzen, ne?
Ja, doch, nee, ich setze auch Marker, ich kann jetzt auch einen Marker setzen.
Also auch Schnittmarker, nicht nur Kapitel.
Ja genau, also all diese ganzen Sachen, die ich mir so in den letzten Jahren
zugelegt habe, insbesondere während Corona, weil da war Corona insofern hilfreich,
als das ja dann auf einmal alles remote war.
Und remote hat quasi dafür gesorgt, dass die Kanaltrennung perfekt war.
Da konnte man sehr viel mehr experimentieren, aber mittlerweile habe ich das,
was ich da mit mir erarbeitet habe, auch jetzt hier für die In-Room-Aufnahme
auch gemacht, arbeite mehr mit Silence hier mit Noisegates, genau,
beziehungsweise eigentlich ist es ja ein Expander aber egal, Details,
und ja und das ist vielleicht hilfreich darüber will ich mal reden,
man muss es nicht so machen wie ich es mache und nicht alle werden das als notwendig
erachten, aber ich fühle mich sehr wohl damit und ich habe vor allem,
eine interessante Querlesemethode.
Was zum Beispiel auch ist, um wenn man nicht weiß, wie man die Sendung nennen soll.
Gibt es halt Stellen, die ich visuell erkennen kann, wo unter Umständen ein
Titelkandidat ist. Nämlich wenn alle lachen.
Und alle lachen sehe ich halt auch, weil auf einmal da auf allen Kanälen die
Würste sind und Und nicht nur einer.
Also es gibt halt einfach verschiedenste Indikatoren dafür, was gerade in so
einer Sendung passiert ist. Und ich kann halt Stellen gut wiederfinden.
Nach meinem alten Mantra, weiß ja, Internet, man kann Sachen gut finden,
aber nicht wie gut wiederfinden.
Also alles, was eine gute Wiederfindbarkeit aufweist, ist für mich in meinem
Prozess eine sehr wertvolle Geschichte.
Und naja, deswegen ist es halt so ein Teil.
Und natürlich würde ich mich freuen, wenn auch,
sagen wir mal so, für diese etwas advancedere Bearbeitungsmethode quasi mir
dieses Programm auch noch weiter entgegenkommen würde oder bestimmte Fehler verhindert,
aber das ist halt etwas, was ich nur interaktiv...
Machen kann. Sowas kann ich nicht in irgendwelche Github-Issues reinschreiben oder so.
Man muss da irgendjemanden haben, der nicht voll labern kann. Sprechendes Denken.
Ich merke, ich erkenne mich in vielem wieder, was du erzählt hast.
Ich sehe auch die Äs und diese Schmatzer und so. Oder wenn Leute lachen.
Aber an anderen Sachen sozusagen. Bei dir sind die Kurven ganz gut komprimiert, glaube ich.
Man sieht, wenn jemand spricht, aber da ist die Wurst relativ gleich dick.
Bei mir ist sozusagen das Pegel hoch runter oder vielleicht erst beim Normalisieren.
Ja, das hat einen anderen Grund. Ich benutze nämlich die exponentielle Ansicht.
Also bei mir sind die leisen Sachen sowieso schon größer, damit ich auch einen
leichten Noise-Floor sehen kann und ich habe keine lineare Darstellung.
Dann kann ich nämlich gerade so mein Noisegate sehr gut triggern,
weil ich halt auch noch die kleinsten Dinger sehe,
die ich sonst halt nicht sehen würde, jetzt würde ich mir halt noch wünschen,
dass die Kurve nicht nur nach oben und unten geht einfach den Platz besser nutzt,
so weniger Ränder, also es gibt da noch
viel, was man besser machen kann aber das ist jetzt auch schwierig zu erläutern
im Podcast, ich würde eigentlich nur sagen, da ist irgendwie einiges zu holen
und darüber werde ich dann halt auf dem Podstock reden und mal gucken.
Vielleicht, nächstes Thema, mache ich den ja auch auf dem Subscribe 11.
So. Jetzt müssen wir nochmal Werbung machen.
Gerne.
Ich habe ja schon letzte Woche ganz viel Werbung gemacht. War das letzte Woche? Vorletzte Woche, ne?
Dein Audiodump? Ja, vielleicht. Was ist Zeit?
Genau.
Also, genau. Wir haben es ja schon ausführlich erwähnt, aber ich erwähne es
nochmal im Oktober. Subscribe 11.
Für alle, die so Podcast-affin sind und sich gerne mit solchen Sachen beschäftigen,
bitte weiter sagen, diese Konferenz findet statt in Berlin und es wird toll.
Auch weil die Location so geil ist.
Auch weil die Location so geil ist. Und du kommst ja wahrscheinlich auch.
Nee, ich komme nämlich wahrscheinlich nicht. Ach, das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Ja, genau. Das ist genau das, was ich über mich selber denke.
Das ist nicht mein Ernst. Ich werde es, glaube ich, nicht hinbekommen und denke
die ganze Zeit, du sitzt bei uns im Podcast, machst den Mund wässrig.
Ich denke so, ja, genau so muss es sein. Ich will einmal Ralf bei einer Keynote live sehen.
Ja, das ist ein Ereignis.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man auch selber noch an dem Ding so ein bisschen mitgebastelt
hat und so. Ist da noch jemand anders da vom Ultraschall-Team?
Mio wird da sein, auf jeden Fall am Samstag. Und Udo, denke ich mal, wird da sein.
Genau, bei den anderen weiß ich auch aus dem Doku-Team, hoffentlich auch,
unserem neuen Doku-Team. Also von daher.
Wobei Udo hat ein bisschen Street-Credibility jetzt verloren.
Er wohnt nämlich nicht mehr in Wacken. Das ist für mich persönlich ein bisschen
schwer. Ich hab immer gern bei ihm übernachtet.
Bei solchen Gelegenheiten. Und dann kommst du nachts nach Hause und er hat einfach
Schnitzel gemacht. Und irgendwie mit so einem liebevollen Zettelchen jeden auf
den Küchentisch hinterlassen.
Okay, wir schweifen ab. Also auf jeden Fall, genau.
Ich bedauere das und bin der Meinung, mehr Subscribes.
Aber diese Subscribe jetzt, so, was bietet sie, außer eure beiden,
ja, Keynote stimmt ja nicht, also eine Keynote für Ultraschall,
ganz nah dran am Metall und du selber machst deinen Workshop und es gibt ja bestimmt noch mehr.
Oder wird da jetzt schon fleißig eingereicht? Was ist denn so das Update seit der Audiodump?
Es wird eingereicht Ich könnte noch ein bisschen fleißiger eingereicht werden,
aber das wird sich schon noch ergeben. Da bin ich ganz beruhigt.
Ich habe es immer besonders gemocht, diese ganzen dynamisch entstehenden Workshops zu sehen.
Also dass viele Leute vor Ort erst so sagen, ah ja, hier, das würde ich gerne mal anbieten.
Und dann haben wir ja so ein bisschen abgefragt, wen würde das interessieren,
etc. Manches wird auch schon vorgeplant.
Aber natürlich ist vor allem...
Ralf ist ja jetzt gezwungen, quasi endlich mal wieder einen Ultraschall-Release zu machen.
Und ich hoffe auch, dass bei Podlove was zu zeigen sein wird.
Also der Erik, der Podlove ja im Wesentlichen, nicht alleine,
aber im Wesentlichen den Publisher gemacht hat, wird da sein und wird mal ein Overview geben.
Und generell sind vor allem die Gruppen sind halt da, also das Hotlabs Team
ist halt da, man kann da einfach mal vor Ort mal reden und,
warum geht das nicht, warum könnte man nicht und so weiter und ich meine,
Ralf wird dann wieder keine Zeit haben für meine Ultraschall-Wows aber das ist
ja ein anderes Thema ja Merkst.
Du da ein Muster?
Ich bin ein harter, ich meine, ich versuche jetzt wirklich seit fünf Jahren
diesen Termin zu bekommen. Ich finde, ich bin jetzt langsam mal dran.
Du kannst ja jetzt mal meine Geschäftsstelle anfragen.
Dann wimmeln die mich ab.
Also, subscribe, elf kommt alle. Es gibt Essen.
Das fand ich übrigens auch noch erwähnenswert, dass im Preis lecker Essen drin
ist, mit Abendessen, Frühstück und genau, man kann sich da schön,
auch wenn man, wie ich es gerade ja bin, wenn man nicht aus Berlin ist,
ist das halt eine relevante Größe. Wo kriege ich dann Essen her?
Wenn ich mich nicht auskenne und so weiter. Das fand ich super.
Das war einer der besseren Upgrades, die wir mal gemacht haben,
für die Subscriber, zu sagen, so, es zerfasert jetzt nicht abends,
weil jeder irgendwie unterschiedliche Vorstellungen hat, sondern wir behalten
die Leute alle vor Ort und man besorgt einen Caterer,
der dem gerecht wird und noch ein bisschen übererfüllt.
Und dann hat man wirklich die kompletten Abende, insbesondere dann da wirklich
noch alle beisammen. Das ist gut und wichtig.
Haben wir einen Link drin?
Hoffentlich. Soll es mal einreihen. So, ich mache morgen, nee,
stimmt gar nicht, übermorgen halte ich auch noch einen Vortrag auf noch einer
Podcast- Veranstaltung, die ich selber noch gar nicht kenne oder von der ich zwar gehört habe,
aber noch nie da war. Nämlich das Podfest.
Das findet hier in Berlin statt. Und das ist so eine Community,
die mir gar nicht so gewahr, also ich weiß, dass es die gibt,
aber ich verfolge die jetzt nicht so.
Also es gibt nämlich in Berlin eine extrem starke internationale Podcast-Community.
Also von Menschen aus aller Welt, die halt in Berlin leben, aber die dann in
der Regel halt nicht auf Deutsch und bevorzugt vermutlich auf Englisch podcasten.
Da gibt es ja sowohl diverse Projekte und aus dieser Community heraus gibt es
dann halt auch dieses Podfest.
Funktioniert ein bisschen anders, das läuft über mehrere Tage an einer Location.
Es gibt dann nur einen Track und jeder Vortrag oder jeder Workshop oder jedes
Ding, was da drin stattfindet, ist quasi auch ein Event in sich.
Das heißt, es gibt dann auch so Dinge, wie dass du quasi ein Ticket nur für
dieses eine Ding und der der oder diejenige, die das halt veranstaltet, bestimmt,
ob das jetzt was kostet oder ob das nichts kostet oder ob das nur zum Spenden ist und so.
Ist auch alles relativ überschaubar. Ich glaube, der Raum hat so eine Kapazität von 60 Leuten.
Es scheint da alles ganz gemütlich zu sein und der Daniel Stern,
der das organisiert, der auch hier so Comedian ist, das ist ein Amerikaner,
der hier in Berlin lebt, der hat mich irgendwie angesprochen und da habe ich
gesagt, okay, da mache ich doch einfach mal ein Talk.
Das heißt, ich werde einen Talk auf Englisch machen.
Und.
Ich habe es genannt, Things are more interesting in the dark.
Und ich will mal eine Herleitung machen über die Entwicklung der Kommunikationskultur,
die zu Podcasts geführt hat, mit einem Rückblick bis in die 80er Jahre.
Also so diese Internetkommunikationsentfaltung und was eigentlich so die einzelnen
Dinge gewesen sind, die dazu geführt haben, dass es am Ende Podcasts gibt.
Das ist so meine grobe Klammer. genau kann ich es ja noch nicht sagen,
weil es ist ja noch zwei Tage hin gehen wir nicht davon aus,
dass ich schon fertig bin,
ich muss ja erstmal drei Stunden auf so einen Stein starren und in Panik verfallen
und dann mache ich das so in einer halben Stunde wie immer.
Irgendwas mit RSS mhm ja, das machen wir auch noch hast du gesagt wo das ist?
Das ist im House of Color in Berlin, das ist irgendwo am Südstern ich packe einen Link
rein, ich hatte das auch schon hier gepostet, getrutet, gesendet, gemacht, getan.
Ich muss jetzt nur noch rauskriegen, wie ich hier diesen Link kopiere.
Könnt ihr, wenn du nichts mehr dazu hast, sonst in der Zeit schon mal weitermachen.
Ja, mach mal weiter.
Ich würde sagen.
Hast du einen Termin? Ansonsten hätte ich nicht noch einen Termin.
Nee, kein Termin.
Weil wir bei Terminen sind.
Genau.
Ich bin nächsten Samstag, also schwierige Definition, also nicht diesen Samstag,
sondern den danach kommenden Samstag nach der nächsten Woche.
Hat der eine Zahl. Woche.
Ja, ich gucke mal gerade eben, was sagt denn der Kalender, ist das der 14.
Du bist doch fest eingestellt, du musst sagen KW.
Das ist der 14. Genau, in der KW 37 am Samstag, dem 14.
September, findet in der Seabase hier in Berlin der Berlin Fediverse Day statt.
Also rund um Fediverse und Mastodon und was es sonst noch so alles gibt.
Mit Eugen.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob Eugen kommt, ist eine gute Frage. Wäre schön.
Ich glaube also, bisher ist er aber noch zumindest nicht auf der Speakerliste.
Aber ich stehe da drauf. Ich halte dann einen Vortrag mit dem Felix Ostrovsky,
der mit mir zusammen in der Stabi gearbeitet hat und wir erzählen dort was über
unsere Bibliotheks-Mastodon-Instanz OpenBibioSocial und wie wir das hochgezogen
haben und was da so die Erfahrungen sind und was wir da ein Blech hinter haben
und wie viel Moderationsaufwand das ist.
Und wir werden das Ganze versuchen, so ein bisschen politisch einzurahmen in,
warum zum Teufel machen eigentlich nicht mehr Leute im öffentlichen Dienst an
solchen Ansatzweise, Entscheider, Positionen mal etwas mehr für ein dezentrales, freies Internet.
Und von daher, falls ihr da Lust habt, ein bisschen irgendwie über Mastodon
zu fachsimpeln oder ähnliches, das ist sicherlich nochmal eine gute Adresse.
Seabase ist da sowieso immer ein Besuch wert. Das Ganze ist kostenlos. Schaut rein.
Das mache ich mal bei meinem nächsten Berlin-Besuch. Ich war auch noch nie in der Seabase.
Was?
Ja, I know. Gott. Den habe ich mir gefragt, ne? Ja. Das war Nick Snyder vor ein paar Tagen. Was?
Und dann sagt er, er kommt noch nicht mal zu The Subscribed.
Du musst einfach mal ein paar Monate Urlaub machen hier.
Verstehst du? Eben habe ich erstmal...
Du hast so die Basics abgedeckt kriegen. Genau.
Ja, ich meine, so ein bisschen Vocation. Weißt du, einfach mal so hier.
Man sieht ja, wenn man so zusammensitzt, kommt man schneller zum Ergebnis.
Aber es ist also, ich fühle es ja, weil also als ich noch nicht in Berlin war
und mit Claudia irgendwie,
da waren wir glaube ich beim WMR-Hörertreffen irgendwie und sind wir nach Berlin
gefahren und saßen dann da irgendwo im Park und dann kam auch die Rede auf die
Seabays und ich wusste auch überhaupt nicht, was die Seabays ist.
Aber was passiert dann? Alle sagen, du weißt nicht, wo die Seabays ist.
Und das nächste ist, alle stürzen sich aufs Fahrrad und fahren in die Seabays.
Und dann haben wir also eine Deluxe-Führung bekommen.
Dann können wir ja auf dem Rückweg noch in der CBS vorbei.
Das macht mal. Ich hab Zeit.
Ja, weil man muss wirklich wissen, ich bin jetzt eine Woche in Berlin hier und
ich hab mir wirklich alles gegeben, was man mit Füßen bei 33 Grad leisten kann.
Also wir reden von 10.000 bis 20.000 Schritten am Tag.
Und ich bin wirklich, ich hab alles versucht, aber man kann irgendwie,
Berlin ist erstaunlich groß.
Das ist irgendwie, man kann nicht den Schlachtensee und dann irgendwie die so
und so E-Mobility-Konferenz auf dem Tempelhofer Feld und dann noch hier beim
Podcast vorbeigucken und das kann man irgendwie gar nicht alles an einem Tag machen.
War der E-Mobility-Event?
Ja, genau, ICNC heißt das Ding, das ist so ein B2B-Event und da war ich dann
wie die Jungfrau zum Kinde, weil alter Mit-Podcaster Julien hat halt gesagt,
ach, du bist in Berlin, ja, ich bin auch in Berlin, ich weiß,
dass er, er arbeitet so im E-Mobility-Business und ich weiß,
dass er öfter in Berlin ist und er sagte, du weißt, dass die weltgrößte,
was weiß ich, E-Mobility-Dings da an dem Tag ist und ich so.
Nö, Gott, ne.
ICNC ICNC ICNC24,
von Hubject ausgerichtet aber das ist jetzt schon sehr in the weeds,
ja, das ist aber ein reines B2B Ding und wir kommen noch dazu,
ich habe auch mit ein bisschen E-Mobility noch zu tun mit dieser Ladefuchs App
und hab dann gedacht, okay, das könnte gar nicht so eine schlechte Idee sein
und wie es dann so ist, man kommt auf so ein Ding und kennt sofort 10 Leute also.
Ja, du hast ja dann jetzt auch im Nachgang auch richtige E-Mobilität kennengelernt.
Ja, genau. Jetzt weiß ich auch, wie das ist, wenn man auf so einer Rakete ohne
Rauch irgendwie durch Berlin jagt. Darf ich Details?
Bitte, du darfst.
Du warst ja schon mal bei Clean Electric zu Besuch, um von deiner BMW CE 04
zu berichten, dem Elektrogeschoss, was sich Motorrad nennt, aber das kann man,
manche sagen so, manche sagen so.
Ich jedenfalls auf dem Sozius, habe ich noch nie in meinem Leben gemacht übrigens
und ich weiß natürlich schon, was Elektromotoren so zu leisten vermögen.
Wenn du dann aber dem ausgesetzt bist, in einem T-Shirt durch Berlin schlängelnd,
an allen Autos vorbei, links, rechts, drunter oder drüber.
Ich sag mal, die Bullen haben wir auch. Wir haben auch unsere Freunde und Helfer
hinter uns lassen können.
Ich hatte auch nicht die ganze Zeit Todesangst, weil sich das abgewechselt hat
mit den Krämpfen in den Händen, als ich halt versucht habe, mich irgendwo an
diesem Motorrad festzuklappern, ohne mir die Blöße zu geben,
jetzt um Tims Bauch zu greifen. Weil dann merkt das ja.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall hier angekommen, ich bin sehr dankbar,
aber wenn ihr nach der Rückfahrt, also ab der Seabase von mir,
nie mehr was hören solltet, wisst ihr BMW CE 04.
Ja, du lachst.
Ja, war doch schön.
Es war super schön, aber wie du am Anfang gesagt hast, die Schwierigkeit ist,
dass ich während ich fahre ja weiß, was ich tue, also wann ich bremse und wann ich Vollstrom gebe.
Ihr kennt dieses Achterbahn-Gefühl, oder wie ist das, diese Falltürme.
Du wirst da langsam hochgezogen, du weißt, es wird passieren und dann macht
es diesen Ruck und dann bist du halt irgendwo 200 Meter weiter.
Und ungefähr ist es so, wenn Tim einen dann abholt, weil ich gesagt habe,
oh, wenn ich zu dir fahre, muss ich viermal umsteigen, Bus, ÖPNV. Och, ich hole dich ab.
Konnte ja keiner ahnen, dass das Letzte ist, was ich tue. Aber genau,
C-Light schreibt auch gerade, ha Malik, du hattest auch das Vergnügen. Nice.
Er hatte mir nämlich noch, wir hatten ein Audiodump-Hörertreffen in Berlin,
weil ich meine, klar, macht ja alles in Berlin.
Und da meinte er noch zu mir, ja, bin auch mal mit Tim gefahren.
Er hatte irgendwie so einen ganz auffällig trockenen Mund und diese blasse Gesichtswabe.
Aber ich habe halt gedacht, gut, klar, Corona, das Alter, Rauchen.
Aber Tim lacht, als hätte er ganz genau gewusst.
Du hast nur deswegen die Karre gekauft.
Ja, danke für die Warnung. Ich bin ja ein Schisser, was so Mobilität angeht.
Dann weiß ich schon mal, wo ich mich nicht drauf begeben werde.
Aber ich sage mal, Tim ist auf jeden Fall das beste Airbag, den ich jemals vor mir hatte.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, wenn ihr schon einfach mit den letzten Sekunden,
ihr fahrt durch diesen Tunnel des Lebens und ihr fahrt auf dieses Licht zu,
aber währenddessen hört ihr einen Podcast von Tim Pridler, der euch erzählt,
wie viel 7,5 Kilowattstunden Durchschnitt auf seine 18.000 Kilometer die Karre halt jetzt braucht.
Gut, so kann man auch abdrehen, meine Meinung.
Klar Also, Seelight rudert zurück Er will nicht direkt aus dem Slack gebannt
werden Nein, ganz so war es nicht, ich fahre gerne mit Tim Hab da gar kein Problem,
Naja.
Also auf jeden Fall Ich mag das schon Diese Art des Reisens Das lief mir sehr Ich.
War in diesem Elektroflugzeug, Tim Aber nie hatte ich Angst um mein Leben Wie auf der Fahrt nach hier,
Du übertreibst So Kann ich doch was von dem Ozon haben,
Okay.
Jetzt haben wir Wo waren wir?
Du wolltest erklären, warum du überhaupt nach Berlin gekommen bist Man macht
so viel in Berlin Mancher fliegt es halt an einem vorbei.
Ja, genau. Eine der Sachen, ach jetzt wollte ich eigentlich, machen wir später.
Okay, also soll ich euch mal was über Elektromobilität erzählen?
Ihr kriegt nämlich jetzt, ich hab da was vorbereitet. Ich bin fast wie Ralf.
Ich hab wirklich einmal in einem Podcast was vorbereitet. Das Problem ist,
mir wird das vorgeworfen.
Regelmäßig.
Ich bin Fan. Ich finde, du machst das super. Also, ich, aber ihr habt mich natürlich
Freakshow-mäßig unterlaufen.
Das Problem ist folgendes. Ich kam hier an, also ein ganzes Team hat jetzt...
Ich habe buchstäblich monatelang an diesem Moment gearbeitet,
dass ich hier sitze und gleich etwas für euch präsentiere, weil in der Freakshow ist ja Roddy dabei.
Und Roddy war sehr lange im Ladefuchsteam.
Ich erkläre gleich nochmal kurz, was der Ladefuchs ist. Und dann habe ich gedacht,
ich komme nach hier und kann etwas auch zu Roddy mitbringen und jetzt ist Roddy in der Ukraine.
Danke Roddy für nichts, aber wir haben es jedenfalls versucht.
Gut, wir haben nur ein paar Monate daran gearbeitet, dann kriegen es halt alle
anderen. Also, was ist der Ladefuchs?
Alle, die elektrisch fahren, wissen es wahrscheinlich. Alle auf der Messe,
auf der ich war, sagten auch so, oh, Ladefuchs habe ich auf dem Handy.
Das war sehr schön, mal in einer Community zu sein, wo jeder dein Produkt kennt,
weil in meiner normalen Welt kennt niemand dieses Produkt.
Es ist so, ihr habt ein Elektroauto oder ein Elektromotorrad und ihr müsst ab
und zu laden und sagen wir mal, ihr könnt das nicht zu Hause tun,
dann müsst ihr öffentlich laden.
Das sind diese Ladesäulen, die überall rumstehen.
Habt ihr vielleicht schon mal gesehen bei Aldi oder einfach am Straßenrand.
So und das Problem in der E-Mobilität ist einfach,
dass es die Leute gibt, die diese Säulen hinstellen und euch Strom liefern, man nennt die CPOs,
Charge Point Operator und dann gibt es aber die Leute, die euch einen Tarif
verkaufen, damit ihr eine Karte an diese Säule halten könnt und dort Strom auch beziehen könnt.
Denn nur weil einer eine Säule da hinstellt, heißt das noch nicht,
dass du bei denen direkt auch den Strom kaufen kannst.
Da braucht man so diese Mittelsmänner, die heißen EMSP oder ja,
gibt es verschiedene, EMP sagen manche auch.
Also, das heißt, es gibt so Leute, die machen so extra Ladekarten.
Ihr denkt jetzt, ja wie, ich habe doch eine Kreditkarte und eine Girokarte und
Apple Pay ist doch total easy.
In zwei, drei Jahren vielleicht und an manchen Säulen gibt es das schon,
aber in den letzten fünf Jahren im Prinzip nein.
Also man kann nicht einfach an eine Säule gehen und dort Strom kaufen. Leider.
Dann hatten viele Leute angefangen, irgendwelche Ladetarife zu entwickeln.
Unter anderem zum Beispiel mein Stadtwerker Aachen, die heißen Stavag.
Ich bin Kunde dort, die liefern Strom, die bauen Ladesäulen und die machen auch so eine Karte.
Also manche machen die Säule und die Karte. Jetzt bin ich da Kunde und dann
kriege ich da irgendeinen Tarif bei denen. Was mache ich aber jetzt,
wenn ich von Aachen zum Beispiel nach Berlin fahre auf die Subscribe 11?
Dann komme ich da also an, habe meine Aachener Karte im Auto und möchte aber
in Berlin jetzt Strom ziehen.
Dann müsste ja der Aachener Kartenfuzzi mit dem Berliner Stromladesäulenfuzzi irgendwie sprechen.
Das nennt man Roaming, wie bei den Handys. So, das Problem ist,
das ist natürlich ein Zoo.
Es gibt 500 von diesen, ich glaube wir haben 300 irgendwas von diesen Karten.
Jedes Stadtwerk macht eine, jede kleine Firma, die sich gedacht hat,
sie könnte damit Geld verdienen, macht eine und natürlich auch jeder CPO,
also jeder Ladesäulenanbieter macht eine.
Und jetzt hast du diesen Zoo an Karten und diesen Kleingartenverein,
diesen Flickenteppich an Ladesäulen und willst aber natürlich mit einem Auto
von Stadt A nach Stadt B fahren, dort laden und auch wieder zurückkommen.
Und das ist ein riesiges Problem.
Eins davon, also es sind viele Probleme, ein Problem davon lösen wir mit dem
Ladefuchs und zwar ist die Frage, was kostet mich das? Und der Witz ist,
Es kostet sehr, sehr viel Unterschied. Da sind 200% Preisunterschiede möglich.
Und das ist natürlich dann gar nicht witzig. Bei so einer Tankstelle seid ihr
ja gewöhnt, da sind irgendwie 5 Cent drauf oder runter oder 3.
Und da sind es halt einfach, ob du 39 Cent oder 89 Cent bezahlst pro Kilowattstunde,
macht echt einen Unterschied dann. Und das würde man gerne wissen.
Jetzt gibt es aber niemanden, der einem das sagt.
Beim Tanken hat der Staat gesagt, liefert uns stundengenau oder so eure Preise
eurer Tankstelle, dann kann jemand eine App bauen und dann könnt ihr nachgucken,
wie sich die Preise entwickeln.
Bei Elektromobilität gibt es das noch nicht.
Und deswegen, ja, weil ich selber das Problem habe, ich kann nur öffentlich
laden, will ich also vor, ich komme vor so einer Säule an, vor der Subscribe natürlich,
möchte jetzt mein Auto laden, ziehe meine 10 Karten aus meinem Auto und möchte
jetzt wissen, was kostet mich das?
Dann nehme ich also den Ladefuchs, ladefuchs.app, kann man hier mal irgendwie
reinwerfen und gucke, ich wähle einfach unten sozusagen die Säule aus,
vor der ich stehe, da steht dann zum Beispiel Berliner Stadtwerke,
dann wähle ich also mit so einem Picker, mit so einem Drehrädchen auf iOS,
ihr kennt das, wähle ich dann Berliner Stadtwerke und oben sehe ich dann einfach
eine Liste von Karten, sortiert von billig nach teuer. Ja.
Und da es inzwischen sehr, sehr viele Karten sind, denkt ihr so,
oh, die ist ja super billig, die kenne ich ja noch gar nicht.
Dann tippt ihr da einfach drauf und dann kriegt ihr ein paar zusätzliche Infos zu der Karte.
Zum Beispiel, ob ihr Strafgebühren zahlen müsst, wenn ihr länger als zwei Stunden
an dieser Säule steht oder solche Schweinereien.
Und ihr könnt auch einfach unten auf Karte bestellen klicken.
Da ist einfach nur der Link hinterlegt zum Anbieter.
Das ist kein Affiliate oder irgendwas, das ist einfach nur, achso,
dann kommt ihr da schnell hin, das ist Convenience. So, und das klingt jetzt
alles schon kompliziert genug.
Der Punkt im Ladefuchs war es möglichst für alle einfach zu machen.
Und bisher haben das, ich glaube wir haben 120.000 Installationen gerade.
Interessanterweise 100.000 IOS, 20.000 Android. Es spricht wahrscheinlich dafür,
dass Elektroautos immer noch relativ teuer sind und die iPhones eher in der
betuchteren Klientel angetroffen werden, anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären.
Jedenfalls sind das viele Leute und die mögen das auch, aber es gab seit Jahren
einen Request, den wirklich alle immer gewollt haben.
Im Ladefuchs waren bisher nur die Tarife drin, die ihr ohne Grundgebühr kriegen konntet.
Das waren früher quasi alle Tarife, aber inzwischen nicht mehr.
Inzwischen ist es so, dass, sagen wir mal, Ionity geht hin und sagt,
hey, gib mir doch mal 10 Euro im Monat.
Dafür lädst du dann jede Kilowattstunde 10 Cent billiger.
Und das kann sich halt rechnen. Wenn man viel über Autobahnen fährt und so, rechnet sich das.
Aber dieser Tarif wäre im Ladefuchs nicht im Preisvergleich drin gewesen. Ja.
Ab der Version 3.0 ist das aber so.
Und es gibt ein zweites Problem. Und zwar, wenn ihr in Buxtehude wohnt,
dann habt ihr euer Stadtwerk Buxtehude nicht im Ladefuchs gefunden. Warum?
Weil wir nicht 150 Stadtwerke unten in dieses Auswahlmenü reinpacken wollten,
haben wir nur die großen genommen.
Also wir haben sozusagen 90% der User 90% der Zeit glücklich gemacht.
Aber was wollen wir natürlich? Natürlich, wir wollen 100% der User und Userinnen
100% der Zeit glücklich machen.
Deswegen wird auch in der Version 3.0, könnt ihr von allen möglichen Ladesäulenanbietern,
also CPOs, die könnt ihr euch da reinklicken.
Wenn ihr also in Buxtehude wohnt, dann geht ihr in die Settings,
sucht Buxtehude, klickt euch Buxtehude dazu und dann ist es ab dann für euch
auswählbar und ihr kriegt auch sofort alle Preise, die da gelten.
Und sollten die Stadtwerke Buxtehude einen eigenen Tarif haben,
den du nur kriegst, wenn du dort Kunde bist, dann taucht auch der automatisch direkt mit auf.
Also, und was ich jetzt mitgebracht habe, ist eigentlich die Version 3.0 vom Ladefuchs.
Grüße gehen raus ans Team Dominik und Sven, die da unermüdlich dran gearbeitet haben.
Und was ich hier machen wollte, ist dem Roddy die Ehre zuteilkommen,
ihr wisst, lassen, dass er das Ding in den Store rein stellt.
Wenn jemand von euch das gerne übernehmen möchte, hätte ich hier die App Store
Connect Oberfläche und ihr könnt klicken und habt damit diese App released.
Ich habe gedacht, wir machen eine Release in der Freakshow.
Ralf?
Ich bin da nicht Zielgruppe.
Mangels Elektromobilität. Ich kann es euch gerne irgendwo drücken.
Nur wenn ihr möchtet. Ich poste gleich mal ein Bild.
Vielleicht wenn man mal sehen will, wenn man es noch nicht gesehen hat,
wie das aussieht in App Store Connect, wenn man dann auf Release drückt. sagen.
Ich mach mal ein Screen.
Ja, ich hab schon welche vorbereitet.
So, also ich habe einen großen, vertrauensvollen Button veröffentlichen.
Schlau ablehnen.
Sag mal Malik, was genau passiert, wenn ich, wie lange müssen wir warten?
Also dieser Geldkoffer, den du links von dir da stehen siehst,
wandert langsam zu dir rüber.
So, ich sehe, es ist eine 3.0.0 Release. Da wäre ich natürlich schon mal sehr
vorsichtig, ob man so eine 0.0 wirklich, ne?
Neuigkeiten. Ihr und der Fuchs, habt lange darauf gewartet. Eigene Tarife, jada jada.
Ab vier Jahre. So ist so. Also ist ja auch schon was für meine Racker.
Maximal inklusiv. Wenn die sich auf die CE04 setzen.
Ich steigere die Spannung jetzt nicht weiter. Ich drücke jetzt hier mal drauf.
So, diese Version Veröffentlichung. Soll diese App-Version wirklich veröffentlicht werden?
So, ich gehe nochmal auf Veröffentlichen.
Ich sag mal, das mache auch ich sehr selten.
Ein spinnendes Rad und jetzt sind wir wahrscheinlich wieder da,
wo wir eben beim Teilen des WLAN-Plastfords waren, das passiert nicht.
So, also der Pop-Up-Dialog ist weg.
Es gibt ein grünes Häkchen. Es gibt ein grünes Häkchen.
Bereit zur Distribution.
Ja, genau. Ich glaube, jetzt kriege ich gerade E-Mails von Apple.
Also landet das jetzt aber erstmal in der Prüfschleife?
Ne, das haben wir schon.
Das seid ihr?
Das haben wir, genau. Und Sven, wie ich ihn kenne, wird das gerade parallel
mit Android machen, weil sowas fasse ich ja nicht an. Man hat ja auch Ehre im Leib.
Also genau, dann ihr da draußen.
Jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt geht's los und genau. Und ab und zu zwinkert der Fuchs jetzt auch.
Wir haben eine kleine Animation reingebaut und es gibt auch noch so Haptic-Feedback und so.
Apropos Feedback, ihr könnt jetzt auch Feedback zu falschen Preisen direkt in der App melden.
Also wenn ihr irgendwie sagt, das sind gar nicht 53 Cent.
Ich stehe doch direkt davor, ich sehe doch hier, das sind 51 Cent.
Dann sagt ihr einfach, Preiseinfos falsch. Das ist ein kleiner Button und dann
drückt ihr drauf und könnt es in einem schönen UI natürlich mal direkt ändern
und an uns schicken. Das wird natürlich noch geprüft.
Und wenn ich Ladefuchs sage, dann muss ich auch darauf hinweisen,
dass der Parkfuchs weiterhin existiert, dass es viel einfacher erklärt.
Der Parkfuchs ist dafür da, zu wissen, in welcher Stadt es welche Privilegien
für euer Elektroauto gibt.
In Aachen zum Beispiel kann man, wenn man ein E-Kennzeichen hat,
zwei Stunden kostenlos parken.
Und das ist in so einer Innenstadt wirklich sehr angenehm, kann ich nur bestätigen.
Aber es gibt ja tausende Städte und jede Stadt entscheidet das individuell für sich selber.
Und das heißt, wenn man wieder in eine andere Stadt will, ich fahre nach Düsseldorf
oder nach Köln oder irgendwo, dann weiß ich wieder nicht, kann ich jetzt hier
parken? Es steht nirgendwo, woher weiß ich?
Parkfuchs.app gibt es als App, gibt es auch im Web. Könnt ihr also einfach dann
eure Stadt eingeben oder euren Standort suchen lassen und dann seht ihr direkt,
was ihr dürft oder ob es keine Privilegien gibt.
Was ist deine Erfahrung, wie lange das nach veröffentlichten Button drücken
auch wirklich im App Store für die Leute sichtbar ist?
Ich glaube sehr kurz.
Also okay, das ist aber jetzt noch nicht der Fall, bei mir zumindest nicht.
Ich hatte aber bis eben auch noch die Beta drauf, ich war ja Beta-Tester,
fand das auch ganz gelungen, auch wenn mir gerade eben noch eine Sache aufgefallen ist,
die ihr durchaus mal noch machen könnt, aber wahrscheinlich wirst du mir erzählen,
dass es mit eurer komischen Cross-Plattform-Methode nicht funktioniert, weil dann...
Das hatte ich schon mal erwähnt, das mit dem Sortieren. Nö, aber ich finde,
man kann halt auch irgendwie, aber ist egal.
Das muss ich gerade aber auch natürlich mal hinterfragen.
Ich bin jetzt gerade mal in den iOS App Store gegangen und habe nach Ladefuchs gesucht.
Und da seid ihr nicht auf der Position 1 der Trefferliste.
Das oben ist ja eine Werbung.
Naja gut, aber ihr seid nicht auf Position 1 der Trefferliste.
Du meinst, wir sollen Werbung für uns selber schalten?
Naja, aber es ist halt,
ENBW Mobility, E-Auto einfache Ladestationen finden, das ist schon Konkurrenz, oder?
Ja, die geben Geld. Das ist dafür aus, um gefunden zu werden,
wenn man einen Ladefuchs eingibt.
Aber die haben 32.671 Bewertungen und ihr habt 277.
Weil das der größte Ladestromanbieter in Deutschland ist, die sehr,
sehr viele Ladestationen und sehr viel Geld haben.
Das macht schon was aus.
Also da ist so ein kleines Community-Hobby-Projekt for free,
kann da nicht ganz konkurrieren, aber ich finde, man findet uns,
wenn man uns finden will.
Ja, Position 2 ist ja mal nicht nichts. So, jetzt gucke ich,
welche Version hier drin ist.
Ja, guck mal bitte. Ich habe auch die Beta drauf.
Ich habe 2, 2, 3 hier noch drin, vor vier Wochen.
Ja, dann bin ich mal gespannt. Innerhalb der Sendung, ihr werdet es erfahren.
Wir bleiben dran.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall, mehr als releasen kann man sie nicht.
Manchmal ist es übrigens auch Caching.
Mehr kann man damit nicht machen.
Nur releasen. Ich habe natürlich eine sehr viel neuere Version,
als diese lächerliche 3.0 schon auf meinem Handy.
Jetzt nochmal so PR-technisch, also Ladefuchs einfach schlau laden und dazu
halt dieses wirklich sehr knullige Icon von dem Fuchs, aber es ist halt nirgendwo Auto drin.
Schlagwörter gibt's, die du nicht siehst.
Ja, aber ich sehe es jetzt halt einfach, ich bin jetzt halt so jemand,
der durch Trefferlisten durchscrollt.
Da sagt man jetzt weder das Logo, noch der Haupttitel, noch der Untertitel,
dass es irgendwas mit Autoladen zu tun hat.
Muss ja auch nicht für Auto sein, es geht auch mit Motorrad.
Wir hoffen halt, dass niemand dieses Motorrad jemals wieder auflädt,
aber theoretisch geht es.
Gut, aber ich höre auf zu nörgeln, das ist jetzt hier ja gar nicht.
Ja, aber es ist ein kleines.
Feines Tool, was einem wirklich helfen kann, wenn man dieses Problem hat.
Für mich persönlich ist es nicht ganz so wichtig, weil ich selten öffentlich
lade und wenn ich es tue, ist der Preis für die 2 Kilowattstunden völlig irrelevant.
Ja, also ein paar mehr sind es schon, aber es macht halt nicht so viel aus.
Aber man kann sich dann, weil die Preisdifferenzen sind wirklich krass.
Also kannst bei Aldi mit Kreditkarte für 29 Cent laden, kannst aber auch irgendwie
mit deiner Ladekarte irgendwie für 85 Cent dir oder 89 sogar eine Kilowattstunde reinholen.
Das ist schon ganz schön frech und im Prinzip merkt man auch,
dass dieser ganze Markt einfach noch nicht korrekt reguliert ist.
Also das, ich meine, ich verstehe ja irgendwie, man will seine Investitionen
reinkriegen und bla bla bla, aber wäre so tankenorganisiert,
ja, dann, das geht so gar nicht.
Ich meine, es ist ohnehin alles noch nicht ganz da, wo man ist mit dem Sprit,
aber das war ja auch mal mit dem Sprit nicht so.
Das wird sich schon noch irgendwie anpassen. Als nächstes können mal alle anfangen,
Kabel an ihre komischen Ladesäulen zu machen.
Das wäre schon mal was. Hier um die Ecke habe ich jetzt ganz begeistert festgestellt,
ich weiß gerade gar nicht, welcher Straße, aber auf jeden Fall werden jetzt
hier auch neue Ladesäulen, die gar keine Säulen mehr groß sind.
Das ist einfach nur so eine kleine Säule.
So eine Stele.
Stele. Das trifft die Sache besser, wo halt schon direkt auch ein Kabel mit
Stecker drin ist, den du da wieder reinstecken kannst, so dass du nicht immer
noch ein Kabel mitführen musst. Das ist ja so eine absurde Geschichte.
Gerade auf dem Motorrad natürlich super nervig.
Genau, auf dem Motorrad nochmal ein besonderes Problem. Gut,
da werde ich jetzt nicht drum rum kommen, weil wenn du irgendwie halbwegs dich
versorgen willst, brauchst du halt einfach die richtige Geschichte.
Aber gut, in zehn Jahren ist das Thema ohnehin durch.
Naja, auf jeden Fall schönes Projekt und schön, dass ihr es jetzt released habt
und welche Ehre, dass das jetzt hier passiert ist.
Wollt ihr mal was mitbringen? Hier gibt es unten eine Beschwerde von Halifax,
der sagt, Glückwunsch wie immer, ich habe kein Elektroauto, daher meine Meinung
nicht wichtig, aber die Werbung unten, die würde mich hart stören.
Soll man sich nicht Werbefreiheit kaufen können?
Dazu würde ich doch gerne zwei, drei Sachen sagen. Also das ist so ein Projekt,
das gibt es seit fünf Jahren, da haben teilweise sieben Leute mitgearbeitet, unentgeltlich.
Und das Einzige, was wir als Konzession gemacht haben, damit wir das Ding überhaupt
machen können, ist diese Einwerbe-Banner unten, was nicht flimmert,
was sich nicht ändert, was nicht getrackt wird, kein Google drin, kein gar nichts,
sondern da weisen wir zum Beispiel darauf hin, dass es den Parkfuchs gibt oder
dass man in unserem Shop T-Shirts kaufen kann mit dem knuddeligen Fuchs oder eine THG-Quote,
das erkläre ich jetzt nicht, aber irgendwie abschließen kann und dann kriegen
wir irgendwie 15 Euro pro Abschluss oder sowas in der Art.
Also das heißt, das ist so die eine Variante, wie wir etwas wiederbekommen können,
überhaupt wiederbekommen können und wir haben darüber nachgedacht,
ob es sich lohnt, Werbefreiheit kaufen,
aber wir haben dann gedacht, bei einer Pfennigfuchser-App, wie viele Leute werden
da eine Subscription oder irgendwie Geld reinwerfen oder so.
Wir haben gedacht, irgendwie 1%, 3% oder so und das ist dann so viel Hassle,
Tim weiß genau Bescheid, mit Steuer,
mit das, was alles 30% gehen an Apple, dann Umsatzsteuer, den ganzen Kram und
das dann aufteilen zu zeitweise sieben Leuten, dann kriegt irgendwie jeder 3,50
Euro, dafür aber den ganzen Code maintainen und natürlich Android und IOS, einfach nein.
Das ist ein Nein, tausendmal Nein für einmal Ja, das war eins der Neins.
Und wenn ihr uns supporten wollt, ja dann klickt vielleicht mal da irgendwo
drauf und kauft euch mal ein T-Shirt oder so, dann freut sich auch das Team. Genau.
Ja, eigentlich wollte ich ja, als ich gefragt habe, warum bist du nach Berlin
gekommen, nicht hören, dass du deinen Ladefuchs releast, weil das hättest du
ja von überall aus machen können, sondern ich hab dich ja gelockt.
Mhm. Es war nicht nur du, es war, wie heißt dieser andere Typ? Linus heißt der.
Und Linus, auch wieder ganz perfide, schickt mir eine Nachricht und meint,
hey, hast du Bock zur LNP 500 zu kommen?
Hier ist ein Ticket. Und ich so, das ist super lieb Dachte, warum ist der so
freundlich Dann hab ich geguckt, was Züge kosten,
Hab ich gedacht, ah verstehe Nein, Quatsch, also ich hab mich echt gefreut Es
war eine super liebe Einladung Und dann hab ich gedacht, ich war seit 2017 nicht
mehr in Berlin Es wird Zeit Und hab es Das letzte Mal.
Als du hier warst Also immer, wenn du nach Berlin kommst, bist du in der Freakshow Oder andersrum Immer.
Wenn ich eine Freak verstehe Genau, also so war es auf jeden Fall und ich muss
sagen, es war ein absolutes Highlight.
Kann ich echt so sagen. Viele von euch, die das jetzt hören, werden da gewesen sein.
Erstmal sagen, worum es geht. Also es ging um Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 500.
Haben wir ja hier auch schon mal angepriesen und das hat jetzt stattgefunden und Ralf war auch da.
Ja, genau. Also genau, Logbuch-Netzpolitik 500 live in der Urania,
die ich auch nicht kannte.
Was passt da rein? 800.000?
866 ist, glaube ich, die offizielle Kapazität.
Ja, und war auch voll, ne? Also es war auf jeden Fall...
Nicht auf dem letzten Platz, aber war voll.
Es war Stimmung, so viel kann ich sagen. Und ich war noch nie bei einer Logbuch-Live-Sendung
oder außer Kongress noch nie bei irgendwas live von deinem Podcast oder eurem
Podcast. Und deswegen...
Ich war auch sehr gespannt auf die herausragenden Gäste, die angekündigt waren
und ich muss sagen, man wurde nicht enttäuscht.
Also es war alles dabei, also meine körperliche Empfindung war irgendwas zwischen
Johlen, Standing Ovations, Beine trampeln, lachen, ergriffenem Zuhören,
also es war einfach alles dabei.
Ich würde sagen, es war einfach eine perfekte Show von vorne bis hinten.
Ich war mega, mega geflasht. Ich hatte Spaß.
Hab ich gedacht, ich muss vielleicht noch zehn Jahre Podcast machen,
dann kann ich auch mal so eine Live-Show machen.
Oh, gemutet, ganz schön.
Noch gemutet. Versuche gerade, wie man jetzt diesen Spruch ummünzt.
Ich bin gekommen wegen der Besucher und geblieben wegen der Gästinnen oder sowas.
Also eigentlich bin ich da hauptsächlich hin, um irgendwie nach zig Jahren nicht
auf dem Kongress gewesen, mal wieder die ganzen Leute alle wiederzusehen.
Und war dann einigermaßen geflasht, was dann da so auf der Bühne passierte.
Also in der Tat, Glückwunsch.
Und die Highlights fand ich waren schon der Anfang und das Ende.
Am Anfang kam ja eine Band, eine Zwei-Personen-Zwei-Damen-Band, Esels Albtraum.
Die waren einfach so geil.
Reclaim the Jodel.
Die Abrissbirne der Volksmusik.
Und haben also antikapitalistische und antifaschistische Jodelmusik gemacht.
Und das Ganze so in grünen Fantasieuniformen.
Und man stellt sich da jetzt alles mögliche vor und es ist dann aber dann wirklich
nochmal auf zwölf gedreht und als sie dann irgendwie hier von Rammstein Engel
dann umgeschrieben hatten, das war schon,
da hat man gemerkt, da entsteht auch was in diesem Raum.
Ja, also so ein Live-Moment und wie dann auch hinterher die Leute dann abgegangen
sind dafür, das hat den beiden glaube ich auch echt gut getan.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die auch immer so einen Resonanzraum vor sich haben bei dem,
was sie machen mit so vielen Leuten, die da gut auf der Welle das verstehen,
was da gerade passiert da vorne.
Real-Time-Follow-Up, die 3.0 sei jetzt da, meldet Kowalski im Slack.
Oha.
Okay, ja. Ich mache ja auch so ein bisschen Musik und dann hört man ja auch
zum Beispiel da drauf, ich höre vor allem so auf Gesang und ich fand die halt richtig gut.
Und das ist, die sind ja wirklich logischerweise beim Jodeln, also for real,
sie haben gejodelt und gesungen und dann gehen die ja durch alle Register und
so eine Kopfstimmenkontrolle ist nicht so einfach und die haben immer alles
zweistimmig gemacht plus Akkordeon und so. Das war richtig toll, fand ich.
Also ich hätte jetzt gesagt, das war jetzt nicht perfekt von den Intonationen
her, aber das hätte auch, das muss nicht autotunen.
Das Konzept sieht das auch nicht wirklich vor.
Es war absolut gut genug, dass man jetzt nie den Eindruck hatte,
oh mein Gott, das ist jetzt aber irgendwie schräg, weil diese Gesamtperformance
einfach so wirkungsmächtig ist, dass man sich da über solche Details sowieso keinen Kopf macht.
Also die sind doch mit Sicherheit, würde ich mal vermuten, auch gut auf YouTube vertreten.
Also da kann man mal ein bisschen suchen.
Das wäre doch ein Song hier für den Ostklang.
Nach Esels Albtraum, das war schon richtig gut. Und eine von den beiden war
dann ja auch die erste Gästin dann.
Das hat dann auch erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Also wer auch immer da die Idee
hatte, das dann auch gleich irgendwie miteinander zu verbinden,
das hat mir auch gut gefallen mit, wie heißt dieser Schnösel-Stadtteil?
Grunewald.
Grunewald, ja.
Das habe ich da gelernt. Für Nicht-Berliner ist das einfach ja nur ein Name,
aber der Reichen-Stadtteil von Berlin.
Also ich würde jetzt gar nicht so viele Details irgendwie spoilern wollen,
weil das Ganze, haben wir kurz vorher besprochen, wird ja alles noch released
als normaler Audio-Podcast.
Folgt aber jetzt ziemlich unmittelbar dem Release dieser Sendung.
Ihr müsst nicht lange warten und wenn ihr nicht dabei wart, hört euch diese Sendung mal an.
Aber kein Video, hier wird schon danach gefragt.
Wir haben keine Videoaufzeichnung, es wird aber eine Videoversion geben mit
der Livezeichnung, diese Veranstaltung wie bei unseren früheren Live-Events,
das war jetzt in dem Sinne nichts Neues, sondern eher schon Tradition bei uns.
Der Roland, der hat das sozusagen auf dem iPad alles mitgehört und mitinterpretiert
und malt halt während der Veranstaltung auf dem Beamer hinter uns.
Also ich habe es noch nicht wirklich angeschaut.
Es entfaltet auch erst seine Kraft, wenn man sozusagen hört und sieht,
gleichzeitig in Realtime.
Und das Video werde ich auf jeden Fall auch noch online stellen,
da könnt ihr euch selber überlegen, ob ihr das sozusagen so wahrnehmen wollt,
wie das die Leute im Saal wahrgenommen haben, außer jetzt dem,
was auf der Bühne passiert ist, aber zumindest seid ihr da akustisch und visuell,
was den Beamer betrifft, mit dabei oder halt ganz normal als Podcaster,
als Esel des Albtraums auch mit dabei.
Ja und die visuellen Eindrücke der Bühne, das ist dann halt den Live-Besuchern dann vorbehalten.
Wir haben uns gegen eine Videoaufzeichnung entschieden, weil das viel Aufwand gewesen wäre.
Der wäre zwar machbar gewesen, aber das war letztes Mal auch nicht so nachgefragt
und things are more interesting in the dark, wie ich schon mit dem Titel meines
Vortrages in zwei Tagen hinweise.
Ich würde aber dazu raten, sich dann Rolands Zeichnungen in live doch das mitzugenießen,
weil ich glaube, es gibt auch ein paar Sachen,
so kleine Schmankerl, die ihr auf der Bühne ja nicht oder spät erst verstanden
habt, weil diese Zeichnung ist ja ein live Kommentar zu dem,
was gesagt wird und er ist auch sehr lustig und das ist halt manchmal so gewesen.
Ich erinnere mich, bei der dritten Gästin kommen wir noch zu,
dass da etwas gezeichnet wurde, was halt super geil abgehoben hat auf das,
was sie gerade gesagt hat.
Und der Saal war halt am Kichern und am Schmunzeln und sie selbst war aber dann
verwirrt, warum das auch gar nicht so witzig war, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Ja, aber über dir, außerhalb deines Blickwinkels wurde halt gerade etwas Lustiges
dazu gezeichnet und das lohnt sich. Gibt es die Zeichnung als Datei irgendwo? irgendwo. Ja.
Wobei die sich ja im Zeitverlauf auch geändert hat.
Ja, ja.
Das heißt, da wurden auch Sachen weggelöscht.
Also ein bisschen.
Es sind vier Zeichnungen im Prinzip. Genau, ja. Also ihr könnt auch verraten,
wer da war, weil das wird ja dann mit dem Release sowieso bekannt sein.
Genau, also den, da würde ich jetzt vielleicht noch den zweiten Marker jetzt
halt setzen, nämlich die dritte Gästin, die du gerade auch angestanden hast.
Das ist mir auch selten passiert, dass es quasi schon Standing Ovations gab
für jemanden, ohne ohne dass der Titel überhaupt genannt wurde.
Es war halt eine Oberstaatsanwältin, eine Oberstaatsanwältin,
oder Ex-Oberstaatsanwältin, muss man genauer sagen, eben aus Köln.
Und das war eben die Anne Broerhelker, die halt ganz wesentlich zur Aufdeckung
der ganzen Cum-Ex-Affäre beigetragen hat.
Und das war ein Moment, wie man ihn irgendwie in der Podcast-Welt ganz, ganz selten bekommt.
So die Sequenz mit ihr. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das war,
knapp eine Stunde irgendwie sowas.
Und da ist es jetzt, finde ich, auch wieder hilfreich, dass wir da,
glaube ich, nicht zu sehr in Details reingehen und zu sehr spoilern.
Aber ich hatte echt eine harte ein, zwei Wochen hinter mir.
Ich war hundemüde und ich war seit Monaten nicht so wach wie bei dieser Sequenz.
Das war...
Was diese Frau alles gleichzeitig mitbringt.
Und auf der anderen Seite, mit wie wenig Moderation ihr dann aber die Sachen
auch richtig gut aus ihr herausgesteuert habt.
Also man braucht jetzt gar nicht denken, dass er sonst was für Skandale sie ausgeplappert hat.
Darum ging es nicht. Aber alleine diese Sequenz, wie sie eigentlich Oberstaatsanwältin geworden ist.
Wie sie also völlig per Zufall so von, das hat mir ehrlich gesagt auch keinen Spaß gemacht.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, du denkst dir so, so okay, jemand,
der dermaßen irgendwie fokussiert dann hinterher darauf ist,
irgendwie Dinge durchzuziehen, da muss auch so ein super gerader Lebenslauf hinterstecken.
Das finde ich war schon mal so ein Moment, wo schon mal so eine.
Mutwelle durch einen durchging nach dem Motto, okay, du kannst dann auch das
Ding deines Lebens noch finden, nachdem du irgendwie sechs, sieben Mal vorher
dachtest, na so richtig ist es das jetzt aber auch noch nicht.
Und was sie dann für Detail Miniaturen hatte, also was für What-the-fuck-Momente da produziert wurden.
Ja, dass es also eine App gibt, das ist aber, dann höre ich auch auf mit Details,
aber das hat sich mir wirklich total eingebrannt, dass es also eine App gibt
für Banken, die sich Banken installieren,
wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft mit einem Untersuchungskommando anrollt und dann
drücken die auf den Button und dann hängt dahinter mindestens eine Rechtsanwaltsfirma
und dann schicken die nicht drei,
Rechtsanwälte und die schicken auch nicht 30 Rechtsanwälte, sondern die schicken
dann 300 Rechtsanwälte, die sich dann also vor dieser kleinen Polizeitruppe
aufbauen und das kann nicht sein.
Das kann auf so vielen Ebenen, kann dieser Moment nicht funktionieren.
Und du weißt aber, nein, es ist Anne und die ist Oberstaatsanwältin und die
war genau in dieser Situation und die erzählte keinen Bullshit.
Mit genauem Incentive kann sogar Deutschland liefern, was digitale Lösungen betrifft.
Also unglaublich. Auch völlig unabhängig,
ob einem jetzt das Grundthema interessiert oder was auch immer.
Also diese Stunde würde ich sagen, das ist Staatsbürgerkunde.
Rest der Sendung auch alles prima, aber diese eine Stunde, nehmt euch irgendwo
die Zeit und hört euch das mal an.
Das ist auf so vielen Ebenen fantastisch, was da passiert. Ganz, ganz toll.
Und es heilt auch, sollte da draußen noch jemand sein, der meint,
diese ganzen Flüchtlinge wären ja viel zu teuer oder die Ausländer und irgendwie
so, da lohnt es sich nochmal doppelt. Das heilt euch nachhaltig.
Wenn man nochmal wissen will, warum manche Leute an Wände in Berlin schreiben,
tax the rich, da kriegt man QED, alles schön aufbereitet.
Also das ist schmerzhaft, wie sie immer sagte, das ist nicht ein Verbrechen, das ist eine Industrie.
Genau, und warum Staatsanwältinnen gerne Döner essen.
Werdet ihr auch erfahren. Für den Anfangsverdachter. Aber was halt auch für
ein Naturtalent an Geschichten erzählen und reden.
Also wie gesagt, es ist so unwahrscheinlich, dass in einer Person irgendwie
so viele Dinge zusammenkommen, die dann Podcast-Gold produzieren.
Ich hatte noch den Doppel-Dummheits-Moment, denn die beiden Gästinnen saßen
ja auch im Publikum am Rand irgendwo, bisschen abgesperrt so.
Und ich hatte mit der, die wir noch nicht erwähnt haben, mit der Rieke,
wie heißt sie mit Nachnamen?
Ulrike Franke.
Ulrike Franke, genau, vom Sicherheitshalber-Podcast, die Drohnenpäpstin,
reden wir bestimmt gleich auch noch drüber, aber ich wollte sie etwas fragen
und neben ihr saß halt die Frau Brohrhilke und ich beuge mich sozusagen an ihr vorbei,
spreche mit Ulrike drei Sätze und denke die ganze Zeit irgendwie diese sehr
stumme, etwas eingeschüchtert wirkende kleine Frau, die da neben ihr sitzt,
habe ich die schon mal gesehen, aber so ganz hinten im Gehirn,
ich war jetzt noch fokussiert, diese Ulrike anzusprechen.
Gehe wieder auf meinen Platz, Tim und Linus kündigen jetzt die nächste Gästin
an, dann denke ich, ach das ist doch die Frau, die da gerade,
oh mein Gott, warte mal, mir läuft jetzt kalt den Rücken runter und ich so, oh das ist ja,
und um mich rum haben es scheinbar auch alle, aber ich saß auch noch 20 Zentimeter
vor ihr und habe es nicht geschnallt.
Es war so, ich habe gerade noch vor drei Tagen irgendwelche Artikel gelesen
und dachte, was für ein Powerhouse.
Ach ja, also ihr habt nicht zu viel versprochen.
Also wenn ihr denkt, dass beispielsweise irgendwie Drosten schon echt irgendwie
ein Naturtalent war im Podcast, dann habt ihr echt hier an der Brock Hill gar
noch nicht gehört. Das ist also echt nochmal Next Level.
Grüße gehen raus.
Ja, Rieke war auch so ein bisschen, da kam die UKW-Ecke nochmal so ein bisschen mit reingeschwemmt.
Musst du hier noch erklären, was UKW so macht?
Weiß ich nicht, aber es ist halt einer meiner anderen Podcasts,
der ja Krisenbegleit-Podcast geworden ist.
Genau, höre ich auch super gerne. Mit Pavel geht es normalerweise um die Ukraine.
Und das ist ja Sicherheitspolitik auch.
Auch wenn ihr jetzt über das Konkrete in der Ukraine sprecht,
gibt es ja immer auch diese Ableitungen. Was heißt das eigentlich perspektivisch für Deutschland?
Wie müssen wir eigentlich diese Bundeswehr aufstellen? Wann steht der Russe
vor unserer Tür und was haben wir dann in der Hand?
Gar nichts. Okay, also diese Sachen, diese Fragen kommen ja dann und Sicherheitshalber
ist ein Podcast, da ist auch Carlo Masala und wie heißt der Thomas?
Wiegold. Wiegold, von Augen geradeaus, richtig? Ja. Und noch jemand dabei?
Frank Sauer.
Frank Sauer, genau, die habe ich zum Beispiel noch nie gesehen,
ich habe da kein Gesicht zum Namen, das fällt mir dann immer schwerer.
Die sind ja mit ihrem Podcast auch schon live, sogar auf Phoenix waren die schon live.
Ah, okay. Genau. Aber auf jeden Fall auch ein empfehlenswerter Podcast,
weil das zwei diese Themen begleitet und die sind dann auch auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz und so, aber talken da halt genauso drüber wie wir hier in der Freakshow auch.
Also das ist halt lockeres Miteinander und auch lustig und so.
Und die hattest du, also die Rieke, die promoviert hat über Drohnen,
was ja schon ungewöhnlich ist, würde ich sagen.
Und die hattet ihr auch eingeladen und wie war denn das für euch?
Was hast du erwartet, was hast du bekommen?
Ähm, ich hab eigentlich das bekommen, was ich erwartet hatte.
Ähm, mehr eigentlich. Also ich war, ich war ja, also wir waren uns eigentlich
relativ sicher, deswegen haben wir auch ein bisschen dicke Hose im Vorfeld gemacht
und schon gutes Gästepersonal angekündigt so.
Also wir waren uns da eigentlich sehr sicher, dass wir da eine gute Mischung haben.
Spätestens nach dem Vorgespräch mit der Bro Helga wussten wir Bescheid so.
Also da war die ja auch schon sehr so, dass ich mir dachte, okay, das läuft einfach.
Das passt irgendwie, weil wir hatten irgendwie eine gute, weiß nicht,
wir sind sehr schnell da auf so einen guten Modus irgendwie gekommen.
Ping-Pong-Gesprächs.
Ja, also wenn ich beim Vorgespräch dann immer schon so, ja, nee,
Linus, jetzt bist du schon fast im Podcast, weißt du so, reicht jetzt,
lass nicht weiterreden, weil wir verbrennen jetzt hier nur das Feuer,
was wir später noch entfachen wollen.
Und ja, mit Ulrike habe ich halt vorher auch gequatscht und da war mir eigentlich
auch genauso klar, dass wir da genug Anknüpfungspunkte finden.
Es war natürlich jetzt ein bisschen gewagt, so dieses Thema aufzubringen,
aber mir gefiel die Vielfältigkeit so.
Früher hatten wir ja eigentlich immer nur so diese Perspektive,
wir wollen Aktivisten und Aktivistinnen vorstellen.
Das war ja eigentlich so ein bisschen unser Kernkonzept bei den letzten Sendungen
und das haben wir in gewisser Hinsicht auch wieder getan.
Nur mit einem Twist halt so. Und mir gefiel das sehr gut und es kam ja auch alles super an.
Also die Stimmung war einfach grandios und am Schluss war es einfach pfff.
Also das war irre. Also ich bin sehr zufrieden mit der Veranstaltung.
Ist auch immer so, Ich bin immer so, ich gehe mal mit so einem Bauchansatz an
solche Veranstaltungen ran.
Es ist nicht alles durchgeplant.
Wir haben uns mit verschiedenen Entscheidungen sehr viel Zeit gelassen.
Es ist wieder mal, trotz größerem Vorlauf, manches dann doch erst wieder in dem letzten Moment.
Und ich finde das manchmal auch wichtig, dass man Sachen erst im letzten Moment
entscheidet, weil man umso näher so ein Event rückt, umso mehr kriegt man da
auch so ein Gefühl dafür,
was ist jetzt genau das Richtige?
Was passt? Wie machen wir es? Also zum Beispiel der genaue Ablauf,
wer, wann, wie, wo am Anfang, wer ist wo auf der Bühne oder nicht,
Vorhang, ja, nein. Das haben wir...
Glaube ich, eine Stunde vorher eigentlich erst beschlossen.
Weil wir das vorher gar nicht klären konnten und auch glaube ich,
so das Gefühl hatten, dass wir das dann schon auch geklärt kriegen.
Und das hat sich dann einfach ganz, ich meine, für jemanden,
der jetzt gekommen ist, wirkte das, glaube ich, bis ins letzte Detail durchgeplant und so aus.
Aber vieles war war also wirklich auch noch im Zuruf mit der Regie und ist quasi im Moment entstanden.
Ich denke auch bei der Freakshow, ihr seid immer so geil vorbereitet.
Was hat Ralf mich laut angelacht, als ich das gesagt habe? Ja.
Es wechselt.
Es ist ein bisschen die... Ich finde, man merkt das Ding.
Ich sage nicht, Sachen sind schlecht, wenn sie gut vorbereitet sind.
Das auf keinen Fall.
Das kann man auch machen. Und es mag Leuten so liegen Ich warte manchmal gerne länger ab,
damit es dann irgendwie auch passt und manchmal habe ich auch nicht recht,
aber da ist es jetzt ganz gut geworden und ich hoffe, dass es auch mit unserer Subscribe,
wo wir einen ähnlichen Ansatz haben, genauso wird.
Am Ende muss man das fühlen.
Bei der ersten Gästin, wie war ihr Name? Ist ja so ungewöhnlich.
Elin Noss.
Die eine Sängerin von der Band sozusagen, auch Aktivistin, die hatte ja erzählt von dieser 1.
Mai Demo im Grunewald, was aus Berliner Perspektive sehr sehr lustig ist.
Aus Aachener Perspektive ist am 1.
Mai in Berlin immer irgendwie Randale, aber was ist schon der Grunewald?
Das haben sie aber dann erklärt und dann habe ich das auch verstanden.
Habt das dann nachher Berliner Bekannten erzählt Die wohnen nicht im Grunewald
Aber sie meinten, oh ja, davon haben wir gehört Da sind ganz viele Sachen kaputt gegangen,
Während sie aber auf der Bühne erzählt hat Es war so alles mit Humor Und lustige
Schilder Da ist glaube ich viel kaputt gegangen Wie war das denn jetzt?
Da ist gar nichts kaputt gegangen Also okay Das war einfach eine hedonistische
Parade Die da durch den Grunewald gemacht wurde So.
Hatte ich das auch verstanden.
Ja, so war das auch Quartiersmanagement Grunewald.
Wenn ihr euch am Profilevel sich die Gegendemonstrationen gleich mitorganisieren
und dann gleich vor Ort interagieren lassen. Sehr gut.
Also, Blogbuchenheitspolitik 500 erscheint mehr oder weniger,
vielleicht nicht ganz zeitgleich, aber zeitnah zu dieser Sendung könnt ihr dann
gerne nachhören, wenn ihr nicht die Gelegenheit hattet, dabei zu sein.
Und ja, wir machen das bestimmt Stimmt auch mal wieder. Mal gucken,
bei welcher Zahl wir zuschlagen.
Nächste würde sich ja bald anbieten.
1024?
Nee, die 512 ist jetzt erstmal dran.
Vielleicht machen wir da spontan noch irgendwas.
Muss ich doch wieder nach Berlin.
Du musst öfter nach Berlin. Das ist schon... Also ich meine,
man kann Berlin einiges vorwerfen.
Aber nicht, dass es nah an Aachen wäre. Ja.
Von A nach B.
Ich sag's euch. Nicht mit der deutschen Bahn.
So, jetzt müssen wir nochmal Follow-Up machen, das hätten wir eigentlich schon
am Anfang machen müssen, aber das ist ja so ein Thema für dich.
Ja, absolut. Ich hab mich sehr gefreut, Ralf war das, glaube ich,
letzte Sendung mit dem Deppen. Tim war's?
Ich hab das auch gebracht.
Ich bin so stolz auf dich. Wirklich? Ja, wirklich. Also ich hab ja mal Design
studiert und da lernt man ja einiges über Typografie.
Und ihr hattet über das Deppen-Apostroph gesprochen, was halt keins ist,
sondern der Axon-Tegu, Axon-Graf, Back-Tig, was auch immer. Also Leute benutzen
die falsche Taste, die neben dem Backspace anstatt Shift raute.
Und da habe ich mich sehr drüber gefreut und wollte schon noch dazu rufen,
okay, es gibt schon auch noch mehr als ein von den Varianten dieses Apostrophes,
weil dann wirst du in der Typografie vollkommen verrückt.
Ich wollte nur noch was dazu addieren für Leute, die sich in der Tiefe da ein
bisschen mehr interessieren, denn das ist schon mein Ursteckenpferd,
so mein Zuhause, Typografie.
Und da gibt es, ich fange mal mit der ersten Hilfe in Typografie an,
es gibt ein Buch, das heißt tatsächlich so, das ist relativ schlank,
ich sag mal fingerdick, DIN A4 groß und sehr, sehr schön aufbereitet, auch für Laien.
Wenn man mal so eine Nase da reinstecken möchte, was eigentlich dieses Typografie-Ding
ist und wo man wann, warum, vor allem auch warum, drauf achten muss.
Jetzt habe ich hier nur so einen doofen, gekürzten Amazon-Link,
das ist Erste Hilfe in Typografie, ich schreibe es nochmal dazu. zu.
Das wäre wirklich, wenn man nur mal so die Nase reinstecken möchte oder man
fängt mit dem Studium an, Grafikdesignstudium, dann würde ich das auch empfehlen.
Und wenn man dann so richtig ins Rabbit Hole gefallen ist, dann geht man eins
tiefer und guckt sich Lesetypographie an.
Das ist ein Schinken, der ist armdick und nicht ganz DIN A4 groß,
aber das ist schon ein richtiger Brocken, wo einfach wirklich.
Ganz tolle Art, auch grafisch mega gut gestaltet, zusammengetragen ist,
wie man Typografie lesbar macht und was, also auch wie man Schriften kombiniert und solche Sachen.
Typografie ist keine Kunst, Typografie ist keine Wissenschaft,
sie ist Handwerk. Das ist das, was da so drüber steht und das kann ich nur unterschreiben.
Und dann, wenn man sowas mal durchgearbeitet oder auch nur dieses Erste-Hilfe-Buch
gelesen hat, dann macht man so viele Fehler nicht, die die ich den ganzen Tag
sehe und die eigentlich allen Menschen das Leben schwer machen.
Zum Beispiel Word aufmachen, Text eingeben bei DIN A4 und auf Blocksatz stellen
über die ganze DIN A4-Seite.
Absolute Tod für Lesbarkeit. Wenn man einmal verstanden hat,
warum, dann wird man blind, wenn man sowas sieht.
Also dementsprechend Lesetypographie ist, das Ding ist schon von 2010 von Hans
Wilberg und Friedrich Forstmann, muss man sich nicht merken,
aber die wissen wirklich, worum es geht.
Und wenn man dann immer noch nicht tief genug in diesem Rabbit Hole ist,
dann kann man sich noch Detailtypographie angucken.
Und Detailtypographie ist dann wirklich
so dieses, wenn du jetzt so eine mathematische komplexe Formel hast,
welche hochgestellten und tiefgestellten Buchstäbchen brauchst du dann in genau
welcher Dicke der Linie im Verhältnis
zu dem Hauptding und wie Kapitelchen funktionieren und so weiter.
Auch nochmal so ein armdickes Ding, das ist halt eher, müsst ihr euch vorstellen,
wie so ein Lexikon zum Nachgucken.
Also ich habe irgendwann mal ein Buch gestaltet, da gab es viele Fußnoten.
Ich mache selten was mit Fußnoten, dann nehme ich dieses Buch zur Hand und gucke
mal unter Fußnoten nach, warum, wo, wie lang, welcher Strich ist und wo die
Zahlen weswegen abgesetzt sind.
Auf welchen Papieren, das sind Beispielpapiere, wie die gleiche Schrift auf
verschiedenen Papieren unterschiedlich aussieht und warum man unterschiedliche
Schriften für bestimmte Papiere nimmt. Also es ist super.
Also rich for all things typography beim Grafikdesign. Das ist also,
ich glaube, mehr zu wissen gibt es da nicht mehr.
Und geil finde ich von den Autoren auch, die haben die Bücher von Anfang an
als unfertig sozusagen gebaut.
Also, gebaut ist natürlich schwierig, du kannst keine Seiten dem Buch hinzufügen,
aber sie geben immer eine Feedbackadresse an und sagen,
wenn uns irgendwo ein Fehler unterlaufen ist, und das ist ja bei so einem Lexikonartigen
Ding ein Problem, dann bitte hier zurückmelden und die nächste Auflage des Buches
wird diese Fixe beinhalten und sie benennen die Fixe auch.
Ach du meine Güte, Notensatz ist da drin.
Alles.
Ich gucke hier gerade so ein paar Vorschau-Seiten auf Amazon an.
Okay, das würde mich, glaube ich, stressen. Also das Letzte jetzt hier.
Die ersten beiden, das kann ich alles ganz gut nachvollziehen,
aber das hier, das ist ja...
Ja, aber das ist halt dieses, du guckst es nach, wenn du dann den Auftrag hast,
dass du jetzt dieses Notending einmal aufsetzen musst. Und dann kannst du es halt nachsehen.
Weil wo hättest du die Info sonst her? Das kannst du im Netz dir nicht zusammensuchen.
Das ist so krass detaillativ.
Wobei ich das eigentlich schade finde, das wäre natürlich ein super Wiki inzwischen.
Die Bücher sind wie gesagt etwas älter, aber das kann ich nur wärmstens empfehlen.
Links sind in den Shownotes.
Also Steve Jobs hat ja seine Liebe zur Typografie dadurch bekanntermaßen entwickelt,
weil er an der Universität irgendwie einen Kalligrafie-Kurs gemacht
hat und dabei sozusagen das schöne Schreiben erlernt hat und dabei so ein bisschen
einen gewissen Respekt vor dem gemalten Symbol sich erarbeitet hat.
Und ich finde, das hat sich dann sehr positiv gemacht im macOS.
Also Typografie war von Anfang an etwas, was eine große Aufmerksamkeit genoss.
Ich würde mir manchmal wünschen, dass so jemand wie Steve Jobs,
den selber werden wir jetzt nicht mehr kriegen, aber es muss ja wohl auch nochmal
ein paar mehr Leute geben, die bei Apple oben sitzen, die auf die gleiche Art
und Weise auf bestimmte Dinge schauen.
Und das ist auch etwas, was mich persönlich mit ihm immer sehr verbunden hat,
weil ich einfach, ich mag einfach so Leute, denen einfach Details wichtig sind.
Und da ist er, also er lag nicht immer richtig, aber er hatte zumindest eine harte Meinung.
Er war aber auch in der Lage, diese Meinung dann auch wieder zu ändern,
wenn man ihn denn überzeugen kann.
Und das ist auch so ein bisschen mein Selbstverständnis und ich habe auch so
eine Geschichte glaube ich mit Typografie.
Die war jetzt nicht in Kaligrafie begründet, aber so meine Begegnung mit Typografie war PostScript.
PostScript ist ja quasi bekannt als die Seitenbeschreibungssprache,
wie man das so schön nennt und war ja quasi verantwortlich für die Desktop-Publishing-Revolution
in den 90er Jahren, kann man so sagen.
Also Adobe hat PostScript entwickelt und was wenige Leute wissen ist,
dass PostScript ja eine vollwertige Programmiersprache ist.
Eine Stack-orientierte Programmiersprache im Übrigen, so ähnlich wie Forth.
Stack bedeutet, sagt ja umgekehrt polnische Notation etwas.
Gar nichts.
Die gibt es in Ultraschall in der Tat, in Lua haben wir die an einigen Stellen
drin, polnische Notation.
Umgekehrte polnische Notation.
Umgekehrte?
Ja, UPN.
Warum ist sie polnisch?
Das ist eine gute Frage, die ich gerade nicht beantworten kann.
Also es geht im Wesentlichen darum, es gibt Taschenrechner, die sehen das auch noch vor.
Es gibt Leute, die diese Art und Weise bevorzugen, wo du nicht schreibst 3 plus
9, sondern du schreibst 3 9 plus.
Die Idee dahinter ist, dass du quasi erst die Operanten lieferst und dann sagst
du, was damit geschehen soll.
Aber du trennst die mit Komma oder irgendwie?
Du trennst die mit was auch immer. Und das ist auch einer der Gründe,
warum sich, glaube ich, die andere Schreibweise letztlich auch durchgesetzt hat.
Aber in bestimmten Kontexten ist es nach wie vor sehr populär.
Oder ist es das noch? Weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall existiert das.
Und es gibt Taschenrechner und
Systeme arbeiten so. Und das mentale Modell ist halt das eines Stapels.
Du hast einen Stapel und da legst du dann erst die 3 drauf und dann legst du die 9 drauf.
Und dann legst du das Plus auf die 3 und die 9.
Und das Plus löst sozusagen die 9 und die 3 auf und ersetzt sie durch eine 12.
Verstehst du, was ich meine, Malik?
Ich kann es mir bildlich vorstellen.
Ja, das kannst du dir auch.
Okay, das kann ich.
Du hast einen Stapel, einen Stack. Und du wirfst da Sachen drauf,
die sich erstmal nicht auflösen, weil sie für sich sind.
Weil sie so ein singuläres Item sind. So eine 3 tut erstmal in sich nichts.
Sondern es ist nur ein Wert. Dann kommt die 9, die liegt da drauf.
Dann kommt das Plus. Und das Plus sagt, ich brauche die beiden Dinge unter mir.
Und ich mache da was Neues draus. Und das, was dabei rauskommt, das liegt dann da drauf.
Merge Layer in Photoshop.
Und es gibt halt Programmiersprachen, bekanntermaßen die Programmiersprache Forth.
Der Vorteil dieser Methode ist, dass du mit sehr wenig Memory Management auskommst,
weil du quasi nur einen Ort hast, wo Dinge sind, nämlich auf dem Stack. Deck.
Du legst die da drauf und du machst einen Operator drauf und du musst nicht
Variablen und Speicher allozieren und so weiter, sondern es gibt quasi so nur
einen Speicher und man kann bemerkenswert viel erreichen mit diesem Ansatz.
Also wenn man da mal so ein bisschen mit rum spielt, so das ist jetzt für heutige moderne Systeme,
ist es ein bisschen überholt, aber es war zu seiner Zeit sehr erfolgreich,
weil es halt sehr wenig Anforderungen an die Hardwareumgebung und so weiter gestellt hat.
Und man kann aber trotzdem sehr klar damit mitarbeiten.
Und es ist auch so, dass ein Compiler, also etwas, was diesen Code einliest
und ausführt, nicht viel tun muss.
Es wirft halt, die Dinge kommen halt eins nach dem anderen und da drauf und
dann der Operator und dann kommt was Neues bei raus und da musst du also auch
keine komplexe Software erstellen, um das überhaupt zum Laufen zu kriegen und
damit ist es auch sehr sicher und sehr zuverlässig,
realisierbar, was ja heute immer noch ein Problem darstellt.
Und als Adobe das Problem hatte, dass sie gerne eine Laserdrucker und so weiter
ermöglichen wollen, also eine Seitenbeschreibungssprache machen wollen,
da haben sie dieses Konzept genommen.
Also PostScript ist inhärent eine stapelorientierte Programmiersprache,
aber eine sehr einfach zu benutzende.
Und als ich mir meinen ersten Laserdrucker gekauft habe, ein QMS PS410, das muss im Jahr.
92 oder so habe ich mir den, oder 91 habe ich mir den glaube ich gekauft,
zusammen mit meinem ersten Mac, mit einem Macintosh 2 CI das war quasi so mein
Power Bundle mit dem ich gestartet bin,
hatte ich einen vollwertigen Laserdrucker, das heißt ich hatte nicht nur einen
Computer, mit dem ich irgendwie mit Frame Maker und Page Maker und so,
Grafiken erstellen konnte, ich hatte auch einen ein Drucker,
mit dem ich das ausdrucken konnte. Aber das Geilste war.
Ich konnte in der Seitenbeschreibungssprache Grafik programmieren.
Also habe ich angefangen, direkt in PostScript zu schreiben.
Ich habe also Grafik durch Programmieren von PostScript gemacht.
Und dann konntest du halt geile Sachen machen.
Weil ich konnte, was weiß ich, du nimmst halt Text, Klammer auf, ein String, Klammer zu.
Das sind dann halt einfach die Zeichen in einer Gruppe. und dann kann ich die halt rendern.
Vorher setze ich Font und Font Size und Bold und dieser übliche Kram und es
gibt halt eine aktuelle Koordinate, an der ich mich gerade befinde,
so als würde ich da mit der Maus drauf zeigen.
Ich kann also die aktuelle Koordinate setzen, ich habe den aktuellen Font,
ich habe die Größe davon und Outline und was man halt alles noch so einstellen konnte
und dann kann ich sagen, okay, jetzt droppt man hier den Text und dann hat der
den dann an diese Stelle geschrieben.
Und dann konnte ich ein Element nach dem anderen irgendwo auf die Seite malen,
ohne jetzt irgendeinen Textflow zu haben oder so, sondern ich könnte einfach
irgendwo, irgendwo hingehen.
Aber ich konnte halt auch so Sachen machen wie mach eine Schleife,
setz immer denselben Text,
rotiere dabei einen Grad, mach den Font dabei immer etwas größer und auf einmal
hatte ich so einen von innen nach außen wachsenden Text, der irgendwie sich gegenseitig mit,
Überschneidungsfilter und subtrahier das und dann dreimal im Kreis und dann
sah das einfach irre aus und du hättest es damals mit Freehand oder so,
sehr aufwendig bauen müssen.
Machen können, aber nicht wirklich
in irgendeiner nennenswerten Zeit oder Präzision und es war für mich halt,
20 Zeilen Postscript, wenn überhaupt das so viel war. Wahrscheinlich noch nicht
mal. Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau.
Und ich hab mir einen Spaß gemacht und hab dann irgendwie meine Liebesbriefe
irgendwie so mit Postscript programmiert und das hat natürlich mächtig Eindruck hinterlassen.
In der Zeit so.
Weißt du.
Bei mir war es ein Megascroller.
Aber ich hatte halt auch eine Kontrolle über die Typografie und überhaupt waren
der Font, das war ja sozusagen überhaupt das Ding bei Postscript,
das ist das Teil mit 13 Fonts kam.
So Hellwetiger, Times, New Roman, Palatino, Zapfchancery, die ganzen Helden der Frühzeit.
Die du unendlich skalieren konntest, ohne Pixel zu kriegen. Das ist ja auch der große Wurf.
Genau, Vektor und so. Alles war super und das war halt, 92 war das halt einfach
mal so krass, die Zukunft, das war irre. Also das war auch so ein Living-the-Dream-Moment.
Da müsstet ihr doch SVG auch total viel Spaß machen.
Das war zu einer Zeit, wo Windows gar nicht drucken konnte. Also de facto nicht drucken konnte.
Also es war einfach, alle scheiterten an Druckertreibern und so weiter.
Können Sie es jetzt inzwischen?
Ich habe gehört, dass es mittlerweile ganz gut geht. Aber kommen wir zurück zum Apostroph.
Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen und in den Kommentaren kam ja dann auch noch ein Hinweis.
Da wollte ich dich jetzt mal befragen. Also, ich habe jetzt mal hier auf dem
Macintosh, man kann ja in jedem Programm ins Bearbeiten-Menü gehen und da gibt
es dieses schöne Emoji- und Symbole-Teil.
Oder auch Control-Command-Space.
Ja, oder Function irgendwas. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr brauchbares Ding,
was wenige Leute benutzen.
Also es taugt jetzt um Emojis auszuwählen, aber man kann im Prinzip alle möglichen
Gruppen von Symbolen aus dem Unicode-Font und so weiter und Emojis und was nicht
alles. Also man findet damit bestimmte Zeichen, vor allem man kann direkt danach suchen.
Also kann ich hier Apostroph eingeben und bekomme nicht nur jetzt die Zeichen
A, P, O, S, T, R, O, P, H, sondern ich bekomme eben auch, ja,
was sind denn Zeichen, die Apostroph heißen.
Und da gibt es tatsächlich, wie von mir ja berichtet, das Apostroph,
also das Shift-Lattenzaun auf dem deutschen Macintosh-Keyboard.
Das heißt halt auch Apostroph. Jetzt gibt es aber den Hinweis,
dass typografisch, gibt es auch noch den Modifier-Letter-Apostroph und das ist
so dieses etwas eleganter aussehende, wie ein schwebendes Komma,
sagen wir es mal so. Genau.
Was in diesem Fall Modifier Letter Apostrophe heißt.
Was der korrekte ist für Deutsch, by the way.
Genau, ja erklär mal kurz, was es jetzt mit diesen Apostrophen auf sich hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann es nicht so in der Tiefe wie die Bücher,
die ich eben genannt habe, aber es ist schon so, dass viele Apostrophe in verschiedenen
Sprachen auch unterschiedlich definiert sind.
Zum Beispiel Anführungen sind in Deutsch, ich sage deswegen neun eben,
weil die halt wie eine neun oben so ein Kügelchen haben und unten so ein Schwänzchen.
Und zum Beispiel, wenn du ein Wort in Anführungen setzt, in macOS macht der
das auch für dich, dann hast du unten.
Am Anfang, Anführungsstriche unten, sind 99, also zwei Neunen,
die nach links offen sind und die Abführungen sind 66, also das sind welche,
die nach oben rechts weggehen.
Das sind nicht einfach diese geraden Striche, die hier auf unserem Screen als
das Apostrophe angegeben sind.
Das wäre ja eher das, nicht das Zollzeichen, das 1 kleinere Inch, wie heißt das?
Die Minute. Die Minute, genau. Dafür kannst du es benutzen.
Das heißt, oft machen ja viele für Apostrophe Shift 2 und das ist eigentlich ein Zollzeichen.
Außer macOS korrigiert dir das alles nämlich dann schön hinterher und macht
dir dann unten stehende Anführungen 99er und am Ende eines Wortes oben stehende
66er, aber das ist dann die Schlaubieheit des Betriebssystems.
Also Apostroph 2, Entschuldigung, Schiff 2 ist Quotation Mark.
Im Englischen, ja.
Also das ist der Unicode Name.
Ja, genau.
Das ist der Standard Name sozusagen, so heißt dieses Zeichen im Unicode Standard.
Und das andere war halt das Modifier Letter Double Apostrophe.
Also da wird eben auch nochmal unterschieden zwischen einem Apostroph,
also was ist denn das Apostroph dann eigentlich von seiner Herkunft her anders als ein Quotation mag?
Wenn es dann doch am Ende beide sind.
Etymologisch kann ich es dir nicht sagen, aber sie bezeichnen hier in diesem
Programm zumindest alles als Apostroph, was so ein kleiner Strich ist,
der halt solche Quotations und sowas bezeichnet.
Ich kann dir nur sagen, wie wir es im Deutschen korrekt verwenden würden oder eben auch nicht.
Die Minute, die halt oft gerne mal benutzt wird, ist nicht wirklich korrekt.
Sondern eben es gibt ja auch Quotation Marks mit nur einem Strich.
Das wird ja auch manchmal gemacht innerhalb von,
Doppel Strich Quotations und so. Und ihr könnt das auch wiederfinden auf dem iPhone.
Auf der iPhone-Tastatur hat Apple das zum Beispiel auch drin.
Wenn man lange den Finger drauf hält, wenn man irgendetwas mit Anführungen umzeichnen
möchte, dann habt ihr da auch die ganzen Dinger zur Auswahl.
Unter anderem auch die französischen.
Das sind diese Doppelpfeile nach links und rechts.
Left Pointing Double Angle Quotation Mark.
Genau, und die werden im Französischen zum Beispiel anders benutzt als im Deutschen.
Man kann die im Deutschen benutzen, das ist auch korrekt, aber im Deutschen
fängst du an, etwas zu quoten mit den beiden Pfeilen, die auf das erste Wort
zeigen, also die nach rechts zeigen.
Kein Space und dann sofort das Wort.
Während du im Französischen fängst
du an mit den Pfeilen, die nach links zeigen. Space und dann das Wort.
Genauso wie du im Französischen Freizeichen vor Satzzeichen,
also vor Ausrufezeichen oder sowas machst.
Kann ich schwer ertragen, gibt es aber. Gut, also diese Dinge korrekt zu machen,
da sind wir dann bei den Büchern, die ich genannt habe.
Das ist glaube ich auch ohne es jetzt zu sehen super abstrakt,
aber ihr würdet euch wundern, wie viele Apostroph ähnliche Striche es eigentlich
gibt und wie verboten die im Deutschen sind, wenn ihr es richtig machen wollt.
Und wie beschissen Word ist, dass einfach diese Dinger benutzt,
weil es keine Ahnung von Typografie hat und jetzt rege ich mich auf.
Während macOS und iOS den Kram einfach total korrekt machen und sogar mit Kerning korrekt machen.
Also wenn ihr irgendwas schön ausgedruckt haben wollt, dann öffnet Notes,
tippt das da einfach rein und drückt auf Drucken und macht nicht Word auf.
Wirklich, das ist kein Witz. Ich kann dir irgendwie bei Blogsatz von irgendwelchen
Seiten, gucke ich drauf, ich sage dir sofort, dass das Word ist,
weil das auch keinen ordentlichen Blogsatz kann, sondern alle Worte im Auseinanderreißen.
Mir kann das ja nicht passieren. Ich habe ja kein Wort. Also ich wollte nochmal eins kurz klarstellen.
Das Apostroph, es gibt auch ein Doppel-Apostroph, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wo das verwendet wird, aber das Apostroph ist quasi das Auslassungszeichen.
Das wird also verwendet um einen nicht existenten Buchstaben,
der halt verschluckt wurde, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, eine Zusammenziehung sozusagen.
Zu sagen, das zeigt der an, Quotation Mark, wie der Name schon sagt,
zitiert etwas und das ist quasi, die sind aber typografisch so nah beieinander,
dass man sie eben auch verwechseln kann, aber man muss schon genau sein und
wenn ihr dann eure Geburtstagseinladung macht, dann verwendet ihr vielleicht ein
Heavy Double Turned, Quotation Mark Ornament oder sowas.
Ja, ich möchte, weil du Auslassungszeichen gesagt hast, das ist nicht ganz falsch,
aber vielleicht denken jetzt Leute, Aber es gibt doch die drei Punkte.
Dazu kann ich euch sagen...
Oh, die drei Punkte, die müssen wir natürlich auf jeden Fall auch noch haben.
So, der geneigte Windows-User mag vielleicht denken, ich sage,
oh, das war so und so, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Und dann tippe ich Punkt, Punkt, Punkt und dann bekommst du drei Punkte.
Diese drei Punkte sind sehr weit voneinander entfernt und das fällt optisch
alles komplett auseinander.
Deswegen gibt es natürlich bei Mac Option-Punkt, also die Auslassungspunkte
oder der Dreipunkt genannt, das Ellipsenzeichen genau,
was ein eigenes Zeichen ist, was drei Punkte zeigt, die aber passend zur Schrift
perfekt gekurnt sind, also wo der Abstand zwischen den Punkten korrekt ist.
Also bitte, wenn ihr drei Punkte benutzt, macht einfach Option-Punkt.
Und jetzt kommt noch einer hinterher, ihr könnt ja nicht einfach irgendwo drei Punkte machen.
Denn, wie benutzt man diese Ellipse korrekt?
Da kommen nämlich die drei Punkte, die kommen an die Stelle,
wo ihr ganz genau etwas weglasst.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel innerhalb eines Wortes etwas weglasst,
also ihr sagt zum Beispiel Oh, der Tim Pritt,
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, dann würdet ihr die drei Punkte, also diese Ellipse,
direkt an das Wort Pritt dran machen, denn da ist ja etwas weggelassen worden,
so wie so ein Atmer, der in der Luft steht.
Wenn ihr aber Worte eines Satzes weglasst, zum Beispiel, der Tim Pritloff fährt
ein tolles Motorrad zum Punkt, Punkt, Punkt,
dann würdet ihr ein Space machen, so wie wenn das nächste Wort kommt und dann
die drei Punkte setzen. Ja.
Das fragen sich natürlich alle, zum was, zum Teufel, zum Spaß, zum Friedhof.
Aber das ist mit dem optischen Punkt, ist ja voll geil. Das kann ich auch sagen.
Geht auch auf iOS.
Genau, teste ich gerade, ich habe es gerade mal hier auf Mostadon gepostet.
Wie sieht es denn auf dem Windows-Rechner aus? Also ist kein ASCII-Zeichen, oder?
Doch, Clio lost me at Windows. Natürlich ist das ein Unicode-Zeichen seit Anfang an.
Das ist Das ist ein ganz normales typografisches Zeichen, das gibt es schon immer.
Ich verwende das auch schon immer und das ist irgendwie auch wichtig.
Wo wir jetzt schon mal dabei sind, das haben wir zwar letztes Mal auch angesprochen,
aber nicht wirklich ausgeführt, das ist natürlich dann auch noch der horizontale
Strich. Da gibt es auch einiges zu lernen.
Wir kennen natürlich alle das normale Minus oder auch Hyphen genannt.
Was zur Hyphenation verwendet wird, also zum Trennen von Worten.
Man könnte auch Dash sagen, aber Dash ist eigentlich dann schon wieder mehr
so der Begriff für die sonstigen typografischen horizontalen Linien,
die es derer in mehreren Varianten gibt.
Und den Dash, also das ist sozusagen ein Trennzeichen, was man üblicherweise
auf Satzebene benutzt, also zwischen Worten und nicht zwischen Buchstaben,
um halt bestimmte Dinge auszudrücken und wie man das korrekt macht ist so eine Sache.
Also es gibt den normalen Dash, der glaube ich im Unicode Figure-Dash heißt,
dann gibt es den N-Dash, also E-N-Dash und den M-Dash, den E-M-Mutti-Dash.
Und das heißt deshalb so, weil der N-Dash sozusagen die Breite eines Ns,
eines kleinen Ns und der M-Dash die Breite eines kleinen Ms hat. Deswegen heißen die so.
Also sie werden stufenweise breiter. Der normale Dash ist der kürzeste,
der N-Dash etwas breiter und der M-Dash noch etwas breiter. So ein richtiger
Gedankenstrich sozusagen.
Genau, das ist der M, würde ich sagen. Das ist der, der wirklich am meisten
Pause und am meisten Abweichung macht.
Während man den N-Dash halt, ja, wann würde man den verwenden?
Für so Nebensätze an sich?
Also ich kann dir sagen, wie ich sie verwende. Da ist auch manchmal einfach
Geschmack dabei oder passt es gerade zu dem, was du gestaltest.
Es ist schon so, der normale Dash ist das, was wir sehen, wenn eine Zeile umbrochen wird.
Also Text-Auslassung, dann Text-Auslassung in die nächste Zeile.
Da haben wir den normalen Dash. Und wenn du aber das betonen möchtest,
also wenn du, sag ich mal, eine Überschrift gestaltest und du möchtest sehr
deutlich machen, dass hier eine kurze Denkpause ist, irgendwie,
der Kanzler, Gedankenstrich, ist er wirklich verrückt?
Also solche Sachen, dann lohnt es sich, diese Strichbetonung auch optisch nochmal
zu betonen und da entscheide ich wirklich einfach, grafisch ist der M-Dash too much?
Weil manchmal nimmt der dann zu viel Raum ein oder optisch zieht der zu viel
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich und dann nehme ich halt den kürzeren.
Früher, wenn du alte Texte siehst, da gab es lange Gedankenstriche,
die waren auch nochmal deutlich länger als der M-Dash und das unterbricht natürlich
diesen Lesefluss aus heutiger Sicht schon relativ stark.
Wobei das natürlich dann auch vom Font abhängt.
Ja, schon. Aber die haben da generell auch gerne mal so drei kurze Dashes hintereinander
gemacht oder die mit Schreibmaschinen so ineinander geschoben und so.
Also da war schon Usus, dass das deutlich länger war.
Der Horizontal Bar ist das dann schon. Das zieht sie richtig in die Breite.
In der Literatur findet man das auch oft so bei Zitaten von,
wer hat das gesagt und so.
Das sind so die längeren Dashes.
Genau. Ja, macht das bitte alle richtig, wir fragen das ab.
Das kommt alles, das ist alles prüfungsrelevant.
Gut, das reicht vielleicht jetzt erstmal so als Typografie-Exkurs.
Ralf, hast du noch was hinzuzufügen?
Nur ein Nachtrag, weil es hat mich gerade rasend gemacht mit deiner umgekehrten polnischen Notation.
Ich wusste, irgendwo habe ich doch im Ultraschallkontext, dachte ich noch,
was zum Teufel ist das denn? So und es ist aber nicht Lua und es ist auch nicht
ReaScript, sondern es ist Walter.
So was ist Walter? Walter ist die Theming Sprache und das Theming Framework, was Reaper benutzt.
Und ich habe mal in die Shownotes hier den Link abgeworfen zu dem Walter Athemas Guide, der ist von 2012,
also jetzt irgendwie mittlerweile 12 Jahre alt und immer noch aktuell,
wurde nie überarbeitet und dort gibt es ein eigenes Kapitel über die Polish
Notation, aber es ist eben nicht die umgekehrte polnische Notation,
sondern die quasi normale polnische Notation, aber da bin ich dann in der Tat mal drüber gestolpert.
Dieses Dokument ist übrigens auch ein ganz guter Einblick in das,
was das ist genau die Ebene, auf der wir da in Ultraschall an der GUI rumschrauben.
Und wenn ihr euch das mal so ein bisschen durchscrollt, da sind auch nur mal
gerade eben 60 Seiten doppelt gedruckt und denkt so, oh, das ist ja super,
sowas möchte ich immer schon mal machen in meinem Leben, dann könnt ihr euch
sehr gerne mal bei mir melden.
Da haben wir für die 6.0-Release bestimmt richtig Bedarf dran,
weil da wollen wir mal wieder ein bisschen an die Oberfläche.
Aber das ist schon so ein bisschen die Welt des Schmerzes, das werdet ihr schnell sehen.
Es ist alles gut strukturiert und gut durchdacht, aber es ist schon auch ein bisschen weird.
Also wenn man früher mal Winamp gethemed hat, dann weiß man so ungefähr in was
für einer Region das unterwegs ist.
Ja, naja, haben wir wieder was geteilt, was wir hier so mal gelernt haben.
Und wer so im Retro-Computing unterwegs ist, der möchte sich vielleicht auch
wirklich mal Forst oder auch PostScript anschauen. Postscript war ja auch,
vielen ist glaube ich auch nicht klar, was Postscript alles ausgelöst hat.
Also Postscript ist ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht der Vorläufer von PDF.
Zwar ist PDF keine Programmiersprache mehr, aber das Beschreibungsmodell von
Postscript, was halt programmatisch durchgeführt wurde, wurde in PDF übernommen.
Also PDF implementiert dasselbe Seitenbeschreibungsmodell, also welche Elemente
können wo wie verankert sein, wie ist das Koordinatensystem und so weiter.
Aber hat halt eine statische Beschreibung, eine strukturierte Beschreibung und
PostScript macht es halt eben mit dem Interpreter.
Das war damals einfacher, weil man üblicherweise nur an einer Stelle formuliert
hat, das hätte ich jetzt gerne auf der Seite und dann wird das auch als solches abgearbeitet.
Da hat man aber eben noch nicht komplexe Vektordateien in so einem Dateiformat
geladen und einzeln bearbeitet und nachträglich noch gefiltert und dann mit
irgendwie Formulare ausgefüllt, all diese ganzen Anwendungen.
Verschiedene Farbmodelle.
Ja, das ist auch nochmal ein eigener Betrachtungsraum, glaube ich,
was jetzt mit Farben noch alles ist.
Aber PDF hat dann letzten Endes die Ideen von PostScript übernommen,
sich aber eben dieses Programm Mir-Sprachen-Interpreters entledigt,
weil das eben dann sehr viel effizientere Beschreibungen, kleinere Dateien und so weiter ermöglichte.
Aber es dauerte eine Weile, bis PDF so smooth dann auch lief,
dass du wirklich PDF an Drucker schreiben konntest, weil auf einmal bei der
Interpreter war wieder sehr viel schwieriger.
Also um PDF korrekt darzustellen, da gibt es ja heute noch tausend Unterschiede
und bitte laden Sie den Akrobat Rieder,
wenn Sie es richtig haben wollen und dann machst du es in einem anderen Programm
auf und dann fehlt wieder irgendwas und dann ist das PDF nicht richtig beschrieben,
sind irgendwelche Fehler drin, dann machst du das im Preview auf,
was das eigentlich perfekt kann.
Dann fehlt irgendwas, dann kannst du Formulare nicht eingeben oder du kannst
Text nicht richtig markieren und Passwortkonfusionen und all dieser ganze Schwachsinn,
der da noch mit dran hängt.
Und da war halt PostScript eigentlich easy, weil hast du einmal PostScript,
das Interpretieren war halt sehr einfach.
Der PostScript Interpreter war halt simpel zu implementieren.
Und Nextstep, also das Betriebssystem, was Steve Jobs losgetreten hat,
nachdem er bei Apple rausgeschmissen wurde.
Basierte auf Display PostScript.
Also das ganze Grafiksystem von Nextstep, dem Vorläufer von Mac OS X,
das basierte auf Display PostScript.
Das heißt, intern wurde dort auch alles mit Postscript-Elementen beschrieben
und so haben Programme eben nicht nur Grafik auf den Drucker gebracht,
sondern auch auf den Bildschirm.
Deswegen funktionierte Nextstep auch so gut in diesem Bereich und war für alle, die so...
Also typografisch, grafisch orientiert war auch sehr interessant und hat ja
letzten Endes auch zum World Wide Web geführt, nur hatte das eben dieselben
Performance-Probleme.
Deswegen ist dann Apple, als sie aus Next Step Mac OS X gemacht haben,
sind sie dann halt auf Quarz umgestiegen.
Also das ist dann quasi ihre modernere Rendering Engine, die dann eben nach
moderneren Prinzipien funktioniert hat und nicht mehr eben dieses Modell gewählt hat.
Aber es war damals natürlich eine super Idee, weil der Nextcube,
der kam ja dann auch gleich mit dem schwarzen Laserdrucker dazu und die Programme
mussten nichts mehr anders machen.
Ein macOS-Programm, Freehand und so weiter, PageMaker, die hatten alle ihre
eigene Art und Weise, um dem macOS-API zu sagen, Quickdraw damals,
wie eine Linie gezeichnet wird.
In dem Moment, wo du sagst drucken, musste quasi all das, was eben für den Bildschirm
formuliert wurde, nochmal in PostScript anders formuliert werden und das ist
natürlich immer so eine Fehleranfälligkeit.
Während bei Nextstep das, was auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt wurde, war schon PostScript.
Und deswegen schwupps, ohne auch groß Berechnungszeit, pipapo,
das Ding ging in Nullkommanix raus.
Und ich meine, es war sogar so, dass das Rendering auf dem Rechner gemacht wurde.
Das heißt, der Drucker selber war gar kein PostScript-Drucker mehr,
sondern das war eigentlich nur eine reine Pixelmaschine.
Und sie haben halt einfach das Rendering, was sie ohnehin im Betriebssystem
haben. Also dort hatten sie quasi ihren PostScript-Interpreter,
das haben sie genommen und haben dann einfach das, wahrscheinlich komprimiert,
rübergeschickt und deswegen war dann auch der ganze Rendervorgang nicht nur
schnell, sondern vor allem auch Pixel-perfekt.
Also es war exakt genau das, was das Programm auch auf dem Bildschirm gemacht
hat, weil es genau dasselbe war, was halt umgerechnet wurde.
Oder eben nur dann in einer anderen Auflösung als auf dem Bildschirm,
weil der halt damals noch bei 72 dpi üblicherweise war.
Ja, also das ist eine sehr interessante technologische Entwicklung gewesen.
Ich vermisse die Zeit ein bisschen, muss ich sagen.
Also diesen Beitrag, das war während meiner Studienzeit, kam InDesign ganz neu
und da kam auch dieses ganze PDF-Thema, man las in diesen tollen Magazinen,
den fachspezifischen Magazinen schon darüber,
dass das dann mal kommen soll und das hatte für uns echt praktische Auswirkungen.
Also dieses, ich fahre nicht für jeden Druck noch in die Druckerei und gucke
mir Filme an, also den Zyran, den Magenta, den Gelb- und den Schwarzfilm und
dann auch nochmal die Druckplatten, wo du dann halt irgendwie ahnen musstest
mit sehr viel Erfahrung,
ob jetzt da in Zyran wirklich genug Zyran drauf war.
Das ist natürlich alles Quatsch. The world is what you see is what you get.
Ab PDF war die Welt einfach komplett anders.
Du musstest nicht mehr selber Druckmaschinen verstanden haben,
um irgendwo etwas drucken lassen zu können.
Ah, da wird gefragt, ob du mal ein CAE überdrucken gemacht hast.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Ja. Ja.
Ich habe, naja, also ich habe tatsächlich,
ich habe mal ein CAE gemacht mit meinem Freund Jum, also genau genommen habe
ich sogar zwei gemacht, einen über Segeln und einen über Fallsharing.
Finden Sie die Gemeinsamkeit?
Ja, also das mit dem Segeln, das ist das, was er danach gemacht hat,
aber mein Freund Jum war einer, der,
also in meiner jungen Anfangszeit war er sozusagen unser Local Programming Guru,
der ein bisschen älter war und schon das Licht nicht nur gesehen hatte,
sondern es auch ordentlich verbiegen konnte.
Der war so voll der Unix Wizard und hatte auch den Source Code,
den Unix Source Code schon gesehen, den es ja damals noch in dem Sinne gar nicht
gab und kannte sich da irgendwie total aus und war so voll der Held.
Und der hat damals mit einem anderen Freund von mir eine Firma gegründet,
die es glaube ich heute noch gibt, Helios Software,
kennen nicht viele, war aber ein Laden, der sehr erfolgreich war in sehr kurzer
Zeit, weil sie was pfiffiges gemacht haben.
Weil damals, also erstmal haben sie quasi Sharing-Systeme, daher seine Kenntnis
gemacht für Macs und dann später auch für Windows-Systeme, also File-Sharing
auf Unix-Maschinen, die damals ja die Workstations waren.
Und wenn du so ein Mac als File-Sharing-Computer genommen hast,
also als Server-Performance.
Und gerade im Prepress-Bereich war natürlich der Performancebedarf für solche Systeme extrem hoch.
Und natürlich auch in Unis und so weiter.
Und die haben halt einfach einen eigenen File-Sharing-Server geschrieben,
der extrem auf Performance ausgelegt war.
Und du konntest halt irgendeine Unix-Kiste, so eine Sun oder was es damals so
gab, HP UX-Maschine, egal,
lief nahezu auf jeder Unix-Maschine, konntest ja halt so eine Workstation kaufen für, was weiß ich,
50.000 Mark damals so, also irre teuer, nur dann konntest du halt auch irgendwie
100 Clients damit surfen und das hat sich für die Firmen sofort gelohnt.
Und das Ding war innerhalb kürzester Zeit bei den Universitäten in Europa so der absolute Standard.
Und dann ging das sehr schnell, dass die Preprint-Industrie draufgekommen ist,
dass sie genau dasselbe Problem hat, weil die hatten halt angefangen jetzt digital
Zeitungen zu machen, saßen da alle mit Quark-Express, muppelten auf ihren kleinen
Macintoshes irgendwie ihre Zeitungen zusammen,
mussten dann aber Fotos platzieren.
Und Fotos, das weißt du ja, für den Druck müssen die halt eine hohe Auflösung haben.
Aber diese kleinen Macs damals, die waren gar nicht in der Lage,
so Fotos in Vollauflösung wirklich gut zu behandeln.
Das konntest du schon machen, aber dann sitzt du da stundenlang mit einem Drag
und Drop und dann letztes Dokument und dann kannst du eine halbe Stunde darauf
warten, dass dein Dokument gilt. Das ist nicht wie heute.
Und was sie halt damals gemacht haben, ist, dass sie so ein Proxy-Interface gemacht haben.
Das heißt, du hast halt auf deinem Mac mit so einer runtergerechneten Version
des Bildes gearbeitet in 72 dpi, was der Mac relativ easy, schnell da draufwerfen
konnte und dann war das auch alles Klick und sofort so.
Und wenn du dann gesagt hast, so und jetzt drucken wir das aber auf unserem
geilen Laserbelichter mal aus, damit dann da eine Zeitung draus wird oder ein
Katalog, dann wurde quasi auf Serverseite die Hi-Res-Version von dem Bild ersetzt
und dann wurde eben mit voller Auflösung gemacht.
Und das war der totale Knaller und damit sind sie irgendwie super reich geworden und alle,
das war so der Standard im Preprint-Bereich und ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht ist das immer noch, den Laden gibt es ja noch und das sind so diese
Entwicklungen der damaligen Zeit. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie bin ich darauf gekommen?
Jum, keine Ahnung. Ich wollte noch auf irgendwas anderes hinaus.
Ah ja genau, dann habe ich halt deswegen den CAE mit ihm zu dem Thema gemacht.
Und damals war halt Postscript und dann später eben auch PDF auch schon so ein Thema.
Und das war so die erste verrückte Firma, für die ich gearbeitet habe.
Ich hatte immer so ein bisschen das Glück, so irgendwo zu landen, wo...
Man hörte davon.
Dinge getan, wo die anderen immer tolle Sachen gemacht haben.
Ich hab ja selber gar nicht so tolle Sachen gemacht, ich war immer nur dabei.
Ja, aber du hast dir die Studienzeit und den ganzen Kram gespart und in der
Zeit halt geile Scheiße gemacht.
Ja, ich hab andere Schlüsse draus gezogen. Also als ich dann da raus bin,
hab ich halt dann den Macintosh rausgekauft und das war dann so mein Kickstart in die Macintosh-Welt.
Und hab dann tatsächlich selber lange Zeit so mit FrameMaker mein Geld verdient.
Weil das halt das geile Tool war, um so Word-Processing zu machen.
Also ich habe nie mit Word gearbeitet.
Gut so. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass Ralf einen sehr langen Tag hatte.
Und ich sehe hier in unserem, wie sagen manche, Pad, hier in unseren Notes,
dass da noch Dinge drin sind von Ralf.
Die sind aber alle eher so nach hinten, wenn man noch ein bisschen Platz füllen möchte.
Also ich dachte, ich wollte dich nochmal wecken.
Nee, nee, alles gut. Ich lausche hier andächtig.
Okay. Ja, ich hätte noch Dinge zu erzählen.
Das ist gut.
Darum bist du hier.
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Sorge, wie tief ihr in dieses Thema oder alle in dieses
Thema einsteigen wollen.
Deswegen schiebe ich ganz scheu mal einen Tipp vorne weg, den ich unbedingt da lassen möchte.
Wir haben das bei uns in der Sendung, Audiodump-Tipps. Ihr müsst das unbedingt
wissen, weil es euer Leben besser macht.
Dass System-Textersetzungen auf iOS oder macOS also nicht nur die Tatsache, dass ihr,
fest eingebaut etwas drin habt, ihr tippt MFG und da steht dann mit freundlichen
Grüßen, sondern ich rede spezifisch von einem System, was ich benutze,
um mir die Textersetzungen untertan zu machen und die machen mein Leben sehr
viel besser und das wollte ich mal hier,
erklären, weil vielleicht gibt es die einen oder anderen, die dann sagen,
was, das brauche ich und zwar benutzt ihr Textersetzung viel?
Praktisch gar nicht.
Ähm, selten.
Selten. Es kommt auch darauf an, ob man die Anwendung hat, die ich habe.
Ihr habt ja schon mitbekommen, ich habe ein oder zwei Projekte.
Und es ist schon so, dass man viel, sag ich mal, trommeln muss für die Band.
Du schreibst mit irgendwem Neues, die sagen, schick doch mal ein Video oder
den Link zu eurem EPK, also eurem Electronic Press Kit, also eurer Info-Page und sowas.
Das braucht man den ganzen Tag immer wieder, egal wo man ist.
Und jetzt gibt es natürlich Textersetzungen.
Und man könnte jetzt sowas machen wie, ich tippe einfach EPK und kriege den
Link zu meiner Nextcloud oder so, dann ersetzt.
Das ist praktisch. Aber sobald du davon mal 10, 30, 100, 200 hast,
wird das halt sehr unübersichtlich.
Und deswegen habe ich mir ein kleines System ausgedacht und das geht so.
Ich führe die ersten zwei, drei Buchstaben, beschreiben das Projekt,
sagen wir mal meine Band, die heißt ja Dark.
Ich mache also DK, also alle Textersetzungen bei mir, die anfangen mit DK, betreffen die Band.
So, und dann möchte ich zum Beispiel das EPK von der Band haben,
also ist mein Shortcut DK-EPK.
Und dann ersetzt er das durch den Link, der Mac oder das IOS.
Also du redest jetzt von dem Textersetzungsfeature, was man im Standardkontrollpanel
findet, das kennen nicht viele, das ist halt in der Tastatur,
in den Settings der Tastatur, gibt es im Bereich Texteingabe,
Den Button Textersetzungen. Und wenn man das mal aufmacht, dann sieht man schon
ganz viele Textersetzungen, die da schon drin sind.
Nämlich vor allem für Emojis. Also es gibt so Doppelpunkt, Avocado-Doppelpunkt.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt wahrscheinlich ganz normal in euer Notepad irgendwo eingibt,
in Notes oder Textedit oder was auch immer, dann wird da eine Avocado draus.
Und das ist bei dir Standard? Bei mir sind die nämlich nicht drin.
Ich habe bei mir genau neun Einträge.
Achso, warte mal, habe ich die?
Ich glaube, du hast die irgendwo dir reingefischt.
Dann habe ich die vielleicht mal irgendwann reingeladen.
Die Standarddinger sind nur so MFG, freundliche Grüßen und sowas.
Und du hast das nämlich, glaube ich, irgendwann mal in Audiodump erzählt.
Ich erzähle das jedes Jahr nochmal überall.
Vor zig Jahren muss es gewesen sein und da habe ich das gehört und dachte,
oh, das hat er sich aber clever ausgedacht.
Also nochmal um der Klarstellung, das ist jetzt gar keine neue Software oder
sowas, sondern das ist eine ganz normale Systemfunktion und du musst natürlich
einmal händisch diese Korrespondenzen dort eintragen.
Das heißt also, du hast jetzt das, was du jetzt quasi erfunden hast oder was
du hier promotest, ist also einfach nur eine, wir würden jetzt sagen Nomenklatur,
also eine Art, wie setzen sich für dich die Begriffe logisch zusammen,
dass du dich gut daran erinnern kannst.
Genau, so ein Mental-Model.
So ein Mental-Model, genau. Und ich erkenne das jetzt daran,
weil ich nämlich hier bei mir irgendwelche Ultraschall-Quicklinks mal definiert habe.
Und zwar genau nach deinem Vorgang. Also ULT für Ultraschall und dann DAN für Ultraschall-Danke.
Und das ist halt die Danke-Page von Ultraschall und so halt noch ein paar mehr davon.
Ich kann aber guten Gewissens sagen, nachdem ich sie modelliert habe,
habe ich sie niemals wieder für irgendetwas genutzt.
Genau, ich habe jetzt gerade auf meinem iPhone mal durchgescrollt, wie viele ich habe.
Und ich glaube, das Scrollen ist allein 40 Seiten oder so.
Das liegt natürlich einfach daran, ich sage dir, meine alte Band war Star The
Revolution, SAR abgekürzt.
Und im Verlauf der Zeit hat man dann, weiß ich nicht, 10 Musikvideos gedreht.
Eins davon heißt Hell Come.
Ich möchte also jemandem dieses Video schicken, dann ist es S-A-R-H-E-L.
Und dann hast du ein zweites Video und ein drittes und ein zehntes und sonst
wie und das läppert sich natürlich,
aber es lässt sich ja immer logisch ableiten, das Kürzel, auf das ich spontan
als erstes komme, ist auch das, an das ich mich gut erinnern kann.
Ja, eigentlich ist es total geil, weil ich hatte gerade heute wieder den Fall,
ich verschicke immer irgendwie dieselben drei oder vier Links zum Thema KI,
so Grundlagen, Dinger, dieser WaitButWhy-Artikel zu AGI,
irgendwie das aktuelle Seemann-Paper da, seine Studie, die er da geschrieben
hat, 100 Seiten, das mache ich ein paar Mal im Monat und jedes Mal,
like an animal, kram ich wieder irgendwo rum, wo hatte ich sie nochmal,
sowas könnte ich da alles mal eintragen, das wäre eigentlich total sinnvoll.
Vor allem für einen Programmierer eine relativ naheliegende Möglichkeit.
Aber irgendetwas hält mich zu.
Also es ist quasi ein Auto, wie heißt das, ein Auto-Vervollständigen des Gehirns.
Also für mich, deswegen meine ich, nicht jeder hat diese Anwendung,
aber wenn man viele Links verschickt oder so, dann guckt mal,
ob ihr euch das angewöhnen könnt.
Meine Sängerin ist auch noch, Kim, die muss auch Dinge verschicken und so,
sie macht das noch in Notes rein. und like an animal öffnet Notes,
sucht die Notiz, wo alle Sachen drin stehen, kopiert sich die Zeile raus.
Kann man alles machen. In der Zeit habe ich halt DKIPK getippt. Space Return. Weg.
Das synkt ja wirklich über die diversen Geräte alle weg, ne?
Sofort auch. Richtig schön, weil es ja so klein ist. Genau.
Also das heißt, wenn ihr das auf dem Mac alles eingebt, was einfacher ist,
habt ihr es auf dem iPhone auch drauf. Und andersrum.
Ich sehe gerade, ich habe hier in der Tat Ultraschall 4.0 ist rein modelliert,
aber zu 5.0 hat das schon nicht mehr geschafft.
Das heißt also, die Unternehmung muss mindestens irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
sechs Jahre oder sowas alt sein.
Genau. Aber sie funktioniert sogar noch.
Ja, bei mir war es wirklich, nachdem ich wirklich das 30. Mal irgendeinen Link
rausgekramt habe, da war dann irgendwann, geht das nicht schneller und dann
habe ich das Ding entdeckt und seitdem werde ich nicht müde,
es allen ans Herz zu legen.
Ja, soll ich wirklich?
Ja, überleg doch mal, dass du so was mit Strahlkraft jetzt raussuchst von dem ganzen Komplex.
Ich habe noch einen kurzen Nachtrag zu dieser Textgeschichte,
weil ich mich gerade selber gewundert habe, dass ich da solche Substitutions
drin habe und ich gerade nicht mehr genau weiß, wo ich die eigentlich her habe.
Aber es sieht so aus, als ob man auf dem Mac in seiner Library in den Präferences
ein Text-Substitutions.pl List-File ablegen kann, wo die dann alle drinstehen.
Das ist dann quasi so ein XML-File, wo man sich das,
zusammenwursteln kann. Ja.
Wir können doch jetzt mal eine Live-Höreraktion machen. Tippt doch mal in den
Chat, wie viele Textersetzungen ihr da drin modelliert habt.
Neun, neun, neun. Aber Chris7 schreibt hier gerade noch sehr gut,
das habe ich nämlich auch.
Textersetzung ist auch fein, um zum Beispiel einen Zero-Width-Space in ein Hashtag
mit Plural-S oder so einzusetzen.
Also ich übersetze es mal, also im Prinzip Sonderzeichen zu machen.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel, es gibt diesen sehr schönen Rechtspfeil,
also er ist ein Pfeil und zwei so Pfeilspitzen, die gibt es in den macOS Standarddingern
und das habe ich definiert, ich mache,
ich tippe irgendwo zwei spitze Klammern und dann ersetzt er mir das in den schöneren
Pfeil, den ich sehr oft benutze.
Ich werde den jetzt mal kurz hier einfach so in den Slack reinposten,
wo der leider von Slack ersetzt wird durch irgendeinen Mist,
aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Also der Pfeil, der aus drei Strichen besteht.
Also Sachen, die sonst schwer zu tippen wären. Zum Beispiel Trademark, das Trademark-Symbol.
Wenn ich TM tippe, dann ersetzt er mir das in das schöne kleine Trademark-Symbol,
weil ich natürlich so ein Typo-Nerd bin und das gerne schön hätte.
Ich habe das in Klammer auf TM, Klammer zu geändert, weil mir das zu oft dazwischen kommt.
Aber er macht es so schlau, dass er jetzt nicht inmitten eines Wortes,
wenn er Atmosphäre, dann ersetzt er dir natürlich nicht in der Mitte.
Ja, aber es ist schon manchmal so, ja, wollte ich jetzt nicht haben.
Ah ja, Max Neider macht AAPL, macht bei ihm den schönen Apfel.
Da würde ich sagen, Option Shift. Ich muss kurz gucken, ist das Ü?
Den Apfel, da muss man eine Aktie machen.
Ja, Option Shift Plus würde dir den Apfel auch geben.
Ja. Ah ja, Interrobang werden wir gemacht.
Auf jeden Fall ganz hilfreich.
Ah, Max Neidert hat recht. Das ist auch eine schöne Methode.
Den Abfüll kannst du auf dem iPhone nicht machen mit Option irgendwas.
Und deswegen macht es auch Sinn, für sowas eine Textersetzung zu machen,
wenn man es auf iOS benutzen möchte.
Also da gibt es auch solche Anwendungen. Ja.
Genau, folgendes. Ich habe gedacht...
Ich kann ja zumindest ein bisschen Rock'n'Roll mal in die Sendung mitbringen.
Warte, stopp noch.
Und vorbei mit Rock'n'Roll.
Rock'n'Roll wird abgesagt.
That's what we have for you today.
Naja, also man kann das Thema Text Replacement jetzt nicht ohne Text Expander
zu erwähnen noch abschließen.
Das ist so das Power Tool für Leute, die von allem nicht genug kriegen können.
Ich habe das jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr verfolgt. Wenn man da auf die
Webseite guckt, dann ist halt auch schon irgendwie mit hier more productive, bla.
Und wahrscheinlich steht hier auch irgendwo schon AI. Aber es ist auf jeden
Fall für so Advanced Text Replacement für Leute, die das oft machen,
entweder in der Kommunikation.
Wie du schon sagst, schick mir mal die Adresse, das, der Standardtext,
die Beschreibung von hier, die Wegbeschreibung nach.
Wenn man das halt oft hat, dann ist das halt auf jeden Fall Hilfe.
So, aber jetzt halten wir um, direkt in den digitalen Bandraum.
Genau, folgendes. Ich habe gedacht, vielleicht ist auch heutige Heavy-Metal-Band
oder Rock-Band haben, kam mir ja auch öfter schon mal zu Wort durch Huckel oder
Roddy, auch interessant aus Nerd-Perspektive.
Also die rein technische, was
hat so eine Band denn heute so dabei und was hatte sie so früher so dabei?
Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie weit das da draußen so bekannt ist.
Ralf ist ja immer sehr informiert über alles, was Bands auch so machen,
aber wahrscheinlich eher im Depeche Mode Level oder so.
Ne, geht's, sagst du? Okay. Also und zwar haben wir in unserer...
Auch Stromgitarren zu Hause.
Ah, ja, so. Nutzt du sie in Band-Kontexten?
Und einen kleinen Camper unter dem Sofa.
Ach, guck an.
Nee, ich habe ja in meiner Band gespielt, aber da habe ich Drums gespielt,
allerdings auch elektrische mit einer sündgroßen, sündhaft teuren Soundlibrary dahinter.
Das war alles sehr nerdig. Surprise.
Nee, mit Gitarre nicht in der Band.
Ja, jetzt ist eigentlich der Moment, wo man Tim nochmal herauszerren müsste
aus dem Klo, um ihm zu sagen, ich wollte ihn animieren, doch jetzt Kapitelbilder doch mal zu benutzen.
Denn das, was ich jetzt erkläre, wird sich wirklich sehr viel besser erklären
lassen, wenn man sieht, was da so passiert.
Ich habe da mal etwas vorbereitet. Fast wie ein echter Ralf.
So, ich werfe jetzt mal in den Slack ein Bild und wie macht man hier eine Kapitelmarke,
wenn Tim nicht da ist? Man weiß es nicht.
Okay, ihr seht jetzt ein Bild von meiner alten Band, wir sind auf so einer Bühne
und auf dieser Bühne gibt es sehr viele verschiedene schwarze Klötzchen.
Also eine typische Rockband ist so aufgebaut, ihr habt ein Schlagzeug,
zwei Gitarren, ein Bass, ein Gesang, sagen wir mal.
Und hier wird sich beschwert, dass irgendwas rauscht. Ich ahne, was es ist.
Aber das muss jetzt leider in den Abschluss.
Also erstens T, zweitens du hast einen Content-Marker, das müsste Ralf auch
wissen, weil den habe ich extra für Ralf eingeführt.
Das ist die Menü-Taste auf deiner Fernbedienung.
Oh super.
Wir haben schon was gedrückt hier.
Es wurde mir nicht erklärt.
Was hast du gedrückt?
Achso, ich habe einfach hier die Kapitelmarken.
Ach, du hast Kapitelmarken gesetzt, so so.
Ja, weil da sollen ja die Bilder rein, sagt man.
Ja, Bilder sind aber keine Kapitel, mein Freund.
Ja, aber anders geht es halt im MP3-Standard nicht.
Ja, MP3 ist ja ja auch scheiße.
Ja, aber es läuft überall.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich das nicht benutze, weil das alles so minderwertig designt ist.
So.
Und weißt du, Bilder haben natürlich eine eigene Spur zu sein. So.
Die in exakt keinem Podcatcher der Welt angezeigt.
Naja, in Apple Podcasts schon, ne?
Weil die es ja schon immer mal richtig gemacht haben. Und dann haben die MP3-Leute
gesagt, ist ja nett, dann machen wir einfach ein Bild aufs Kapitel.
Das muss natürlich separat sein, eine Bildmarke. Aber natürlich muss man wieder
alles zusammenschmeißen, weil nobody thinks just...
Das ist dieses von der Tapete bis zur Wand, weißt du? Das ist so in etwa der
Gedankenspace, in dem solche Features definiert werden.
Malik sieht gerade wieder seinen Rock'n'Roll, die ist klobunter gespült.
Du kannst hier jederzeit auf die Menü-Taste drücken und dann hinterlässt du
in meinem Recording einen Content-Marker, der ist blau.
So, das nenne ich Macht.
Ja, und das ist für mich eine Stelle, wo ich weiß, hier geht es irgendwie um
den Content. Zum Beispiel, jemand hat was Tolles gesagt, das könnte ein Titel sein.
Oder hier muss nochmal eine URL nachgeliefert werden. Oder sowas.
Das will ich auch. Ich nehme einfach hier heimlich so eine Fernbedienung mit.
Kannst du dir auch alles nachbauen. Habe ich auch schon mal in einer Freakshow beschrieben.
Aber ich erinnere mich, ja.
Das ist doch sogar im Sendegate dokumentiert, oder?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, und dann kommt ihr einfach auf die Subscribe und fragt persönlich, wie es geht.
So nämlich.
So. Also folgendes, ihr seht da so eine Rockband auf einer Bühne und ihr seht
da so schwarze Kästchen vor der Rockband und ihr seht da so Gitarrenverstärker
und Boxen und Kram hinter der Rockband.
Wir ignorieren jetzt gerade mal das Schlagzeug. Sorry, alle Drummer da draußen.
Und zwar ist das Ding, so eine Bühne ist A, ziemlich vollgestellt und B,
muss man die ganze Scheiße schleppen, wenn man so irgendwo weiß ich nicht,
wir spielen demnächst irgendwo in was hab ich gesagt,
Bochum, dann müssen wir halt sehr viel davon in irgendwelche Vans verpacken
und irgendwo hinfahren und das ist alles sehr schwer und ich bin sehr alt Aber jetzt.
Ich will dich jetzt gar nicht dazwischen grätschen, aber jetzt solche Geschichten
wie hier dieses Event da in Bochum da kommt ihr doch eigentlich auf eine fertige
Stage da bringt ihr doch nicht die Stageboxen mit.
Ja, aber nein. Also das stimmt. Aber ich komme gleich nochmal dazu.
So, also das stimmt. Die Boxen, wo hier unser Sänger Patrick das Bein draufstellt
auf dem Bild, was ihr da seht, das sind Monitorboxen.
Die sind immer so schräg abgewinkelt und die coolen Rockstars stellen da ihr
Bein drauf und alle denken, die sind super cool, dabei wollen die nur ihre Hüfte entlasten.
Findest du, dass dieses Bild so super komplex ist, dass man das auch nicht als
solches beschreiben kann? Also ich meine, dieses seht ihr auf dem Bild,
keiner sieht das hier auf dem Bild, weil es sind ja alle im Podcast und die
Leute sitzen jetzt gerade auf dem Fahrrad, im Auto, die haben einfach keine Möglichkeit.
Die haben gerade angehalten, um...
Ja, um so deine Kapitelbilder anzuschauen.
Um auf ihre Watch zu gucken, wo das Kapitelbild erschlitzelt.
Ja, das ist viel zu klein, da kannst du nichts erkennen. Also da steht ein Typ auf der Bühne,
die Haare werden, wie sagt man, gemoscht und vorne stehen die Monitorboxen und
der tritt auf den Monitorboxen rum und der Techniker von der Location denkt
sich so, oh, die machen wieder alles kaputt.
Etwa so. Und jetzt denkt man sich, warum sind diese Monitorboxen eigentlich
immer in dieser komischen Form?
Hier kommt Bild Nummer zwei und da habe ich mal in Rot und Grün zwei Abstrahlwinkel eingezeichnet.
Der grüne ist so dieser Abstrahlwinkel, der aus so einer Monitorbox rausgeschallt kommt.
Das sind so 45 Grad Pi mal Daumen. Das heißt, wenn du vor dieser Monitorbox
stehst, hörst du, was du hören sollst. Wenn du anderthalb Meter daneben stehst,
hörst du fast nichts mehr von dem, was aus dieser Box rauskommt.
Vor allem, wenn alles lärmt und kracht.
Also bei Sprechern auf einer Bühne geht das noch.
Bei euch zum Beispiel jetzt hier bei der LNP ist das alles easy.
Aber wenn du hinter dir ein Schlagzeug hast und der drischt wirklich rein,
dann musst du wirklich vor dieser Monitorbox stehen.
So, und deswegen, weil eine Monitorbox nicht reicht, weil die nur so einen schmalen
Strahl vor sich an Audio-Informationen rausgibt, brauchst du mehrere Monitorboxen.
Je breiter die Bühne, desto mehr Monitorboxen.
Das bringt weitere Probleme mit sich, nämlich wir bewegen uns relativ viel auf
einer Bühne, also ich stehe zum Beispiel rechts mit meiner Gitarre und laufe mal nach links rüber.
Dann ist aber auf meiner Monitorbox rechts, ist der Ton für mich persönlich gemischt.
Da ist meine Gitarre lauter als die andere, da ist mein Gesang lauter,
damit ich bessere Kontrolle habe.
Solange ich also vor meiner Monitorbox stehen bleibe, ist alles schön.
Wenn ich drei Meter weggehe, höre ich nichts mehr von dem, was ich tue.
Ich höre Echo aus dem Raum, ich höre Krachen vom Schlagzeug,
ich stehe vor einer anderen Monitorbox, zum Beispiel vom Bassisten und höre
sehr viel Bass, aber nicht, was ich spiele und damit wird es unpräzise.
Also das nervt. Das ist ein jahrzehntealtes Problem. Außerdem,
man versuchte dem entgegen zu kommen mit noch mehr Monitorboxen,
aber eigentlich ist das, das System ist so.
Und dann sehen wir hier auf dem Bild noch einen roten Abstrahlwinkel,
das ist, hinter uns stehen die Originalinstrumente, also die lauten Gitarrenverstärker
und Bassverstärker und so, das dröhnt einem von hinten in die Hosenbeine.
Auch nur mit so einem Abstrahlwinkel von ungefähr 45 Grad.
Das heißt, ihr könnt euch vorstellen...
Und davor hängen die Mikros, die den Sound eigentlich abnehmen und dann über
die große PA abstrahlen.
Wo du dann wieder auch Feedbacks kriegen kannst und Rauschen und Lärm.
Warum ist das eigentlich so? Also
wieso macht man als Instrument einen Lautsprecher und dann ein Mikrofon?
Wieso verstärkt man das nicht einfach direkt mit dem Signal und nicht auf der
Bühne, sondern woanders?
Weil du den Klang und die Verzerrung dieser echten, meistens rührenden Verstärker haben willst.
Und boxen. Auch die Box macht die Hälfte vom Klang.
Ja gut, aber die müssen ja nicht dastehen.
Genau, manchmal, wenn die Bühne nur so groß ist, dass du sie nicht woanders
hinstellen kannst, dann müssen die dastehen.
Aber bei noch größeren Bühnen siehst du dann auch manchmal, dass die die dann
an der Seite weggestellt haben, sodass die außerhalb der Bühne irgendwo hinweg leuchten oder so.
Aber du hast, gerade wenn du in kleinen Clubs spielst oder so,
da hast du gar keine Möglichkeit.
Und dann hast du auch das Problem, in kleinen Clubs, auf kleinen Bühnen,
die ersten zwei Reihen hören, den einen Gitarrenverstärker, vor dem sie stehen.
Sie hören nicht das Gesamtprodukt, was über die PA kommt, weil sie so angeblasen werden.
Es muss eine gewisse Lautstärke haben, weil das Schlagzeug laut ist,
das kriegst du kaum leiser. Also müssen die Amps laut sein.
Also ist da vorne schon mal alles laut. Und dann muss die PA irgendwie noch
lauter sein, damit du nicht nur die Bühne hörst und alle sind genervt.
Also du kriegst, du hast große Probleme, einen ordentlichen Sound zusammenzukriegen,
weil alles sich gegenseitig anbrüllt.
Kopfhörerparty!
Darum war mein Drumkit nämlich so geil, weil ich das natürlich in der Lautstärke
völlig variabel justieren konnte.
Da war die Restband immer sehr dankbar, dass sie da nicht gegen so einen Riesenkrach
anspielen mussten. Aber gut.
Ja, genau. Oder manchmal sieht man diese Plastik-Cages um Schlagzeuge drumherum.
Also wenn du ein echtes Schlagzeug hast, die also so Plexiglasscheiben,
die auch den Schall nach außen minimieren sollen.
Ich habe noch ein Bild gepostet. Ich drücke die Menü-Taste. Auf der Bühne stehen,
die man eigentlich gar nicht gerne dort hätte.
Man hätte viel lieber einfach Platz für die Musiker, damit wir da rumrennen
können. und ich poste ein weiteres Bild, wo man einfach Jetzt soll ich Kapitelmarken machen.
Jetzt soll ich Kapitelmarken machen. Also wenn du jetzt.
Also, wenn du jetzt wirklich möchtest, also wenn du jetzt über Bilder reden
im Podcast ist ja eigentlich verboten, weil dann wissen die Leute nicht worüber
du redest, weil es ist ja ein Outdoor-Podcast.
Genau, beschreib es auch. Aber wenn du jetzt möchtest, dass die Dinger jetzt
wirklich drin sind und es ist an Kapitelmarken gebunden oder sonst,
muss mal gucken, was ich machen kann und du zwingst mich dazu,
das zu tun, was wahrscheinlich dazu führt, dass die Sendung erst in drei Tagen
rauskommt, dann musst du auch eine Marke setzen.
Wenn es nur eine Content-Marke ist.
Welche ist das dann, wenn es nicht die Menü-Taste ist? Weil die hab ich jetzt gerade...
Mach ruhig die, ich weiß ja, was gemeint ist. Ist ja kontextsensitiv.
Der wird ja intelligent produziert.
Genau, also das heißt, ihr seht hier auf der Bühne hab ich jetzt mal auf diesem
Bild alles weggeixt, was man da eigentlich gerne nicht hätte.
Und ich seh auch im Slack kommen die Leute schon genau auf das Bild.
Du darfst nicht sagen, ihr seht hier. Das geht nicht. Das kann man nicht machen
im Podcast. Das geht nicht.
Sagt doch einfach, Was man da sieht.
Was man nicht sehen sollte. Genau, die Monitorboxen und die Instrumentenkästen.
Also die Amps und die Boxen von den Musikers.
Die würde man gerne alle von der Bühne haben und am liebsten auch die ganzen
Instrumentenkästen muss man halt immer auf der Tour mit rumschleppen und dafür
große Autos mieten, die sind teuer.
Also eigentlich möchte man das alles gar nicht mitnehmen.
Also zwei Drittel der Sachen auf der Bühne sind hier durchgeixt.
Dankeschön. So, genau. Und jetzt haben die Leute auch schon das richtige Thema
aufgebracht, In-Ear-Monitoring.
Alle haben bestimmt schon mal, weiß ich nicht, eine Live-Übertragung von Rock
am Ring oder sowas gesehen, da seht ihr, dass die Musikerinnen und Musiker,
die haben dann immer so schwarze Knöpfe im Ohr.
Und das sind in ihr Monitor. Die müssen natürlich nicht schwarz sein,
aber üblicherweise sieht man da im Ohr steckt irgendwie so ein Gerät.
Und dieses Gerät heißt also, man hat sowas wie ein Airpod, sage ich mal,
im Ohr, auch mit einem Funksystem dahinter.
Und dort bekommt man das Monitoring, also das, was ich gerne selber hören möchte,
auf mein Ohr für mich zusammengemischt und auch nur in mein Ohr.
Auf der Bühne brüllt nichts mehr, ich brauche keine Monitorboxen.
Und alle anderen Musiker hören das, was sie hören wollen und nicht nur einen
Mix für alle, sondern jeder hat individuell seinen oder ihren eigenen Mix.
Ich habe das auch in einem Bild dargestellt, wo man sieht, alle Instrumente
gehen in einen komischen Rack-Kasten mit sehr vielen Kabeln und einem Computer
drauf und von dort zu einem Sender und der Sender sendet es mir quasi in den Knopf im Ohr.
Und das hat natürlich riesige Vorteile, weil in diesem Ohrknopf habe ich keine
Feedbacks, ich kann es so leise machen, wie ich möchte, also ohne,
dass man Gehörschäden kriegt oder solche Sachen und man kann halt seine Gitarre
im Verhältnis so laut oder leise machen, wie man möchte.
Wie ist denn dann die Latenz?
Ich würde sagen...
Also da spreche ich jetzt als Gitarrist, die wir manchmal Dinge spielen,
ich habe sie nicht gemessen, aber ich würde mal sagen, vielleicht sind es 20
oder weniger Millisekunden.
Ich kann es dir nicht ganz genau sagen, aber es ist so, wenn ich zum Beispiel
schnelle Sechzehntel spiele und ich spiele mehrere Gitarren ein hintereinander
und ich kann sie präzise einspielen, dann ist die Latenz nicht so hoch,
dass ich ein Problem bekomme.
Also so als Keyboarder würde ich sagen, so 20 Millisekunden schon.
So ein Flam-Gefühl. Also das kriege ich normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe kein individuelles Gefühl von, die Kontrolle ist nicht da.
Aber ich habe es nicht eins zu eins gegen Kabel probiert.
Aber ich meine, Funkmikros auf einer Bühne ist ja ähnlich.
Also, weiß nicht, ihr habt bestimmt alle mal ein Funkmikro in der Hand gehabt,
da reingesprochen und hattet auch nicht das Gefühl, da kommt erst zehn Sekunden
später dann das vorne aus der PA, was ihr gerade sagt.
Ja gut, wenn es über einen Lautsprecher läuft, dann hast du ja allein schon
in der Luft ganz andere Latenzen.
Also das spielt ja keine Rolle, sondern die Latenz ist eigentlich nur dann,
wenn du einen Kopfhörer hast, relevant.
Also wenn du quasi mit deiner eigenen Stimme in ein Mikrofon sprichst und dann
hast du die Konkurrenz zwischen das, was ins Ohr eingespeist wird und das,
was du über deinen eigenen Körperschall hörst.
Also du brauchst eine Latenz, die mit dem Körperschall mithalten kann.
Das ist da nicht so schnell unterwegs und es gibt Leute, die sind da sehr sensibel.
Also ich würde sagen jetzt hier zum Beispiel den Rodecasa, den wir jetzt hier
verwenden. Wir haben ja im Prinzip genau die Situation gerade.
Der ist relativ langsam. Ich hatte es auch, glaube ich, in meinem Test mal gemessen.
Es war definitiv zu viel.
Und ich würde halt sagen, ein richtig gutes digitales Mischpult muss eigentlich
so eine Millisekunde haben in dem Mix.
Bei drei, vier gehe ich noch mit, ab fünf höre ich es.
Also das Ding klingt definitiv nicht so gut wie mein Yamaha Mixer,
den ich zehn Jahre schon vorher hier im Einsatz hatte, 14 Jahre vorher.
Weil der war immer knacke Latenz dann tue ich denen vielleicht Unrecht.
Ich habe mal einfach so geschätzt jetzt, weil ich weiß, im Studio,
wenn ich Sachen einspiele, da geht es eigentlich nicht um Funkstrecken,
da höre ich Latenzen bei Gitarre als unpräzises Spielen ab. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht...
Vielleicht ist es so, die 20 Millisekunden oder so. Ich weiß nicht, ob man fünf hören würde.
Eine Gitarre ist ja nicht in deinem Kopf.
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Du hast immer so ein mittelbares Ding noch dazwischen.
Da lehne ich mich jetzt mal nicht mit einer Zahl aus dem Fenster.
Es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass wir alle kein Problem haben.
Also noch nie hat sich irgendwer beschwert, ja, dann ist alles so labberig.
Also das kann man absolut machen Machen ja auch alle Profis und so Überall so,
das ist absoluter Standard Also das, was ich heute jetzt hier beschreibe Ist
eigentlich die Transition der
80er, 90er, 2000 Wie hat eine Band funktioniert In das, was jetzt in den.
20er Jahren dieses Jahrhunderts Eigentlich Standard wird Für alle Bands,
auch kleinere Bands So, es gibt natürlich noch welche, die schleppen gerne noch Verstärker,
Grüße gehen raus an Ben Aber eigentlich spielen wir schon Öfter Konzerte mit
Leuten die alle nur so ein Rack dabei haben.
Und ich wollte jetzt vielleicht nochmal aus technischer Sicht mal ein bisschen
zeigen, was das so bedeutet.
Also ich werfe ein weiteres Bild hier hinein und sage, es ist ein großes,
unser altes Rack hatte eine gewisse Höhe.
Ihr seht da, wie hoch wird das sein? Anderthalb Meter.
Das sind so zwei Racks aufeinander. Ich glaube 14 HE, also Höheneinheiten hatte das.
Das ist schon ein ganz guter Brocken, den man im Kombi ganz gut reinkippen kann.
Aber dieser Brocken enthielt etwas, wofür man vorher den ganzen Van gebraucht hätte.
Und zwar die, eben hat Ralf davon gesprochen, die Gitarrenverstärker,
in unserem Fall wurden die dann digital, die Kemper.
Und ich habe jetzt hier ein weiteres Bild, das muss man tatsächlich da mal drauf gucken.
Also Kemper mit K.
K-E-M-P, genau. Der der Mensch, der es gemacht hat, heißt Camper.
Habe ich vor irgendwie anderthalb Jahren oder sowas mal ein bisschen drüber erzählt.
Habt ihr denn euer Original Setup mit denen dann auch wirklich aufgenommen oder
arbeitet ihr da mit Presets, weil ihr denkt so.
Okay, da Also aufgenommen haben wir nicht mit denen, könnte man.
Also der Grundgedanke von so einem Camper ist, dass du dann dein Traum-Line-Up hast, eben aus,
Gitarren-Effekt-Geräten-Verstärker-Box Effekt-Gerät, genau Box so und dann
misst du da halt irgendwie so, weiß ich nicht, drei, vier Minuten mit rum mit
dem Camper und danach ist der erstaunlich gut quasi digitalisiert und du hast
halt das, was du eigentlich so liebst und immer haben willst,
dann halt digital dabei in viel kleiner.
Aber diese Teile bieten natürlich auch Tausende und Zehntausende von super profimäßig
eingemessenen Standardkombinationen oder auch völlig exotische Kombinationen.
Von daher, also ihr nehmt dann eher das, was da so auf dem Presetmarkt.
Teils, teils. Wir haben einen von dem anderen Gitarristen, Ferdi,
haben wir eingemessen, weil der ein Setup hatte, was er geliebt hat.
Mein Setup war mir relativ egal, ich wollte nur, dass es im Band-Kontext gut
klingt und deswegen war es bei mir ein Preset.
Also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, der Camper ist ein Computer,
der Gitarren-Sounds kann.
Und weil, sobald man sowas digital hat, heißt das natürlich,
da gibt es eine Software, da können alle Leute ihre selbst kreierten Sounds
auch hochladen und ihre eingemessenen Gitarrenverstärker und Boxen und so hochladen
und dann ist das ein riesen Repository für alle.
Wenn jemand die perfekte Jimi Hendrix Gitarre einmal da gemodelt hat,
sage ich mal, dann kann das für alle zum Download bereitstellen,
das ist ein paar Kilobyte, kann man die runterladen und dann klingt deine Gitarre halt so.
Und das ist natürlich ein Riesenunterschied zu ich kaufe dreimal im Leben einen
2000 Euro Gitarrenverstärker, der halt einen Sound hat. Ich habe halt unendlich
Sounds, ich habe alles was ich will.
Das ist halt auf dem Qualitätsniveau. YouTube ist voll mit AB-Blindtests,
wo also noch die überzeugtesten Analogis verzweifeln, dass sie bei ihrem Lieblingsequipment
selber dann keinen Unterschied mehr hören.
Ich würde da tatsächlich widersprechen. Wir haben es nie auf das Niveau gebracht,
dass es wirklich, wirklich, ich fand es immer ein bisschen muffiger,
ein bisschen, aber es gibt, es kommt glaube ich darauf an, spielst du cleane
Blues-Gitarren oder so, kann das fantastisch funktionieren, spielst du super
krasse High-Gain-Gitarren.
Vielleicht waren wir aber auch einfach zu dumm, weil ein Gitarrensound heutzutage
ist auch nicht einfach nur noch ein Sound.
Da wird dann oft ein zweiter Sound zugemischt mit einem Highcut,
dann hast du nur bestimmtes Frequenzband, was nur in den Tiefen was anderes
macht und so, reagiert vielleicht auch noch auf die Schlagzeugspur,
also es sind Automatisierungen drin und sowas, das ist nicht mehr nur einfach ein Gitarrensound.
Und im Prinzip ist es sehr elektronisch geworden, das ganze Gitarren-Business, so wie Techno auch.
Also es wird sehr viel, also ein fetter Bass ist oft auch ein synthetischer Bass.
Also wirklich, weil fetter als synthetische Sinus kannst du nicht machen,
egal wie toll du spielst, egal was du kaufst.
Also wird sowas oft zugemischt und so. Aber da kommen wir jetzt ein bisschen
ab von dem reinen technischen Setup.
Wenn ich das Bild mal beschreiben darf, in so einem Rack ist von oben nach unten
bei uns drin, oben ist einfach mein Gitarrenstimmgerät, da drunter sieht man
vier schwarze Kästchen Seite an Seite, das sind unsere Sender zu den In-Ears der Musiker.
Wir sind fünf in der Band, aber der Schlagzeuger kriegt ein Kabel,
weil der braucht keinen Funksender, denn er sitzt immer an der gleichen Stelle,
während wir uns bewegen müssen.
Deswegen sparen wir uns einen Sender, ist auch billiger und spart Platz.
Da drunter, das grüne, große, klumpige Ding ist ein Camper. Die haben wir inzwischen
nicht mehr, aber dieses Setup hatten wir damals.
Das ist also der Gitarrenverstärker, der kann einen Sound für ein Instrument machen.
Dann ist da eine Lücke und dann sieht man da die Gitarrensender,
denn es ist auch so, ich spiele Gitarre, da will ich auch kein Gitarrenkabel
haben. Weil wenn du auf der Bühne umeinander rumläufst, dann hast du ganz schnell
nach zwei Minuten Kuddelmuddel und alle sind ineinander verheddert.
Das ist ziemlich uncool. Vor allem im Halbdunkeln mit Nebel.
Genau, darunter gibt es einen weiteren, das breite ist trotzdem auch ein Gitarrensender
und darunter kommt ein weiterer Camper.
Also das eine ist vom Bass, das andere ist von der Gitarre. Und darunter einfach
nur eine Schublade, wo unser Krempel drin ist.
So Batterien und der Sender und solche Sachen. Und das war das Setup,
mit dem wir lange unterwegs waren und das war relativ groß und dann hatten wir
Ansprüche und die Ansprüche zeige ich Ihnen in einem nächsten Bild.
Aber das ja an sich ist das ja schon mal ein ziemlicher Evolutionsschritt,
im Prinzip nur so zwei Gitarrenverstärker, Synthesizer quasi zu haben und ein paar Funkstrecken.
Genau, damit spart man sich halt die Monitorkisten auf der Bühne,
damit spart man sich das Schleppen der Gitarren-Ams und der großen Boxen und
sowas. Das ist dann alles schon subsummiert, klein komprimiert in diesem Digital-Rack.
Du schleppst eine große Kiste zum Konzert und nicht zwölf oder so.
Also es ist wirklich, das ist schon ein super Unterschied. Und darum ging es
uns auch, Tourtauglichkeit.
Einfach diese Schlepperei, du wirst da verrückt. Du musst ja nach,
fährst 500 Kilometer nach Hause,
schleppst den ganzen Kram wieder in den Proberaum, musst alles verkabeln.
Das ist bei uns ja jetzt gar nicht so. Du machst die Klappe auf das Rack,
rollst das Ding ins Auto, rollst es wieder raus, machst die Klappe ab,
machst Strom rein und alles ist wie vorher.
Wo bleibt denn da die Turbo-Romantik?
Ja, das ist dann der Duft von den Mettbrötchen mit Zwiebeln,
die irgendwelche Leute dann unbedingt essen müssen.
Genau, und dann wollten wir kleiner werden und wollten gleichzeitig zum Beispiel
Stereo auf unseren In-Ears haben, damit ich meine Gitarre ein bisschen links
und die andere Gitarre ein bisschen rechts habe. Das ist für die Unterscheidbarkeit sehr viel besser.
Danke für den Tipp an Tom, das hat unsere Welt verändert. Das ist wirklich ein
Riesenunterschied, Stereo, it's a thing.
Ansonsten seht ihr auf dem Foto weiterhin die ganzen Funkstrecken und mein Stimmgerät
und oben ist so ein Ding mit so einem großen Monitor,
das ist das neue Mischpult man stellt sich ja beim Mischpult sowas mit so Fadern
vor die man so hoch und runter ziehen kann diese Digital-Mischpulte sind einfach nur noch so ein Kasten,
der einen Monitor hat den du nie benutzt und das Ding hat eine Funkverbindung
zum iPad und am iPad siehst du dann diese ganzen Fader und kannst dann eben
so viel Kanalzüge ziehen und drehen und so, wie du möchtest.
Das hat natürlich dann auch Noisegates und Hall für die Stimme und so Effekte
und ganzen Kram dabei, zum schöner machen.
So was hatten wir ja bei meiner Band auch schon vor irgendwie zig Jahren so.
Und das mit so einem iPad dann so durch den Raum laufen können,
während irgendwie der Soundcheck läuft und du kannst wirklich so Front of House
mäßig, egal wo du bist, an den Reglern rumschieben.
Das ist schon mal ein Riesenvorteil gewesen.
Aber wo kommen jetzt die Gitarren-Sounds her? Weil da sind ja jetzt keine Camper mehr drin.
Genau, du hast es genau gesehen, wir haben die Camper verkauft,
denn was du hier nicht siehst, unten ist so ein schwarzes Loch und in diesem
schwarzen Loch ist so eine kleine Rausziehschublade und diese Rausziehschublade ist ein Quad Cortex,
das müsste man eigentlich hier mal verlinken, das ist sozusagen der neuere,
10 Jahre jüngere heiße Scheiß beim Modeling von Gitarren.
Suchst du den Link gerade mal raus?
Ich bin gerade hier noch bei eurem Mischpult, das werfe ich hier gerade raus.
Das ist ein Behringer X32.
Ah ja, genau das habe ich schon gesehen, den werfe ich hier gerade nochmal rein.
Genau, Quad Cortex von der Firma Neural DSP.
Das ist, ich würde mal sagen, wenn die Camper so...
Der alte Windows-PC sind, dann ist das Quad-Cortex-Ding das iPhone.
Und das ist nicht einfach nur so das iPhone, sondern auch das ganze Usability-Thema
von denen ist sehr iPhone-artig.
Das hat einen großen Farbscreen, man kann da alles draggen und droppen,
die Typografie ist geil, Dinge sind, so ich werfe irgendeinen Link in irgendeinen,
dann könnt ihr mal gucken,
so, da hab ich einen Thomann-Link genommen, ist aber egal, sucht nach Quad Cortex.
So, das Ding ist sozusagen die 10 Jahre neuere Technik.
Das heißt, viel schnellere Prozessoren, geiler Touchscreen und was Ralf hier
gerade auf dem Schirm hat, man sieht diesen Monitor und darauf sieht man wie
App-Icons auf dem iPhone viele kleine Kästchen in vier Reihen angeordnet.
Also ihr habt von links nach rechts so eine Lane, die heißen Lanes und da sind
hintereinander so kleine,
wie Icons eben, also so wie iOS-Apps und das ist nämlich, man schachtelt sich
einfach hintereinander, was man hintereinander in der Tonkette haben möchte,
nämlich zum Beispiel zuerst, weiß ich nicht, das Noisegate und dahinter einen
EQ und dahinter den Amp und dahinter einen Kompressor und dahinter die Box und dahinter so und so.
Und das kann man einfach durch vorne und hinten tauschen, in Realtime einfach machen.
Und das Tolle ist natürlich, wenn man sich Sounds zusammenstrickt,
kann man das in Echtzeit hören, was es bedeutet, den Kompressor hinter dem Amp
zu haben oder den Kompressor vor dem Amp zu haben.
Aber du hast halt keine Drehregler mehr, wo du mal so den Gain und so. Ich sehe da keine.
Das sind doch Fußschalter. Genau, die silbernen Fußschalter,
wie viel sind es? Acht oder zehn oder so, sind auch Drehregler.
Weil du hast vollkommen recht.
Da hat ja jemand mal nachgedacht Weil man möchte gerne an so Volume-Buttons
und sowas gerne vorsichtig auch drehen können, um vorher nachher zu hören Genau.
Aus den 10. Delays, irgendwie das Timing einstellen oder sowas,
das willst du nicht auf dem Touchscreen machen.
Genau, das willst du nicht kannst du halt auch, kannst natürlich eine Zahl eingeben,
das haben sie auch schön gelöst finde ich, also ich würde sagen,
das hält bei vielem mit iOS mit, ohne iOS zu sein.
Also Also es war so gewesen, wir hatten die Camper seit 2017 und wir wollten halt kleiner werden.
Und jetzt ist das so.
Diese vier Lanes, die du da siehst, ist so viel Processing Power,
dass wenn du nicht ganz, ganz viele kleine Kästchen für deinen Gitarrensound
brauchst, du brauchst eher so drei, vier und nicht zehn, dann kannst du vier
Instrumente mit dem Ding befeuern.
Und realistisch sagen wir mal, wir brauchen zwei Lanes pro Instrument,
wenn wir es ein bisschen schöner haben wollen.
Also ein Quad Cortex befeuert bei uns bei der halben Größe vom Camper den Bass und die Gitarre.
Also habe ich nur noch ein Gerät für zwei Instrumente bei nochmal halber Größe
von vorher einem Instrument.
Also das heißt, ich habe ein Viertel Volumen.
Wenn du Instrument sagst, meinst du immer irgendwas Gitarrenartiges oder Bass?
Oh, Equation Syndrome. Ich muss wieder stehen.
Das heißt ein Instrument.
Aber ist jetzt nicht für irgendwas anderes noch.
Du kannst da natürlich auch Vocal Processing drüber machen, kannst der Sängerin
eine Lane zuweisen und einen tollen Halleffekt machen und so.
Und was diese Computer, das sind sie ja am Ende, auch können,
ist natürlich über MIDI oder so extern angesteuert werden.
Und das bedeutet zum Beispiel, und jetzt kommen wir zu der Neuerung,
die wir uns jetzt halt auch, da haben wir uns lange vorgedrückt und haben es
jetzt doch gemacht, das MacBook Air, was hier gerade in der Meta-Ebene auf dem
Tisch steht, ist eigentlich unser Band-MacBook Air.
Und das ist die Steuerzentrale für alles, was im Rack passiert.
Gemeint ist, wir benutzen Ableton Live, das ist eine DAW, wenn man so will, also so wie Reaper.
Da läuft sozusagen unser... Du musst da aufpassen.
Er hört irgendwann auf, einfach aufzunehmen.
Das war ja mal länger im Einsatz und da vor das Licht hier einen Zug gehalten hat im Meter eben.
Aber Elbiton Live lässt sich sehr geil mit mir einfach aufsetzen.
Das ist immer noch das beste User Interface. Da können sich Reaper mal einen
ganz großen Block, kompletten Brotleib von abschneiden.
Das ist nämlich so scheiße im Vergleich dazu. Also ja, ist so.
Das macht Jens, unser Bassist. Da habe ich immer nur so ein bisschen die Finger
dran, eigentlich gar nicht.
Also Ableton Live ist einfach so ein Programm, wir bündeln es nicht zum Aufnehmen,
sondern eben nur zum Abspielen.
Ihr müsst euch dann vorstellen, da sind verschiedene Tracks drauf,
nämlich zum Beispiel ein Klick-Track, also ein Metronom für die ganze Band.
Das hört nur die Band in ihren Monitoren, nicht die Leute da draußen.
Das heißt, wir hören Klick, wir hören, wenn kein Schlagzeuger gerade im Proberaum
dabei ist, können wir auch einfach das Schlagzeug anmachen und können trotzdem
proben, auch wenn der Schlagzeuger keine Zeit hat.
Wenn er da ist, machen wir es halt aus, dann schalten wir einfach die Lane aus,
den Kanal aus sozusagen und genauso haben wir da Backing-Vocals drauf,
also Chöre oder so Sachen, die wir nicht live singen können,
weil wir sind halt nur drei und nicht 30.
Das ist alles nur Fake?
Nicht alles. Nur die Leute auf der Bühne sind fake.
Das heißt, wenn wir Backing-Sachen, zum Beispiel Samples oder irgendwas,
was man da einfliegen möchte,
das können wir da beliebig zuschalten, aber auch Trigger, zum Beispiel für unsere
Rauchmaschinen auf der Bühne.
Wir haben Licht auf der Bühne, was wir selber mitbringen.
Ihr raucht auch schon selber gar nicht mehr selbst, oder was? Für alles jetzt Gerät.
Sonst macht der DJ immer den großen Knopf. Und jetzt, genau,
ihr müsst euch vorstellen, wir haben da auf der Bühne vorne so sogenannte Riser stehen.
Ego Riser genannt. Also das sind einfach so Kiste, auf die kannst du draufstellen,
dann stehst du höher. Das ist manchmal ein schöner Effekt, dann sieht man besser.
Und unter denen, die haben oben nur so Gitter drauf. Und da drunter steht so
eine Rauchmaschine, die so eine Rauchsäule nach oben schießt.
Davon haben wir zwei, vielleicht bald drei.
Und das heißt, es kommt ein bestimmter, in so einem Song, ihr kennt das, es kündigt sich was an.
Boom! Und auf der Eins kommt dann halt eben, schießen die Rauchsäulen hoch und
das Licht flackert, alles knallrot und so.
Diese Sachen werden natürlich auch von dieser einen Quelle von Ableton Live gesteuert.
Das heißt, wir verknüpfen am Anfang des Konzerts natürlich die ganzen Funkstrecken
und das MacBook mit diesem Mischpult und so weiter.
Aber eben auch ziehen wir Kabel von den Rauchmaschinen. zu.
Jetzt sind da ja aber auch Fußschalter dran und die machen ja auf einer Bühne
auch total Sinn, weil du willst von einem Song, Gitarrensound schon irgendwie
zwischen Chorus und Refrain und Strophe vielleicht so zwei, drei unterschiedliche
Presets irgendwie so hin und her schalten.
Wie kommt ihr euch dann mit euren dann doch viel weniger Fußschaltern nicht
in die Quere oder gibt es dann nochmal so Breakout-Fußgeschichten für?
Also ich bin ja der Meinung, wenn ein Computer etwas was für mich tun kann,
mache ich das nicht selber.
Deswegen kann man Ableton Live natürlich sagen, oh, hier kommt der Chorus,
schalte doch mal den Camper auf Kanal 2 für das und das Instrument.
Aber das heißt, dass wenn ihr einen Song spielt, der quasi schon in diesem Teil
oder in Ableton vorstrukturiert ist und ihr euch an Timing, Sequenzen und sowas,
mal eben so eine kleine Jam Session in der Mitte ist dann nicht so.
Nein.
Ach, so eine Band seid ihr.
Wir sind eine absolute, das ist noch ein Untercover-Band, eigentlich.
Wir sind eine absolute Playback-Band.
Man muss das leider alles noch selber spielen, aber wir arbeiten dran.
Der Bierkapitän hat ja schon.
Was ist denn das für ein Produkt, dass man mit Midi irgendwie diesen Riser hochfahren kann?
Hochfahren kann man nicht, da kommt nur der Rauch raus.
Achso, es geht nur um Rauch.
Ja, Rauch und Licht.
Ich dachte, man selbst wird hochgefahren.
Aber könntest du ja auch triggern.
Aber vermutlich gibt es Breakout-Boxen für noch mehr Fußkram.
Oder?
Na klar gibt es Fußschalter mit Midi.
Ja, gibt es. Also bei mir war aber das Ziel, ich hatte früher auch Fußschalterleisten
vorne auf der Bühne, aber da kippt
ja eh nur das Bier drauf und wenn einer Stage-Dive, dann latscht er dir.
Ich hasse, wenn auf der Bühne was steht. Ich will da laufen und ich will da nichts stehen haben.
Und deswegen, ich selber, bei mir ist es einfach, ich habe bisher nur einen
Sound, ich muss nichts umschalten, aber genau ab da, wo wir das müssen oder
wollen, weil es im Intro mit Radiosound irgendwie anders klingt oder so,
würden wir es die Maschine machen lassen. Und das macht man halt auch über Medien.
Das heißt aber natürlich auch, diese Hochintegration ist super geil,
weil du mehr machen kannst und ist genauso eine Riesengefahr.
Wenn irgendwas schief geht am Laptop oder das USB-C-Käbelchen kommt aus dem
MacBook Air raus oder so, ist natürlich deine Show gelaufen.
Also das heißt, und wir sind natürlich, genau wie du sagst, daran gebunden,
ja, du spielst den Refrain halt jetzt 18 Takte und wenn du dann zu spät bist,
wir sind halt nicht zu spät, aber wenn du dann zu spät bist,
dann kannst du auch da nichts mehr einfangen.
Was man mit diesem System allerdings schon machen kann.
Ich war halt in so einer Band, wo wir keinen Song zweimal gleich gespielt haben.
Das ist dann einfach ein anderer Ansatz.
Sowas geht aber auch damit. Wir haben zwischen den Songs so Interludes.
Also einfach so Musik, die im Hintergrund läuft, damit nicht totale Stille ist,
wenn der Song zu Ende ist, die wir uns selbst gebaut haben, die zum nächsten
Song so ein bisschen anzitiert, so Dinger.
Und da gibt es manche, da wissen wir, okay, da reden wir darüber,
hey, kommt doch zum Merch-Stand und holt ein T-Shirt oder wir sehen uns nachher an der Bar.
Und da wissen wir nicht, wie lange wir das sagen, weil wir ja interagieren mit
den Leuten. Und dann kannst du zum Beispiel sagen, im Interlude,
letzter Teil, machst du einen Loop rein.
Und erst wenn jemand wieder Space drückt, und unser Bassist steht direkt neben
dem Ding, also er drückt irgendwann Space, dann spielt der Loop zu Ende und dann geht es über.
Und wir hören halt, und das ist noch ein Ding, was wir hören,
was andere nicht hören, sogenannte Cues.
Das sind Ansagen. Also wir haben nicht nur den Klick, dass so ein Metronom mitläuft, sondern...
Wach auf, du bist gleich da.
Ja, es ist so, genau.
Jetzt das Publikum animieren.
Picasso.
Die Metaebene bricht zusammen.
Hast du das berührt? Ja, mit dem Stuhl oder irgendwie nach hinten.
Alfred Hitchcock ist mir fast aufs Gesicht.
Original Thinktank für den Poster.
Ja, ich muss mir auch was einfallen lassen.
Gehen Sie weiter, es gibt nichts zu sehen.
Was war die Frage?
Irgendwas mit den Automatisierungen von dem hier.
Genau, mit so improvisierten Sequenzen und eure Loops und dann Space-Taste und
dann geht's wieder. Die Cues.
Cues, also C-U-E. Cues. Und Hinweise, genau.
Das heißt zum Beispiel, ich höre dann, ich rede gerade mit den Leuten und höre
auf dem Ohr Invisible, so heißt ein Song von uns.
Falls ich gerade nicht auf die Liste gucke, was als nächstes kommt,
Invisible Und dann irgendwie 10 Seconds oder so Und dann hörst du halt irgendwie 3, 2,
1 Und dann hörst du halt den Klick vom nächsten Song Das heißt,
ich bin orientiert, wo ich bin Und für uns ist das eine super Erleichterung
Weil du auch Sachen machen kannst Jetzt gerade in diesem Metal-Kontext Ihr kennt
das auf der Bühne, der Schlagzeuger zählt so ein Genau.
Wie sich das gehört Kann man ja auch machen.
Wenn man will Aber geiler ist manchmal zu sagen So und das nächste Baby ist
genau das und ohne dass jemand was ahnt, fangen alle gleichzeitig an und der
Rauch kommt und das Licht ballert und die Strobos.
Also du hast keine Anzähler und kannst deswegen diesen Schockmoment des Anfangs auch geiler gestalten.
Wir hören halt eins, zwei, drei, vier, wir wissen jetzt geht's los und können einfach anfangen.
Das muss man ja nicht so machen, aber dann kann man überhaupt so Sachen machen. Schon geil.
Aber ich werde zu alt für sowas. Also ich sehe den Punkt, aber...
Kommt ja auf die Mucke an. Also das ist ja nicht was für jeden Kontext.
Aber uns nimmt das halt unglaublich viel Schmerz aus dem ganzen Ding.
Also die Bühne ist halb leer. Wir fahren viel weniger Zeug rum.
Wir haben viel präziseres Hören durch die In-Ear-Monitore.
Weil das ist wirklich... Ich mache mir selbst die Bassdrum 1 dB leiser.
Das kannst du vergessen in einem echten Bühnen-Setup, wo alles sich gegenseitig anschreit. Und...
Nee, gegen das Setup habe ich gar nichts. Also ich habe jetzt ein leichtes Störgefühl,
das ist ein schöner Begriff aus der ZLB, was halt jetzt so dieses sehr durchgeskriptete angeht.
Weil da finde ich dann schon auch ein bisschen vom Live-Spiel irgendwie dann
verloren geht, wenn halt alles wirklich schon mit sehr engen Leitplanken so versehen ist.
In dem Fall haben wir uns die ja gesetzt Du musst die ja so nicht machen Du
kannst ja einfach sagen, du machst jetzt nur den Song Und nur den Klick und
das war's Und dann machst du nachhalb Pause und wenn du den nächsten Song spielen
willst Machst du halb Pfeil nach rechts Ja.
Ich denke auch, das ist der Punkt Du kannst halt sehr sophisticated Sachen machen
Die sonst gar nicht denkbar wären Die einen eigenen Wert haben Du kannst es
halt anders Choreografieren Du kannst es auch mit,
Nicht-Musikinstrumenten kombinieren Du kannst es mit Licht, mit Rauch,
mit was weiß ich, vielleicht,
cool, also ich hab dich ja vorhin so verstanden, dass ihr so eine Box habt,
die ihr mit Midi dazu bringen könnt, dass so ein Fahrstuhl hochfährt und du
stehst dann sozusagen so drauf, weißt du, so Rauch und so.
Lady Gaga.
Ist das dann Lady Gaga?
Nee, aber es gibt ja dieses so aus der Bühne hochfahren und so,
da brauchst du ja so Lafetten und Hydraulik und so. Musst ja auch wieder rumfahren.
Also sowas könnte man sich wahrscheinlich sogar noch relativ einfach bauen,
weil das ist ja nur irgendwie wie ein Stepper-Motor, richtige Umsetzung,
irgendwie in so eine Box eingebaut und dann kannst du halt so Scherze machen.
Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendein Wert ist.
Alles, was du MIDI triggern kannst, hast du ja hier in der Meta-Ebene auch gemacht.
Also alles, was du triggern kannst, kannst du halt triggern.
Und dann sagst du, Ableton, einfach mach den Trigger auf dem Kanal und go.
Fußpedale hatte ich auch mal überlegt für Kapitelmarken, aber das war dann...
Aber soundtechnisch seid ihr mit diesem DSP Quad Cortex zufrieden.
Also es war so, wir spielten die Camper seit 2017, dann haben wir ein Quad Cortex
gekauft, weil wir gehofft haben, er ist hoffentlich wenigstens gleich gut,
dann haben wir ungelogen drei Minuten hat Jens einen Amp zusammengestellt,
Standard 5150, die und die Box, also es ist ein bestimmter Gitarrenamp.
Einfach wirklich in drei Minuten das per Hand zusammengeschoben,
wie auf dem iPhone. Wir haben das Ding angesteckt und ich habe nie wieder den Camper angemacht.
Das war der Effekt und wir haben sofort das zweite Ding gekauft und die Camper verkauft.
Also das ist einfach nochmal ein Quantensprung. Also vor allem für unsere Mucke.
Du kannst mit dem Camper sehr schöne Sounds machen, aber für das,
was wir suchen, war das einfach, endlich klingt es so. Endlich, endlich.
Aber eigentlich auch das Handling. Ich natürlich als UI-Freak,
wenn ich das Ding einmal gesehen habe, der Camper ist wirklich wie ein Radio
selber auseinanderbauen.
Kondensatoren löten. Nee, wirklich, das ist kein Interface. Das ist für mich
unbenutzbar, das Ding. Habe ich auch immer andere Leute machen lassen.
Da habe ich vollkommen kapituliert.
Also das hat ja auch eine Fernsteuerung beim Rechner.
Also die eigentliche Modellierung machst du ja alles am Computer und dann ist
es eigentlich sehr schön, finde ich, darauf reduziert, so was brauchst du dann live noch wirklich?
Also ich habe halt den Stage, der eine Kombination ist aus Fußtastern plus ein
paar Regler und diese Regler regeln halt genau das, was du so live halt brauchst
und den ganzen restlichen Krams machst du in Ruhe auf dem Sofa mit dem Computer halt.
Aber okay, also ich sehe den Punkt. Vor allem diese Kombination aus Fußschalter
und Drehregler, die habe ich überhaupt noch gar nicht gesehen.
Das werden die nicht erfunden haben, aber das ist natürlich eine coole Idee.
Ich kannte es auch noch nicht, aber es ist auch sehr solide gemacht und so. Das merkt man.
Das Ding hat auch einen Lüfter drin. Merkt man auch. Also in dem Moment,
wo der rechnet, kommt an der Seite was raus gepustet.
Wir mussten ihn also auch im Rack so verbauen, dass der auf jeden Fall Abwärme
irgendwo ableiten kann.
Der Huckel hatte übrigens gefragt über Mastodon, als ich wegen IEM,
also In-Ear-Monitoring, mal was gepostet habe, welche wir benutzen,
weil er sich glaube ich überlegt, für irgendeinen anderen Zweck zu Hause,
glaube ich, eher Gitarren aufzunehmen.
Und wir benutzen jetzt gerade hauptsächlich die Shure, die kleinen 200 Euro Dinger, also S-H-U-R-E.
221 oder so, müsste ich jetzt nachgucken, also die Standard kleinen Shure Funkstrecken
mit so einem kleinen Kopfhörerchen dabei,
so transparente Hörer das sind so zwei Wegesysteme, die funktionieren,
das tut's irgendwie, wenn die im Ohr gut halten das war bei unserer Sängerin
zum Beispiel nicht so dann sind die okay.
Und ich habe in letzter Zeit mal Heroes ausprobiert von der Firma Bachmeier
aus München. Das ist dann schon eher so der High-Class-Kram.
Und fragt mich gerne bei Interesse, wenn ihr über Heroes was wissen wollt,
denn ich habe mir die Heroes, die es bis vor kurzem gab, mal so ein Testpackage
von allen in ihr Hörern zuschicken lassen.
Die haben dann zwei Wege, drei Wege, vier oder fünf sogar.
Also viele Wege ist falsch, Treiber. Die haben zwei Treiber drin,
dann hast du halt Höhen und Bässe und die haben manchmal drei Treiber,
das ist wie bei Boxen zu Hause und manche haben auch vier oder fünf Treiber
drin und die klingen dann halt immer besser aufgelöst.
Die kleinen klingen simpler und sind billiger und die großen sind teurer.
Und wir reden von teuer, die großen Kosten wie 1600 Euro und die kleinen 800
oder so, 900, das ist schon substanziell nur für die Hörer, ohne Funksystem.
Also nur die Hörer angepasst ans eigene Ohr allerdings, den rutschen dann nicht mehr und klingen super.
Und die Heroes haben gerade alles komplett neu rausgebracht.
Ich hatte gerade deren Testpaket einmal durchprobiert und dachte,
okay, ich will die und die.
Da hörte ich, weil ich dort angerufen habe, dass sie sagen, ja,
in zwei Wochen kommen die Neuen. Ich so, okay, hab sie mir direkt nochmal schicken lassen.
Und ich verlinke einfach mal heroes.shop oder irgendwie so.
Mit den In-Ears, was ist so mit dem Argument, du willst doch gerade den Bass
im Bauch und so, gerade das brauchst du doch als Band.
Finde ich, braucht man auch, genau, aber du willst nicht den Tinnitus im Ohr.
Das heißt, du kriegst natürlich bei einem echten Konzert, hast du ja Subwoofer
unter der Bühne und du hast ja die ganze PA.
Die ist nicht präzise genug, dass du toll deine Anschläge hörst, aber den Bums hast du.
Aber das Fundament ist drunter.
Absolut. Wenn der Drummer in die Bassdrum kickt, dann spürst du das halt bis
in den Unterleib. Das ist auf jeden Fall da. Du hast die Konzertatmosphäre.
Ja, ich mache mal hier diesen Link rein, mal sehen, ob er den nimmt.
Ich mache mal HTTPS, dies, das und so. Könnt ihr euch mal angucken.
Genau, die werden es jetzt bei mir werden und da würde ich aber sagen,
und das ist jetzt das, was vielleicht Richtung Hucke geht, man kann sich halt
für 200 Euro irgendwelche In-Ears holen von Shure, das ist so der Standard, würde ich sagen, tut's.
Und man kann halt 800 Euro ausgeben, 1000, 1500, 1600 und wahrscheinlich gibt es noch teurere.
Und lohnt sich das? Das ist halt die Frage, die man sehr selten selber ausprobieren
kann, vor allem bei den Angepassten, weil das Anpassen ist das Teure.
Du musst halt zum Akustiker dir das Ohr ausgießen lassen, die machen dann einen
3D-Scan dazu, schicken das dann der Firma und inzwischen werden die auch wohl
3D geprintet, die Dinger.
Habe ich auch erst neu erfahren. Ich dachte, so digital ist Deutschland nicht, aber doch.
Ja, und das aber alles ist halt einfach teuer und Handarbeit und dies und das.
Und die bleiben dann aber auch drin und rutschen nicht raus,
auch wenn du da wild am Moschen bist.
Genau, Headbang und alles, man muss wissen,
wie man die ins Ohr tut und hinten habe ich eine kleine Klammer,
die das Kabel nochmal ans T-Shirt klammert, weil bei mir läuft das Kabel dann
unter dem Gitarrengurt durch und wenn ich mich dann nach vorne beuge,
um die Haare schwingen zu lassen,
dann zerre ich ja an dem Kabel und dann der Gitarrengurt zerrt dann in die andere
Richtung. So was kann dir schon die Dinger aus den Ohren ziehen.
Du willst also eine Zugentlastung und deswegen habe ich so eine kleine Klammer,
wie man so am Schreibtisch, gibt es doch diese Klemmen, die man so aufklemmt
oder für so Hosenträger zum Beispiel.
Und die Teile selber kabellos haben, das ist dann alles wieder zu wackelig.
Gibt es nicht. Nicht, dass ich je gesehen hätte, dass da auch noch ein Funksystem
drin ist. Die Dinger sind proppenvoll mit diesen Treibern.
Also es ist nicht wie Airpods.
Was das angeht.
Und auch da wäre latenzgarantiert ein Problem.
Ja, also Wireless.
Ja, genau.
Der Tod.
Wobei wir natürlich...
Das ist jetzt auch Wireless.
Ja, genau. Das Kabel führt zu meinem Funkempfänger an meinem Gürtel.
Also es ist schon ein Wireless, aber die sind dann Diversity,
zwei Antennen drin, die haben dann mehrere Frequenzen, viel mehr Saft.
Wir benutzen übrigens einen Tipp für alle Bands da draußen. Wir haben umgestellt
von In-A-Loop-Batterien, die immer wie bei allen In-A-Loop-Akkus,
wie bei allen Akkus liefern die ja die volle Spannung, nicht die ganze Zeit.
Ist Spannung das Richtige?
Das ist lustig, das Thema habe ich auch noch auf meiner Liste heute.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was du meinst.
Also bei Akkus ist es so, im Gegensatz zu Batterien, die man kauft und leider
immer wegwerfen muss, wo ich gar keinen Bock drauf habe, ist es so, Akkus.
Gehen halt, sagen wir mal, die können jetzt irgendeine Spannung,
x Volt, boah, ich sage bestimmt alles falsch, das werfe ich immer durcheinander,
Spannung, Widerstände und Strom.
Spannung, ja, sagen wir mal, du brauchst Spannung, 10 und die Akkus machen so,
nach drei Minuten machen die nur noch Spannung 8, halten die ziemlich lang und
sterben relativ schnell plötzlich.
So, während eine Batterie hält sehr lange Spannung 10,
geht gegen Ende so ein bisschen auf 9,8 und deswegen merkt das Gerät auch,
hey, deine Batterie wird leer und zeigt dir in der LED eine andere Lampe an,
dann gehen sie auf 9,7 und auf 9,5 und auf 8, und irgendwann reicht es nicht
mehr, um das Ding am Leben zu halten und dann geht es halt aus.
Aber Akkus sterben halt instant. Oder sehr, sehr schnell, in drei Minuten und nicht in 20.
Und das Problem, In-N-Loop-Akkus haben den Vorteil, du kannst sie einen Monat
im Schrank liegen lassen und die verlieren nicht so viel Energie.
Aber sie haben auch das Problem, wenn du ein System hast, was diese Spannung
braucht die ganze Zeit, wie unser Funksystem, dann hast du ständig Knackser und so drin.
Weil das Gerät so fast genug Saft kriegt, aber nicht ganz, aber jetzt doch wieder,
aber dann, das ist schlecht.
Deswegen haben wir die ganzen In-N-Loops abgeschafft. die waren eh ein paar
Jahre alt, dann wird es natürlich immer schlimmer und haben jetzt Lithium-Ionen- Akkus gekauft.
Jetzt hätte ich mal raussuchen sollen, welche, weil da gibt es tolle Batterie-Vergleichs-Seiten.
Man kann nicht einfach irgendwas kaufen, aber unsere sind ganz geil.
Weil das wäre jetzt schon interessant, weil da immer auf der Suche hast du irgendwie
Amazon Shopping History oder Tumann oder was auch immer.
Und da haben wir jetzt komplett drauf umgestellt, was man wissen muss,
man braucht dafür spezielle Ladegeräte auch.
Also diese Dinger, das sind AA-Akkus, ganz normale, wie wir sie kennen, aus dem Wecker.
Aber die Lithium-Ionen brauchen ein anderes Ladegerät.
Es geht ja auch immer die Sage, dass die Inelobes nicht mehr so gut sind wie
früher, als sie noch von Sanyo kamen.
Kann ich nicht sagen, weil unsere sind, die haben über Corona im eisgehaltenen
Proberaum gelegen und irgendwann sind die halt auch durch.
Genau, eins hier von Higson. Ich werde einen Link verteilen.
Und wenn er mir den Link rausgibt, ich nehme das hier und werfe es in den Slack.
Das sind die, die wir haben. Das war Stand, als ich sie gekauft habe,
sagen wir mal vor sechs Monaten oder so.
Wenn es noch geilere, neuere Erkenntnisse gibt, dann möge man mich da korrigieren.
Genau, also auf jeden Fall ist es schon so, ah hier, die Leute wissen schon
Bescheid, die Akkus machen gleich nur 1,2 Volt statt 1,5 Damit kommen nicht
alle Geräte zurecht Die sagen jetzt hier.
Sie hatten 1,5 die du gepostet hast.
Genau, aber die Frage ist, wie lange halten sie die halt wirklich und das funktioniert
mit denen Wir hatten auch ein anderes Problem auch, ach da müsste ich auch diesen Podcast posten,
Jens und ich haben uns mal einen Podcast gesetzt und haben unser komplettes
System noch viel deutlicher erklärt, so als Anleitung für Bands.
So, wenn ihr das umbauen wollt, von alte Amps auf unser Zeug,
was müsst ihr beachten und so.
Und da sind auch Sachen drin, wie, wenn du vier Funksysteme hast von Shure,
also diese Ohrhör-in-ihr-Funksysteme, ab drei kriegst du schon Interferenzenprobleme.
Dann kriegst du Knackser und Tonausfälle, einfach nur, weil zu viel Funkwirrwarr
auf der Bühne unterwegs ist.
Um das zu ändern, brauchst du eine Sammelantenne, so ein Antenna-Combiner.
Da musst du fast 1000 Euro ausgeben oder irgendwie 800 Euro ausgeben,
um nochmal ein extra Gerät ins Rack zu packen und eine, so eine,
wie sieht die aus, wie so eine kleine Finne oder so eine Fahne,
so eine kleine Antenne, die du separat auf die Bühne stellen musst und die.
Kombiniert dann eben alle Funk-Dinger, die du in deinem Rack hast und schickt
die gesammelt einmal über die Bühne, um sowas zu verhindern.
Und man kann immer noch in Probleme laufen, wie hatten wir in München,
haben wir im Backstage gespielt, Das ist so ein Club und wir spielen den ersten
Song, man fängt an abzurocken und auf einmal haben alle totale Aussätze auf
dem In-Ear und du hörst nicht mehr richtig und das ist natürlich Mist.
Was stellte sich raus, was es war? Die Band, die nach uns gespielt hat,
hat ihr Rack schon mal neben die Bühne geschoben, die auch so Funkstrecken drin
hat und hat das Rack eingeschaltet, weil sie ja schon mal alles so verkabeln und Strom und Dingens.
Und in dem Moment, wo sie ihre Funkstrecken angemacht haben,
haben die halt unsere Funkstrecken gestört und das war alles Chaos.
Aber das musst du erstmal raffen. Du bist auf der Bühne, du rockst da rum,
auf einmal hörst du nichts mehr. Ist die Gitarre kaputt? Ist der Sender kaputt? Ist der Akku leer?
Ist irgendwo ein Kabelbruch? Haben die anderen das Problem auch? Weißt du alles nicht?
Irgendwas ist scheiße, aber du musst ja gerade noch weiter präzise blind weiterspielen,
um nicht für die Leute da vorne alles zu verkacken.
Also diese Momente wird man einfach haben. Es gibt Learning Curves bei dem ganzen Shit.
Gerade mal geschaut, also die sind jetzt schon auch doppelt so teuer wie Eneloops,
die auch schon nicht so richtig günstig sind, aber dafür halt 1,5 Volt und...
Wenn sie denn das Problem lösen, so be it.
Also das ist jetzt nichts für irgendwie das Kinderspielzeug im Haushalt,
sondern das ist dann jetzt halt echt für die Spezialanwendung.
Genau, sie lösen das Problem, bringen neue mit. Weil sie die Spannung halten,
weiß dein Gerät nie, dass dein Akku langsam leer geht.
Dass es gleich zu Ende geht.
Das heißt, das Licht ist immer grün, bis es stirbt. Du hast vielleicht ein bisschen
Knackser auf einmal, so die letzten paar Minuten.
Also wenn ich jetzt noch Knackser höre, die wir anderweitig ausgeschlossen haben,
denke ich, oh shit, die Batterien gehen leer. Und tausche sie halt zwischen den Songs.
Also die alten Eneloop-Batterien waren Nickel-Metall-Hydrid-Batterien und die
haben 1,2 Volt geliefert.
Und das ist meistens kein Problem, wenn man das so für Tastaturen und so Geräte,
die ohnehin relativ wenig Power brauchen und nur konstant versorgt werden sollen,
war das halt eine gute Lösung.
Wo sie halt mit den klassischen AA,
den, nennen wir nochmal die klassischen Batterien, die Alkali-Batterien nicht
mithalten konnten, ist, dass die halt eigentlich auf 1,5 Volt gespeckt waren.
Jetzt gibt es halt viele Geräte, denen ist es halt egal, aber es gibt auch Geräte, denen ist es nicht egal.
Zum Beispiel so ein Milchschäumer-Handmixer ist so ein Kandidat,
der lässt sich dann halt einfach mit so zwei 1,2 Volt Akkus einfach nicht betreiben
und mit 1,5 funktioniert es halt.
Was du da vorhin beschrieben hast mit der Kurve, das ist halt eine Eigenschaft,
also die Alkali-Batterien,
die lassen halt mehr oder weniger linear, diese Spannung bricht halt mit der
Zeit ein und fangen sehr viel früher an.
Sodass dann halt irgendwie die Power langsam sinkt, aber es ist halt auch noch
genug, dann dreht sich das Ding ein bisschen langsamer und irgendwann reicht es dann halt nicht mehr.
Ja, bei den moderneren Akkus wie den Lithium-Ionen und ich glaube das gilt auch
für die Nickel-Metallhydrid, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau,
ist es so, dass diese Kennlinie, also dieser Verlauf der Spannung eben eher….
So ist, dass er über den Großraum mehr oder weniger konstant ist und dann halt
schnell einbricht, hatten wir hier auch schon nochmal diskutiert,
als wir über diese ganze Viktronen- und Solarsache gequatscht haben,
ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche Thema.
Ich fand das jetzt ganz lustig, dass du das jetzt aufbringst,
weil ich hab mir jetzt nämlich auch, ich hab ganz viele Enelups,
die ich jetzt alle gar nicht mehr brauche, weiß gar nicht, was ich damit jetzt
machen soll, ich würde die irgendwie jemandem spenden, aber ich weiß nicht,
wer noch welche braucht.
Ich wüsste jemand tatsächlich. unsere Kim arbeitet in einem Kindergarten und
die hatten immer Bedarf.
Also wenn du irgendwen kennst von so Institutionen oder halt für so Geräte.
Abspielgeräte und so weiter, ja genau, da kann gut sein.
Kinderspielzeug, irgendwas.
Genau. Dann habe ich mir also geguckt, okay, es gibt halt mittlerweile so Lithium-Polymer-Akkus,
also wenn man Lithium-Ionen sagt, sagt das ja eigentlich gar nichts aus,
weil Lithium-Ionen sind immer im Spiel.
Die Frage ist, was ist halt außerdem Lithium noch so drin? drin.
Dann gibt es halt Polymer 1000 Varianten, LFPs, pipapo.
Pfiffig ist, es gibt halt mittlerweile diese AA-Batterien mit USB-C-Port.
Und das ist ja wirklich ein Feature.
Was?
Ja, du kannst ja AA-Batterien kaufen, die haben halt oben entweder so an der
Seite oder oben auf der Kopfseite haben die einfach ein USB-C-Sort.
Das ist eine geile Idee. Und die haben halt ein eigenes Ladegerät sozusagen mit drin.
Das heißt, du steckst halt einfach USB-C an deine Batterie und brauchst halt
nicht so ein externes Ladegerät.
Nachteil ist, hast du ein externes Ladegerät, kannst du das aber nicht mehr
verwenden für die Dinger.
Und weniger Platz drin für den eigentlichen Batteriesaft.
Ja gut, das ist halt dann die Frage, wie viel Leistung die Dinger haben,
wie kompakt die sind, da muss man dann halt selber mal schauen,
aber mein Hauptproblem war in dem Moment einfach die 1,5 Volt,
wobei ich jetzt eh von dem Stabmixer weggegangen bin und mir jetzt ein Standalone
Milchschäumergerät gekauft habe und mein Leben ist wieder ein bisschen besser
geworden dadurch, wer hätte es gedacht.
Ja genau, ich kenne die, genau wie du gesagt hast, mit dem Stecker noch so auf
der Seite, aber es gibt die auch mit Stecker von oben.
Gibt es oben, gibt es von der Seite, gibt es alle möglichen,
aber es ist halt ganz pfiffig, wenn man halt mal AA braucht,
aber eigentlich schon auf universelles Laden mit USB-C umgestiegen ist, geht damit halt.
Also jeden einzelnen von denen dran stöpseln ist natürlich irgendwie umständlich
versus ich kann jetzt irgendwie acht Stück in meinem Ansman gleichzeitig rein.
Ja, die meisten kommen dann auch mit so Krakenkabeln, wo du dann irgendwie so
einen Verteiler hast auf vier Kabel oder so.
Aber meistens braucht man ja gar nicht so viele und man lädt die dann halt vor,
wie man das irgendwie auch sonst so macht für den Makita Akku oder so.
Ich hatte die überlegt, aber wir haben uns dagegen entschieden.
Einmal, weil die halt dann weniger Wumms haben, aber auch, weil bei uns ist
es so, wir brauchen eher, ich weiß nicht, jeder hat zwei Akkus in jedem Gerät.
Das sind irgendwie vier, sechs, sieben Geräte oder so.
Das heißt, wenn wir so ein großes Ladegerät da stehen haben,
wo irgendwie, weiß nicht, zehn Akkus gleichzeitig laden können,
das macht schon total Sinn. Da willst du halt nicht mit den Kabelchen rumeiern.
Es ist immer noch keine richtig geile Lösung fürs Rack tatsächlich.
Es gibt nur ein einziges Ladegerät, was ich gefunden habe, was in ein Rack einbaubar ist.
Denn ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wenn man auf Tour ist, dann will man auch wieder
nicht so Ladegeräte mit diesen Kabel-Dings rumfliegen haben.
Die hat oben keine Klappe, dann fallen die Batterien raus. Das musst du alles
irgendwo in eine Kiste tun und das ist auch alles scheiße.
Aber das Ladegerät, also wo du in einem Rack sowas fest verschraubst und dann
so von vorne einfach die Batterien da so reinsteckst, die kosten dann irgendwie
wahnsinnige 800 Euro oder so ein Quatsch und können kein Lithium-Ionen.
Deswegen, ja, dann gut, dann machen wir es also mit Ladegerät,
aber das war ein Grund dann nicht die USPC-Dinger zu nehmen,
fand das aber auch sehr interessant.
Ich glaube, Tom hatte mal schlechte Erfahrungen mit denen, ich will aber jetzt
nichts Falsches sagen, weil er die für seine Heizungsthermostaten benutzen wollte.
Und da, ja, ich glaube, da hielten die dann auch wieder die Spannung nicht und
dann ging das mit den Thermostaten nicht und dann ist natürlich alles schrecklich.
Dann hat er sich, glaube ich, genau, hat er sich selber was gelötet,
dass die quasi permanent eingesteckt sind in dem USB-C.
Ich glaube, so war das. Sodass die quasi immer geladen werden,
während sie im Heizungsthermostat stecken oder so.
Und das ist irgendwie, weiß auch alles nicht, was man haben will. Keine Ahnung.
Ach ja, die Welt der Energieversorgung. Da muss ich auch noch ein anderes Produkt
droppen, was ich mir gerade noch gekauft hatte. Das war auch noch so ein guter Tipp.
Das passt jetzt so halb dazu. Und zwar,
wer so Makita-Akkus hat, sozusagen
als Energiequelle für die ganzen geilen Makita-Werkzeuge, hat man ja,
möchte auch gerne noch einen,
wie heißt das so schön?
Das ist hier wieder irgendein China-Kram, Uhun, tralala, das ist ein Gerät,
das ist so halb so groß wie so ein Makita-Akku und hat einen Makita-Akku-Stecker
und das steckst du auf deinen Makita-Akku drauf.
So.
Und was macht das?
Makita-Akku-Stecker-Stecker.
Naja.
Dank dem Adapter.
Dank dem Adapter wird jetzt dein Makita-Akku zu einer Powerbank.
Sweet.
Das heißt, du hast da hat einen USB-C-Ausgang mit 65 Watt und kannst da irgendwie
auch USB-A anschließen und hat auch ein kleines Display und ist klug.
Aber du kannst dann mit dem Teil auch über USB-C deinen Makita-Akku laden.
Also du machst sozusagen wirklich eine vollständige Powerbank,
die man über USB-C beladen und entladen kann.
What a time to be alive.
Oder? 65 Watt? Also du kriegst ja richtig ein MacBook mit befeuert?
Ja, müsste funktionieren, ja.
Sweet.
So aus dem Makita-Akku mein MacBook, weißt du?
Ja, ist ja auch ein Klumpen, ne? Also warum nicht?
Ja, also wie lange es dann hält, das hängt dann von deinem Akku ab, so, aber...
Und dann per Solarladen.
Ja.
Full Circle.
Das sind so Produkte, die man,
mal kennen muss. Da muss man dann Freakshow hören, dann kriegt man sowas.
Finde ich mir auf jeden Fall mal an. Habe ich ja öfter gehört.
Wir haben unsere magische Zeitmarke erreicht.
Das ist die 4.
Gibt es, ja wir machen ja eigentlich in der Regel nach 4 Stunden fällt ja Ralf tot um.
So viel ist sicher.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, Ralf hat tatsächlich noch 2 Themen, die er jetzt entweder
noch bringen oder verschieben kann.
Vielleicht machen wir eine Sache so als Rausschmeißer.
Kann ich noch kurz reingrätschen? Ich habe gesehen, dass mein Thema noch nicht
zugemacht hat. Das sind einfach nur zwei Links.
Wer ein bisschen sehen möchte, wie unser Tech Rider aussieht,
also wenn wir in einem Venue spielen und denen ja sagen müssen,
was wir für Technik mitbringen, das tut man in einem sogenannten Tech Rider.
Das sind so ein paar Seiten, wo drin steht, wir brauchen diese Kabels und wir bringen das mit.
Da kann ich mal den Link, weil ich glaube, das ist immer ganz schön.
Es gibt nicht so richtig viele schöne Tech-Rider, finde ich,
und wir haben sehr, sehr viel Mühe da reingesteckt, den verständlich zu halten.
Wenn jemand denkt, ja, wie habt ihr das gemacht, wie habt ihr das gemacht, da drin steht's.
Und das andere ist, es gibt ein Schaltplan-PDF und ich verlinke jetzt mal einen Podcast,
den habe ich eben schon mal erwähnt, den werde ich jetzt raussuchen,
wo Jens und ich ausführlich erzählt haben, vor allem Jens, wie unser Rackzeug
aussieht und dort in den Shownotes findet ihr auch die PDFs,
wo ihr wirklich den Schaltplan von unserem Rack und sowas seht. seht.
Da steckt sehr, sehr viel Gehirnschmalz von Jens drin und wir haben halt gedacht,
Leute sollen schöner Spaß in ihren Bands haben.
Deswegen hatten wir den da verlinkt. Das ist jetzt nicht das ganz neue Rack,
davon gibt es leider keinen. Aber ob da jetzt ein Camper drin ist oder ein Quad
Cortex, ist euch auch egal.
Okay, und damit übergebe ich an mich.
Bevor Ralf dann seinen Dings macht, schmeiße ich auch noch kurz zwei Sachen
ab, die ich ungern jetzt noch verschieben wollte.
Es sind zwei Feindings im Internet.
Das eine ist der Bellingcat Bellingcat Shadowfinder.
Was könnte das sein? Das ist sowas für Leute, die vielleicht später mal so im
OSINT-Bereich Erfolg haben wollen.
Ihr wisst schon, so Leute, die die ganze Zeit im Internet hängen und irgendwie
Open Source Intelligence machen.
Der Bellingcat Shadow Finder ist ein zugegebenermaßen etwas krude User Interface Tool,
aber was es macht ist, man kann halt ein Foto hochladen, auf dem irgendwas fotografiert
ist, was einen Schatten wirft.
Was? Krass.
Und du markierst halt, du misst einfach die Länge des Objektes oder die Höhe
des Objektes und du misst die Länge des Schattens.
Und diese zwei Zahlen, die gibst du ein. Du hast einfach die Pixel in Photoshop,
was auch immer in deinem Screen Capture Tool. Wie hoch ist das Objekt?
Wie breit ist Schatten? Dann wirfst du das da rein.
Und dann rechnet er. Und jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, du weißt,
wann das Bild geschossen wurde, Datum und Uhrzeit.
Dann kann er dir so einen Ring zeigen, wo auf der Welt dieses Foto gewesen sein
kann mit einer relativ genauen Angabe.
Aber wenn du die Zeit nicht weißt, wenn du nur die Tageszeit weißt,
also wenn du nicht absolut, wenn du nicht weißt, wo auf der Welt welche,
du hast irgendeine Local Time, aber du weißt nicht, wessen Local Time,
dann kriegst du so einen Ring um die Erde herum irgendwie.
Also es gibt Möglichkeiten, das einzuschränken. Wenn du von irgendeinem Ding
zwei Fotos hast oder wenn du halt genau das Datum und die Uhrzeit hast,
dann findest du damit wirklich relativ schnell irgendeinen Ort auf dieser Welt.
Das fand ich irgendwie cool.
Und die zweite Sache, das zweite Finding ist, wird ja immer wieder beklagt,
dass Letty hier nicht mehr ist.
Ja, das kann man beklagen, aber die ist ja nicht aus der Welt.
Und Letti hat jetzt, also erstmal hat sie mit Huckel ja einen Podcast,
den Glitterbrains Podcast, glitterbrains.org, aber sie ist jetzt auch unter
die YouTuberin gegangen.
Also Letti gibt es jetzt auch in Bild und Ton und sie hat ihr anderes großes
Hobby dort zum Inhalt gemacht.
Sie ist ja so eine Masterclass-Näherin und macht sich ja irgendwie all ihre
Klamotten selber schon immer.
Und jetzt hat sie angefangen, das so richtig schön im Garde Maas auf Englisch
im Internet abzukippen und das gibt es ab jetzt auf YouTube.
Typ, aber ich habe von ihr was gesehen, da ging es um Light Travel.
Also sprich, wie packe ich super leicht, wie packe ich eigentlich für eine bestimmte
Reise? Da ist sie auch immer viel unterwegs.
Und genau meine Reise nach Berlin, da stellte sich genau diese Frage,
wie nehme ich für sieben Tage irgendwie Zeug mit, wenn ich weiß,
es wird über 30 Grad, ich muss immer T-Shirts wechseln und will trotzdem nur
einen Rucksack mitnehmen.
Dann habe ich mal bei ihr reingeklickt, aber leider hatte sie auch irgendwelche
Utensilien, die ich auch gar nicht hätte.
Und bei ihr geht es auch, glaube ich, eher darum, rum, ich bin irgendwo im Wald,
aber ja, also deswegen, das ist das, was ich gesehen hatte, ich dachte,
es ging darum, um diese Reiseoptimierungssachen.
Das ist mir jetzt nicht bekannt, wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht,
das scheint nicht auf diesem Kanal zu sein.
Gut, das mal so als Interesse für unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer hier.
So, ich habe noch was zum Rauswurf, wir hatten ja,
Letzte Sendung mal echt die Latte für Hochkultur so richtig wohin geschraubt
und wir hatten noch überhaupt keinen Latein in dieser Sendung und das prangere ich an.
So, keine Angst, ganz so schlimm wird es nicht. Ich habe mal was mitgebracht
und zwar das höchste bisher jemals gescannte Kunstwerk.
Audiodump berichtete.
Was jemals im Rat ist, ist das auch schon vom Rijksmuseum?
Ich habe es wahrscheinlich im gleichen Moment gesehen wie du.
Rembrandt.
Vielleicht lüge ich auch und es steht bloß im Trello und nächste Sendung komme
ich an und sage Scheiße. Okay, also Preakshow berichtete.
Ja, ich habe vielleicht noch ein bisschen Hintergrund dazu. Also erstmal, was ist das Ganze?
Dieses Bild, was die jetzt hier mal wieder, das ist so deren Go-To Ding vom
Rix Museum Amsterdam, mit dem sie immer so ihre ganze Digitalität so ein bisschen
ausprobieren und das ist jetzt quasi der Next Step, den sie haben. Wie viel?
717 Gigapixel und wenn man also maximal reingezoomt hat, dann ist das,
also jedes Pixel ist informationstragend und die Größe eines Pixels ist dann
5 Mikrometer, das ist kleiner als eine menschliche Blutzelle,
schreiben sie in ihrer Textbeschreibung.
Da kann man also wirklich rein und man sieht also noch den allerletzten Riss
in dieser Leinwand entsprechend drin.
Und warum mich das grundsätzlich interessiert.
Ist, dass ich mit denen schon seit vielen Jahren mal immer was zu tun hatte,
weil die halt als Museum so ziemlich, finde ich, weltweit die Ersten waren,
die völlig kompromisslos digital gegangen sind und gesagt haben,
so, alles, was wir irgendwie an coolen Sachen in unserem Museum haben,
das digitalisieren wir in der bestmöglichen Qualität und kippen das völlig frei
und ohne jede Einschränkung ins Internet.
Und das ist quasi unser unique selling point. Und normalerweise ist es so in
der Kulturszene, gerade bei Museen, wenn das alles zu hochauflösend ist,
dann will ja keiner mehr ins Museum und da machen wir uns doch die ganzen Einnahmen
kaputt, was war dann alles nicht mehr an den Kassen und so weiter.
Es ist halt alles Quatsch, wenn man sich halt anguckt,
die Zuschauerinnen zahlen vom Rijksmuseum seit Jahren im Aufflug,
eben weil die einfach auch im Internet vernünftig Werbung für sich und ihre Kunstwerke machen.
Wie haben die denn das gescannt?
Das beschreiben sie hier auf der Seite, das ist also mit einer 100 Megapixel
Hasselblatt H6D 400 MS Kamera.
Ich dachte jetzt made with iPhone.
Zusammengesetzt aus 8.439 Einzelbildern.
Wie haben sie denn diese Kamera bewegt? Haben sie da so einen Roboter damit beauftragt?
Ja, das sieht man da so rechts. Da gibt es also einen Rechts?
Also hier auf der Seite von dem Link, den ich gerade eben gegeben habe,
da sieht man so einen Ausschnitt.
Ich meine, ich hätte auch irgendwo ein Video davon gesehen, wo man das in Bewegung sieht, das Ganze.
Also die dokumentieren das dann auch relativ gut. Da kann man sich also auf
deren Seite einfach mal durchklicken.
Okay, das Bild ist auch groß.
Okay, das ist irgendwie vier Meter hoch oder so?
Genau, im Original ist es groß. Es ist insofern interessant,
als dass irgendwie Details mal verschütt gegangen sind, die sie versuchen digital
zu rekonstruieren und sowas. Also das ist diese Nachtwache.
Und das hat es schon in diversen Iterationen bei denen immer so auf die Startseite gebracht.
Nach dem Motto so, wir haben wieder was Neues erfunden und guck mal hier unser Standardbild quasi.
Und das ist jetzt deren letzte Iteration. Aber Rijksmuseum finde ich immer eine
gute Adresse für mal etwas Mut haben im Kulturbereich,
Dinge online zu machen und einfach mal maximal denkbare Qualität und darüber
hinaus einfach ins Internet schütten. Das wird schon gut gehen.
Daniel hat gut zugehört und sagt, ich hätte vorhin QED gesagt,
es sei also doch Latein in der Sendung vorgekommen. Ich sag, alle Jagd ist gesund.
Also 5,6 Terabyte ist die Datei groß.
925.000 mal 775.000 Pixel.
Falls man sich übrigens fragt, wie kann man das denn alles überhaupt im Internet irgendwie zeigen?
Also bei dem Link, den ihr in den Shownotes findet,
landet man erstmal so auf dem Grundbild und dann kann man halt so Stück für
Stück weiter reinzoomen und das nimmt halt gar kein Ende und man zoomt und zoomt
und es hat jetzt nicht die ganzen Daten gleichzeitig jetzt irgendwie hier im Browserspeicher drin,
sondern man kann das gut vergleichen mit Google Earth.
Ich wollte auch gerade sagen, was ist das wieder für eine Schande,
dass sowas wie die Space-Maus kein Standard-Input-Device ist,
in dem man einfach mit einer Bewegung da reinzoomen und rumrotieren und drüberfliegen kann.
Hast du die eigentlich mal da? Das muss man nicht jetzt machen,
aber nach der Sendung. Ich will dieses Ding seit Jahren hören.
An jedem Computer habe ich hier eine dran.
Gut, also kurz den technischen Gedanken zu Ende. Also Google Earth ja auch zusammengesetzt
aus tausenden und abertausenden von Luftbildern,
die zusammengestitcht sind und je nachdem wie man rein und raus zoomt,
werden die Sachen dann halt einfach nur in den Browser nachgeladen und reingestreamt
und zusammengesetzt, ohne dass man was davon mitbekommt.
Und ich hatte immer mal das Konzept, das mal mit gescannten Büchern zu machen,
dass du also so eine klassische Bibel hast, schön illustriert und die Bibel
ist ein sehr strukturiertes Dokument, wo du diese ganzen Bücher hast.
Und meine Idee war immer, jedes Buch der Bibel ist quasi eine Spalte und dann
die einzelnen Seiten sind dann halt die Zeilen unten drunter.
Also solche Visualisierung gibt es auch schon, aber ich hätte dann gerne was
gehabt, wo man halt wirklich völlig frei so rein und raus fliegen konnte,
um also so die Bibel mal so als quasi auf ein einziges aufgeblättertem Riesenboden.
So eine Datenwolke, wo du visuell sehen kannst, Buch Johannes viel größer.
So und so lang, genau.
Da war ich auch kurz davor, das mal zu bauen. Da war ich noch in Göttingen,
aber aus irgendwelchen Details.
Und da hatten wir als Framework eben dann genau, Sea Dragon hieß das damals.
Das war dann so eine Abwandlung von quasi so einer Technologie,
wie sie Google Earth dann auch einsetzt.
Aber naja, vielleicht macht das irgendwann nochmal jemand.
Tja, im Sendegate gibt es bestimmt irgendeinen Kanal dazu. Oh,
jetzt der Tim fliegt über.
Fliegt schon wieder in.
Fliegt schon wieder, aha. Es sieht sehr fliegig aus. Ja, wir wollen es mit Apple
Maps. Achso, Apple Maps ist doch jetzt im Web.
Geht das jetzt mit der Space Mouse? Ist der Traum wahr geworden?
Ach, Quatsch. Ne?
Ja, eine bekannte Bibelvisualisierung. Dann sind wir jetzt aber wirklich...
Haben wir unseren Kulturauftrag auch erfüllt.
Das hier ist...
Tim, jetzt lass doch mal dein Gefliege da durch Berlin.
Das sieht man alles gar nicht.
Das ist ein Audio-Podcast.
Alles, was auf dem Bildschirm stattfindet.
Existiert nicht. Das hat ignoriert zu werden.
Schalt mal um auf den...
Ihr seid so visuell orientiert. Das ist echt euer Problem.
Hauptscreen, okay. Gut, also falls es Bilder in den Kapitelmarken gibt,
könntet ihr jetzt eine Grafik dort sehen, wo ihr die ganze Bibel visualisiert seht.
Jedes Buch der Bibel ist eine Spalte
und nach unten sind dann einfach nur unterschiedlich lange weiße Streifen.
Man sieht also, wie lang sind die verschiedenen Bücher.
Und das Besondere ist, dass dann viele Bücher der Bibel ja aufeinander Bezug
nehmen und sich gegenseitig referenzieren.
Und das ist dann nochmal mit so farbigen Bögen versehen, wodurch dann so ein
sehr anmutiges, regenbogenartiges Dingsee entsteht.
Das ist erstaunlich, ehrlich gesagt, weil es so regelmäßig aussieht.
Also bis auf einen Ausreißer ist jetzt Genesis irgendwie am Anfang genauso viel
wie irgendwo Jesus, wo wahrscheinlich das Neue Testament...
Ja, es gibt schon so ein paar Cluster, die sich da so...
Stimmt, es gibt so breitere graue Balken und irgendwas ist.
Auch diese Bögen, also die Referenzierungen sind wirklich von vorne bis hinten
und mitten quer durch und so.
Das ist ein sehr schönes Kapitelbild wäre das.
Ich poste da auch mal noch die Seite zu.
Korrekt in den Metadaten erfasst.
Ist von 2019 diese Visualisierung.
Was ist dieses lange Pimmelchen da in der Mitte?
Musst du mal nachgucken.
Da ist Mohammed zu den Sebanier abgestiegen und da sagt, du kommst hier nicht vorbei.
Aha. Ja, schön.
So.
Klappe zu, Affe tot oder was?
Haben wir es?
Ich denke, das war es jetzt mit dieser Sendung. Die ist ja auch schon lang genug.
Wir haben jetzt eine sehr lange Sendung gemacht und das ist ja auch richtig
so. Ihr wollt ja was zu hören haben.
Der Maik ist ja auch weit gekommen zu uns, weit gereist. Dann soll es sich auch mal lohnen.
Für jeden Meter, zwei Minuten.
Aha.
Ja, dann steht es mir an dir, Danke zu sagen für deine Beteiligung, Malik.
Gerne, ich sag danke. Großer Spaß immer.
Nächstes Mal hören wir uns dann mal an, was Roddy alles Wildes in der Ukraine erlebt hat.
As we speak dürfte er sich gerade auf der Rückreise befinden,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
He made it out alive.
Wobei er muss ja mit Zug fahren, das heißt, es kann sein, dass er in Deutschland hängen bleibt.
Schauen wir mal, wie weit er kommt. So, dann sagen wir Tschüss hier an alle.
Vielen Dank für eure Begleitung im Chat, für eure Begleitung in den Kommentaren und auch sonst.
So, toll, dass es euch gibt.
Und wir klicken uns jetzt aus. Tschüss, bis bald.